sit here and say you're gonna let's make it happen. Let's make
it happen.
Hi. Come on.
They come and say like probably, "Hey, it's the middle of the
night. The This is This is the person who's going to beat Zena
fight." Okay. Security shows up. Imagine it's not even the cops,
but security shows up. And this is the This is the energy switch.
Okay. Hi,
bro. Imagine if Zena was doing this rant. The energy she'd have
for security if they showed up.
The content police
angeling for a job clipboard in his hand while Kelly's just
uh Trump decided to straight up drop an uh an Fbomb today. Okay.
What the Iran violated the peace agreement in the So apparently
people were accusing Iran of violating the ceasefire agreement.
Do you believe that Iran is still committed to cease? Yes. They
violated but Israel violated it too. Israel is committed. Israel
as soon as we made the deal they came out and they dropped a
load of bombs the likes of which I've never seen before. The
biggest load that we've seen. I'm not happy with Israel. You
know when when I say okay now you have 12 hours. You don't go
out in the first hour and just drop everything you have on them.
So, I'm not happy with them. I'm not happy with Iran either.
But I'm really unhappy if Israel is going out this morning because
the one rocket that didn't land that was shot perhaps by mistake
that didn't land. I'm not happy about that. You know what? We
have We basically have two countries that have been fighting
so long and so hard away. Damn.
Damn. I sent sent you the muppets. Damn. Yeah, I got it. I got
it. Where is Okay, I'll fix it right now. Howard just dropped
everything.
I'm not happy with them. I'm not happy with Iran either. But
I'm really unhappy if Israel is going out this morning because
the one rocket that didn't land that was shot perhaps by mistake
that didn't land. I'm not happy about that. You know what? We
have We basically have two countries that have been fighting
so long and so hard that they Discord site is not working. So,
GG. I tried, Kelly. I can't I I appears I can't upload anything.
What the heck? No. Is it just Yeah, the the reactive Discord
is just broken right now, unfortunately. So, I can't I can't
set that up for you right now. Soon, soon.
Wild talking about Israel and he dropped the fbomb. I mean, is
he really talking about Israel at all? Antonio Brown has apparently
fled the country. Guys, if you remember, Antonio Brown was the
guy who fired shots
at the Aiden Ross boxing event. Former borderline Hall of Fame
NFLer. Okay, this guy almost certainly could have made the N
the Hall of Fame. This guy was a prolific, like the best wide
receiver in football for like 5 years in a row. And
he is
so lost. He says, "I'm out of I'm out the country. Ain't no more
child support. Tell your mama get a job." Damn. Damn.
That about his own kids.
Yeah, he's definitely bragging about being a dead beat dad right
now. Yeah. Dear God.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. That's
Oh, not cool. Not cool, Antonio. Not cool at all. What the hell?
Not even borderline. If he wasn't mentally ill, he'd be in. Yeah,
he's like I'm saying he's borderline first ballot and I think
there was still like a glut at wide receiver, but he he was just
like the best in football for like and like it wasn't close at
all. The other crazy thing is I don't think he got lit the up.
Like yeah, okay, the perfect hit was bad, but I don't think he
he usually didn't get like lit the up. He was a really crisp
route runner. He never I I don't think he got caught squarely
all that much. Right. It had to be Yeah. Well, it had to be like
the perfect hit. People basically had to catch him like in the
process basically. Like if he's going up for a catch. Uh yeah,
if he's going up for a catch, you'd have to hit him before he
had the ball. You guys disavow him. I don't know, man. If he
was a receiver for my team, I'd probably have a hard time. He
certainly won me a lot of money in fantasy football. This guy
was I played PPR leagues. This guy was like a number one pick
like multiple years for me. People just wouldn't pick him and
then I get him and then he'd just be like the highest scorer
in the league. Okay. Easy, easy points every time. He was out
of his mind. Anyway, all right. Being a deadbeat dad in 2025
is embarrassing. Is he naked? I don't think he's naked. No, this
is like a bronze statue of him or something. Is him as a bronze
statue with a massive bulge.
Apparently, apparently they decided to do that. You cannot call
him a deadbeat dab when you don't even cover how much he was
required to pay. Uh, yeah, I can. He literally just said he literally
just said, "I'm not paying you money." That's not I don't need
need to know how much he was ordered to pay. She's just like,
"I'm not paying you anything." That's a deadbeat dad. Massive.
I mean, okay. Noticeable bulge. Pants are like struggling to
contain. Yay is paying half mil per month. That's probably appropriate.
How would it not be appropriate for Yay to pay a half mil per
month? Wouldn't that be That just sounds appropriate to me. Kim's
got money. That is ridiculous. No, it's not. Kim's got money.
They both got money. Kim's not getting like insane money from
him. It's just it's literally like you're covering about half
of the kid's expenses. That's basically all it is. Why do we
pretend it's something else? A child did not cut does not cost
that. Yes.
Kim Kardashian and Kanye West child cost that much to raise.
Kim Kim don't need the money, bro. That's like so he can cover
half of the expenses for their kid. I guarantee you they go to
the best private school in the USA or some [__] and
they go on trips all the time and they've got like insane designer
clothes that Kanye would want them to have, right? Code Maxer.
Yes, but that child is growing up with privilege either way.
That child should be growing up with privilege. That's like that's
like the bare minimum for Kanye to be spending. It's insane if
you don't understand that. Why send his son? Well, I don't think
it's his son, right? It's his kid. I I I thought his kid I thought
he had a girl little girl with Kim. Am I crazy? Play the merk
clip. Oh, I didn't do subreddit review. True.
No, there's a bunch of stuff in the subreddit that I probably
wanted to look at, right? I think I think there's a bunch of
stuff. I grabbed this to actually watch. Uh, what is this? There's
an aristocracy 8 minute 30 second aristocracy clip. God, don't
be bad. Don't be that bad. Casey, these chatters. I saw Kelly
pop up in my city's Bumble. Ask Kelly if she's single. Are you
guys okay? Uh, no. They're not okay. That's probably why they're
chatting like that. Doesn't sound like they're okay, Kelly. It
sounds like they're kind of crazy to me. Sounds like you're getting
catfished.
Sounds like they're not doing well out there. Okay.
All right. We're good to go. On to content for today. So, there's
a couple space ghost clips. Uh, I'll do the space ghost clips.
I'll do we'll go space ghost. We'll go into what? Merk off the
park. probably quite a bit of this stuff. We can we can just
roll through a couple of these right off the bat. So, this is
uh Casey Tron. Bro, Casey Tron's been a little bit funny. Okay,
as as gross as Caseyron is, she's been a little funny. She I
She knows like once you understand her only goal is to upset
people. It's like, oh, well, she's actually quite good at it.
I'm sorry. She'd been quite good at it, right? She's kind of
like she kind of really funny, but she's just people off. Yeah,
degenerate pads earned me too. Uh, green screen probably. Oh,
Casey Tron takes shots at Destiny and DJers during Ethan lawsuit
response.
Like I understand that like like it's like there's a lot of people
that I don't like too, but I don't think that they're like I
don't think that they deserve to be locked up and have their
entire life ruined,
you know? Like, you know what I mean? Yeah, I know what you mean.
I know exactly. Besides Destiny, I do think he should be locked
up. I swear to God, I didn't know I was pausing at that exact
moment. That's Wait, but also true, but also true. So, Oh, so
good. So good. And if you're a fan of Destiny in here, um, like,
leave me alone. You guys have been harassing me for 5 years.
Like, has it been more than 5 years now? Like, oh my god, I'm
so sorry that I clock Destiny being a sociopath like 5 years
before anyone else.
Like, why am I being attacked? Like, you can like even his viewers
know he's a sociopath. Like, even the fans of him know he's a
sociopath. Like, I'm so sorry for clocking the truth. Like, you
guys can stop harassing me now. It's been 5 years. Only five
more years and not will get there, too. Only five more. Steven's
like really good. like really really good guys. Let's take Okay,
what is this one? This one is We probably did see this potentially.
Okay, it's sloppy. It's This was a hit piece. Pisco reacts to
Ethan's lawsuits. I'm I'm going to check it out cuz um I do think
we watched this one. This will update Kelly a little bit in case
you didn't catch this back in even bigger picture. The notion
that, and this is not even disputable at this point, that H3
is acting like a savior for the fair use community, the reaction
community is so preposterous.
Yeah. As to be insulting to my intelligence.
They're calling Pisco a socialist now. Yeah. Full of hell. I
don't know if you caught it. We did. That was the I think one
of the last segments I did was just going over some of the people
responding to Pisco and Lykan and like Straighter Aid streams
with Pisco a decent amount. I think they do like reacts to random
content together, right? They'll both fire up their stream. They'll
both stream like a react together, which is cool, but I think
people are like, "Oh, well actually he does content with Straight
now, so he's a socialist." And it's like one, I'm pretty sure
his existing partner was already pretty left-leaning. Okay, so
like if you're going to just say Pisco's by like a woman, you
could at least say his actual partner's name who's very po who's
like does politics on her own, has like a channel with like a
bunch of big videos on it, tons tons of subs, right? Like if
you're going to say that, you shouldn't even give it to Straight
Raid for one thing, but people do. And it's like it's just clearly
when they say that it's clearly just DGers who are like mad about
straight raid and Lykan because that's the only reason you would
think that. Yeah. It's because Yes. It's because he's criticizing
H3. Absolutely. Yeah. And I believe it actually is a bit of disingenuousness
to start off with this broader concern about the quote injustice
regarding these kinds of streams that basically steal content
and don't transform the nature of the content at all or provide
any commentary.
to start with that view to show XQC be one of the prime suspects,
one of the biggest purveyors and then to try to distinguish and
say this is really about helping the reaction community to prevent
a kind of a lawsuit from which by the way is the first line of
the Denim's lawsuit, right? That this is meant to prevent lazy
reacts, but that's not what he's trying to do at all. It's not
even remotely what he's trying to do. Disney or Sony, that is
so disingenuous and it's just false. It doesn't pass the smell
test at all. I resent it. Yeah, it's Oh, thank you. Yeah, it's
gross. It's gross. You're gross. And then second point, the complaint's
unhinged. You have a strong case. Just present the case. Don't
be a loser idiot. Hire some lawyer who either doesn't know what
he's doing or
you're telling him to do this kind of unhinged [__]
It's sloppy. Tons of typos, formatting errors. It's impossible
to read. It's [__] So if you really cared about protecting
the reaction community, you wouldn't use that filing, dude. You
wouldn't do that. Filled with venom, filled with, you know, not
getting to the facts, not getting to the point. This was a hit
piece in the form of a legal filing. And maybe even it's even
true on some base accusations. But don't pretend you're here
for the broader reaction community when you file that piece of
[__] You're not doing anyone any help. You don't
think anything would settle with a symbol of public apology?
Of what? Hold on. Um, the code max guy, you're really dumb. You're
going to like actually trigger me. The reaction community. You
can't say the reaction community when your number one defense
of your lawsuit is, "I'm trying to help the reaction community."
And the the point of the criticism is Ethan is a disingenuous
loser.
Like, we're calling him disingenuous. We're pointing out the
obvious problem of him saying he's protecting the reaction community
while not taking steps to do that. And then people are like,
"Well, the reaction community." I Okay, then you should also
call Ethan Klein a disingenuous loser. Thank you. Cool. I'm sorry
for what? That's the question, right? And it's the it's a great
question, right? What is What are they sorry for? What does Ethan
want them to be sorry for? He doesn't want them to be sorry for
Thank you for the membership. He doesn't want them to be sorry
for copyright infringement. That's not what's going on here.
And you have to be very like naive to think that that's what
they would want an apology for. I'm sorry for stealing your video.
XQC stole your video. He's not actually mad about that. He's
mad about these people because of who they are, not what they
did or what they did. Is the reaction community malicious? Not
a relevant point because it's not the first line of the lawsuit.
The first line of the lawsuit is about protecting the reaction
the the community, the commentary community from lazy reactions
causing like a a downstream effect. That is the first thing on
other stuff, not this. That's it. What do you want to say? Both
is the answer to the question. That's it. That's it. All right.
Cool. Okay. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. So, there's an Aerys
clip. We will watch the Aerys clip first. I'm going to watch
this Merc clip because Ry wants me to watch the mercip you. I'm
going to you. So, this is
M. By the way, disavow. Totally. This is MK talking about Zena
apparently. So, you know what? You know what? That's fine. As
long as I get my That's fine as long as I get my hands on you.
But I will get my hands on you and I will finally teach you a
lesson. Dina, I'm on I'm on some real I'll you up
talking about Oh, I'mma stab you. I'mma You ain't doing You
Okay, I will say Riyle when you when you want to upload these
things. I don't know if this works. I get I get what you're cooking.
I get that you're trying to do the um you want to pass. I think
if you also put text up, text will get analyzed by YouTube anyway.
So, you probably won't get through sensors,
right? YouTube scans all text on screen and parses it. And if
you have a whole bunch of profanity on stream or on screen, it's
not going to work. So, your bleeping is like kind of pointless
in the first place. I don't post this on YouTube. Are you crazy?
Then why do you have it all censored?
I'm just saying I get Okay, I get why it's censored. Maybe if
you want me to watch it on Twitch or something, but I'm just
saying that like the censorship might not make as much sense
if you're not going to push it and with the text. I don't know.
It's fine. I your man and you're up about it. I on your man.
He drank my you. Oh my god. I Why would you brag about that?
Gross. She just said She just said
pissed on. Okay. Sidonia is moving away from the Twitch chat.
Guys, don't forget twitch.tv/jlk
with an underscore. We're live on Twitch as well. All right.
Oh my god. That's where we are. We're over there. We're uh hold
on.
three lawsuit coverage. Sorry, I need to do better better titles
on Twitch, I think. But guys, don't forget about the Twitch.
Okay, we're over there. We're on both. Rick is so dumb for this.
She knows she can't fight. Well, she's saying that she in Darus
Darius's mouth, which is kind of up. Okay. I don't know why you
would out that detail. That seems like like you're not even hurting
Zena the most. You're kind of hurting Darius. You're outing a
thing about Darius. What are we doing here? your man and you're
up about it. I on your man. He drank my you. Oh my god. I caught
down. I on your man and he drank my You stupid. You Yeah. Yeah.
You're mad because your man drank my You're mad because this
is very gross. Your man drank my He drank my
These people are so mad. Your man drank my Your man drank my
You
man drank my Yeah, he drank my And you're mad. You're mad. said,
"Your Your man drank my Your man drank my Your man drank my You
stupid." Yeah, he I
just kind of She needs to She needs to up the variation a little
bit. I I feel like after the 10th time it doesn't hit quite as
hard. Okay. I I literally stood over his face and I all over
him and he drank my stupid
Wendy's. What? Dude, you you can see her. You can actually see
her reliving the moment like as she talks through this. You can
see it in her eyes that she's reliving that moment of like looking
down on Darius and just like, "Yeah, I
literally stood over him." She She's like, she can see him. She's
projected him in her mind onto the ground there. Okay, which
she can do cuz she is like 3 ft taller than Darius. All right.
Darius was standing full up beside her and she still did this.
Okay, that's how much taller Murk is than Darius face and I all
over him,
dude. The the eyes like just Oh, this frame this frame right
here goes like hard if it wasn't blurry and they all go hard
all over him and he drank my
Okay, it's not it's not a funny it's not a funny comment most
of the time, but when it comes to the TTS at that perfect moment,
okay, it is funny. Only thing I want is to give your ass the
black eye is to put my hands on you. And I have been begging
and begging and begging. And you know what's true? Oh, I'm going
to you. I'm going to you. So, you know what? You I'm sorry. Merc
is like way bigger than Zena. Okay. Way way bigger than Zena.
Ain't nobody on planet Earth taking Murk in a fight. If they
actually get in any physical altercation, there are zero people
on the planet of Earth who would take MC over Zena in a fight.
Okay. I think she got punched the other week, didn't she? Merc.
Yeah,
Zena is like a honey badger. Okay. You just You would not You
would not bet a M. You know what? That's fine. As long as I get
my If If you me, you me that's fine. That's fine. That's fine.
As long as I get my hands on you, but I will get my hands on
you and I will finally teach you a lesson because your cat sits
on the internet talking about all these people. You need to be
taught a lesson. You need to be taught that you can't just sit
here and say all this without getting with getting away with
it. You're not going to get away with it. You're not going to
get away with it. I have been begging and begging and begging.
It's your karma is coming for you. You will finally learn a lesson.
Whether or not I die, whether or not you beat this money, that's
fine. As long as I get my This is just some crazy fanfiction
fantasy.
Okay. Shower arguments 101. Hands on you because you're not getting
away with this. You are not getting away with it. I don't give
a I don't give a if I lose my KCIP. I don't give a You You literally
sat here and begged. Oh, no cameras. Uh, no police, no this,
no that. I don't give a I will, Zena. I'm telling you right now,
I'm going to get my hands on you. That's why I in your man's
mouth and I'll in his mouth again
his mouth every Let's be real. That's probably true. It's probably
true that she will do it again. Like, let's be 100% honest with
ourselves, with everybody. That's almost certainly gonna happen
again. Single day of my life. And he liked it, too. And he drank
that
all over him. And guess what? Guess what? Guess what? He drank
my
you.
Yeah. Is this the same clip or like It's not. It's not. She just
keeps saying it over and over and over again at the camera. I
just over and over. We're only halfway through the clip and it
feels like too many.
I will you up. Come over right now. Come over right now. You
stupid.
I in your man's mouth. He drank He drank my urine.
Why would anyone brag about this? I just I in your man's mouth.
Cry about it. You I don't know.
I What's up here? In your man's mouth. You were in what? I just
don't find any of these men attractive. I will forever be safe.
She's I in your man's mouth.
I in your man's mouth and you can't do about it. I all over him.
I I gave him my urine. I gave him my urine and you're not going
to do about it. You're not going to do about it. Like in a jar
as well or save for later? You're not going to do about it. Come
right now. Come right now and I'll I will queue up. I will
Yeah. Drama 101, you're gone for a little bit. Okay. You can
come back in 30 minutes. You need to you need to go and think
about your life. So, you got a 30-minute timeout. Good luck.
Come back later. Do you want I'm not reading it. Letting everyone
on the internet. I in your man's mouth. Can't do about it. So,
next time you kiss him, taste my And you
Oh, that's gross and cold and gross and cold. Every every time
Zena is talking to Darius, just imagine.
Okay, imagine Darius's breath here. Okay, Zena's probably into
it. Imagine apparently also apparently Darius's head got shaved.
I might have to watch some highlights from the Ice Boseidon cuz
Darius is now
shaved like a monk or some [__] I don't know what
the Isn't there a Tekken character with that kind of hair?
Uh, Heihachi has way cooler hair than that. Yeah, you think of
Heihachi, but it's all up instead of down. Yeah, this is uh this
is crazy. I thought somebody made this with AI. I didn't think
this was real. I didn't think it was real at all. But yeah, Darius
is uh Yeah, he's having he's having a time. He's having a time.
Oh boy. Because I in his mouth, you
you. We're getting close, Kelly. We're one minute out from the
end. Here's the thing. You can sit here and talk all this. For
one, you're jealous because I Your man. Was he quit? Darius quit.
Oh, too bad. Apparently, lots of apparently it's just like these
events are just people signing up to be tortured. Like, it's
just fun ways to torture people. It's uh it's brutal. In his
mouth. Um, you're jealous because I get more attention for doing
less than what you're doing than you're mad about it because
you realize, oh, I'm a I'm a you are realizing you're in and
you're a and I don't have to do half the you do to get attention.
Says the person that was just talking about drinking for Yeah.
I don't I don't Well, no, no, no. Somebody else logic. No, no,
no. Not not drinking. Okay. The other person was drinking her.
I don't Oh, is she at a hotel for this in the middle of the night?
Out here at a hotel in the middle of the night. I don't have
to do half the in order to get what I Oh, also Zena does get
like 500 viewers most of the time. I've gotten I haven't had
to give up. Nope. What have you given up to get what you've gotten?
And you want to sit here and talk about, oh, you're more important
than me and you get more collabs than me. Yeah, because you give
up your name one person besides Darius that I you can't because
you give up your you give up everything to get a single crunk
in here in life to get your I don't know why I don't know why
she even say this.
Yeah, it's and realistically I don't know about a whole bunch
of other people maybe. But like I've I haven't heard that accusation
from basically anybody but Merc in prison forever as long as
you don't have a career. All right, you're going to you're going
to you're going to me. All right, let's see it. Let's see it.
I'm willing to give up my life so you ain't have for the rest
of your life. You that's not acting like you have more to lose
than Zena or that you're better than Zena. You're like, "Yeah,
my life's so that if you me, I'll just be happy knowing you went
to jail." That's But she's also like, "You're a loser. You suck."
Okay, I got to send one more clip of like apparently this is
in the middle of the night at the pool at her apartment and they
don't like that. Okay, hold on. Come you want to sit here and
say you're going to me and me. Let's make it happen. Let's make
it happen.
Come on.
They come and say like probably, "Hey [__] it's the
middle of the night. The are you doing ranting out here in the
pool getting drunk? You're not even supposed to have alcohol
out here. What are you doing?" Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Embarrassing,
baby. This is This is the person who's going to beat Zena and
fight. Okay. Security shows up. Imagine it's not even the cops,
but security shows up. And this is the This is the energy switch.
Okay. Hi, bro. Imagine if Zena was doing this rant. The energy
she'd have for security if they showed up. Probably just the
building man. It might be the building manager. Yeah, that's
just very funny. It's just very funny. Damn. Okay, I got sent
a clip of Zena bear masoning Darius.
Apparently, this happened. You want to hurt the person that you
once loved? I went easy on you. I should have been on here. Oh,
they got steak odds for everybody. They got Darius and Shuy still
going,
Serious. How much money did Darius get? Did Darius get money
to shave his head like this? Or did they do that to everybody?
Oh, they did it to everybody. Everybody's got goofy hairstyles.
Okay. It's supposed to be in your eye.
Oh, boy. More or is that enough? All she does is cause pain to
your life. There is no benefit at all for you and her. Okay.
Thank you, Ice Poseidon. Coming in with like the voice of God
from above. Okay.
Darius. Darius, there is no benefit to either of you in this
relationship. Please listen. Please listen. Little do they know,
Darius, the voice was like, "Darius, Darius, Darius, Darius,
Darius, Darius, what are you doing? What are you do?" I'm trying
to be a Destiny. I can't do it. Uh, high pitch, very fast speaking.
That would be the voice that Darius would listen to as if it
were God. Okay. How shallow that cast of car characters for Ice?
Well, I think a lot of those people for Ice Poseidon like they
know that this was advertised as like basically torturing people.
Yeah, Ice does kicker keep where he wins every time. Why would
you enter his contest? He's a Okay. Uh, all right. Spends the
next two hours in pain. It's hilarious. Is it hilarious? Maybe
it is. It might be. Okay. We got the Aerys clip. Oh, we got a
couple things. If you're going to defend Denims for 3 hours,
it's time to walk the walk. What is this and dislike the video?
The Where's the Denim's defense for 3 hours? Um, did I get linked
to time stamp or Oh, no. I don't have to watch this. I don't
have to watch this because it was very kind of Ethan Ply to point
out that like she actually gave substantial commentary the whole
time. He pointed out all the time stamps. You don't have to watch
it. You can just go look at the lawsuit. The lawsuit doesn't
claim that she did not substantially react to this. The lawsuit
claims that her reaction, her commentary was bad. That's what
the lawsuit claims. Yeah, it's it's actually just such garbage.
It's very embarrassing for Ethan Klein and all involved. Yes,
Ethan deceptively edited the video to make it look like Denim's
chair reacted to that whole thing when that was not the case.
Is Discord React still scuffed? Is Discord React still? Oh, I
have no idea. I can check it in a little bit. Okay. Uh Ry, they're
both a part of the lawsuit, but he is suing for both, right?
He is suing for both. And his the way he frames it in his video
as if this is is ish is as if it's about the content nuke when
it's not. But there's also all of the commentary from the content
nuke, the things he disagrees with, that's all in the in the
lawsuit as well. The the stream is probably only there so that
he could frame it this way. That's actually he probably realized
that when he was trying to frame it, it actually goes really
poorly for him. So he registered the stream to go, "Oh, I want
to include the chair part." That's that seems like the most likely
option to me. Possibly something different, but I don't see what
else. He's not suing anybody else or he's uh what is he not doing?
He's like he's he didn't need that for anybody else, right? I'm
I'm pretty confident that's the case. Would love to see if anybody
ever asks him that. Okay. All right. All right. All right. Darius
dropped out today. Yeah, I heard that that Darius dropped out
today. Are we watching Are we watching? Um
I I'm trying to get Aristocracy to come on stream to talk about
stuff to Okay, so I don't know. I don't know if I want to watch
this and like totally disagree if it's like hyperdefensive of
uh of Ethan Klein. I Well, also aggression against Israel. Yeah.
No, I'm not going to watch that if it's about Israel. Nope. Nope.
Nope. Are we just sticking our head in the sand, are we? Uh,
no. That's going to be about
What are you What are you going to do when they actually come
on stream and then you disagree? Uh, disagree politely. So, you
can't disagree politely on stream without them here.
No. What do you mean no? You can only be an Because it's going
to say things that I'm going to be like, "This is insane to me."
Um, the joke that I This is It's going to feel insane. It's going
to feel I and I Friday night. Listen, I've had I've I've looked
at Aerys's commentary before and I I'm like, this is not realistic.
I don't think this is realistic at all. I No, I'm just wondering
why you have
reserve when someone's in the room, but you can't have the reserve
when they're not here. It's like, can't you just pretend they're
here if that's what you're worried about? I can I can direct
I can like ask questions. When I can't ask questions and they
keep compounding their statements over and over again, that's
where it gets frustrating, right? If I could if she like made
an assertion, I could immediately pause her and go like, "Hey,
wait, wait, wait, wait. Can we walk through that?" Then it's
different, right? But if I'm going to have to watch her like
walk through things over and over and
true. uh if I have to like listen to her talk about and I know
what it's going to be about because it's about like anti-semitism
in Canada, which I'm just like, "Brother, sister, what are we
doing? What are we doing?" Was um they were so grateful that
their um their neighbor um their neighbor was not a Zionist because
otherwise they would be trying to steal their water and their
land. Everyone laughed at that.
Wait, what? Um the joke that I heard Friday night was um they
were so grateful that joke she heard Friday night is in eastern
and western Canada very very different.
Uh yep. Yep. Not that different. Their um their neighbor um their
neighbor was not a Zionist because otherwise they would be trying
to steal their water and their land. Everyone laughed at that.
Mention literally neighbor. So yeah for do you know what it Yeah.
I I'm sorry. I don't really expect Muslims to uh I don't really
expect Muslims to differentiate there to be honest like at the
current it was like to watch hostages friends of my family members
and stuff um on videos like around um being stored in areas with
bags that have wait she watched videos of her family members
being held hostage by labels on organizations I'd raised money
for that's gonna that mean
I okay I friends of family members with bags from aid organizations.
Okay, I would say probably you don't know what happened with
the aid from those organizations if it was stolen. It's all about
this. It's like right like we don't know what happened with the
aid could be stolen from those organizations. You don't know
and then it's just bags, right? It could be taken from anywhere.
I don't know that that means like fundraising for Palestine is
always bad. And um but I need to get out. I need to get out of
my situation. It's not good. It's really bad, you know. So, I
don't have much of a choice. Um, and I can't People are like,
"Oh, like leave leave Canada." It's like, "Where do you want
me to go?" My other option is first of all, I She's saying her
situation in Canada is bad. I'm because of one joke and something
to do with aid that didn't happen in Canada, I assume.
Or what was that then? Uh, I think she's she basically feels
like it's incred like Canada is disgustingly anti-Semitic. I
believe because of one joke and one issue with the crimes like
I think one of the things that happened around her was people
people might have painted like swastikas on like a bagel shop
or something. I saw a post about that. There's been like some
things where people might have been like attacked on some basis,
but it's like it's not really any different than anywhere else
in terms of like you'd probably have about an equal chance of
being hate crimes for being just about anything. I just I don't
believe that are at like some sort of like out they're not at
like some insanely outlying position where they're way way way
more likely to be hate crime in some way. I just don't believe
that. Right. Like I'm sorry. Who who would you rather be in Canada?
Question for the class for everybody here. Would you rather be
an Indian man in Canada or a female in Canada? That's not close
to me. That's not remotely close. I know which one I'd pick every
single day of the week. Okay. It's not close at all. Okay. In
terms of the amount of like racism and and uh prejudice you're
going to face, it's not close. mostly from you. No, not from
me. I'm just saying that like Indian people get like a ton of
hate here and that's I would be way more concerned. Now, you
could argue that they're a way bigger block, so they maybe have
some groups they could live in, but um yeah, and then just to
begin with, on a base level, Canada's like the most racially
accepting place on Earth. Okay, I'm sorry. Just on a base level,
Canada is like so more ac so much more accepting than basically
anywhere else on the planet. It's crazy. I just refuse to believe
that these people like go outside of their house enough for this
to be a legitimate problem. Also, Canada's mostly like ice. Like,
I don't know. Like, what's the likelihood you're really going
to run into someone that's like a problem? It's not mostly ice
where she lives. It is mostly ice. Cold and I don't know. You're
a weird ass country.
Yeah. Yeah. Which way? Um, and I can't penguins. Uh,
aren't penguins only at the South Pole? Damn, that sucks. You're
cold. At the North Pole, I actually don't know. I have no clue.
What do you have at the North Pole? Do you have anything cool?
Um, I mean, polar bears. Yeah, which aren't cool. They're not
cool. Polar bears are psychotic. There are communities where
like they have to be aware of polar bears. Polar bears are crazy.
Polar bears have no penguins that eat them all. Polar bears are
capable of pattern matching in a way that like most other predatory
animals are not. Okay. land predatory animals. Polar bears will
literally stalk humans,
figure out their schedule, and then try to ambush them in places
where they're alone. Like, if you take a every morning at 8:00
a.m. and you walk out to a like a outhouse that's there, a polar
bear will be waiting there to ambush you at like 8:00 a.m. Like,
they will know if I go about this time, I will I will find them
there. And they also don't try to like uh they I think they also
torture their prey. They also just for fun. Like basically if
you run into a polar bear, it will kill you. Polar bears just
operate on like I you no threat to me. I kill you, more food
for me. I kill you, nothing bad happens to me. I you automatic.
I can kill anything. If I see you, I kill you. That's like the
That's what polar bears operate on. Okay. It's nuts. You don't
want to be Polar bears are one of the few animals that regularly
stalk humans as prey and they're hyperaggressive in general.
Yes, exactly. Also, uh there's like a joke about polar bears
that like what do you do if you run into a polar bear in the
wild, uh you take your clothes off and you start running and
you hope that you can freeze to death before it catches you.
Yeah, polar bear is not cool, dude. Okay. Have you seen an arctic
fox? They're really cute. I just Googled animals that are in
the North Pole. Uh there's probably
All right. Uh back to Aerys. Let's see what she's about. She's
about to highlight like some of the reasons she's leaving. We're
good. It's really bad, you know, so I don't have much of a choice.
Um, and I can't People are like, "Oh, like leave leave Canada."
It's like, "Where do you want me to go?" My other options, like,
first of all, I can't go to America. So, the only other option
really be like is moving to Israel. And um, while that's tempting,
I don't know if I want to go without my parents, right? And my
parents might come to be honest. My parents just had almost like
an almost pilgrim in their neighborhood. Was this video? Oh,
before Iran bombed back. So, if I had to guess, this would be
shortly after October 7th. Probably like 2 to 3 months after
October 7th, but I don't know for sure. Riyle, you clipped it.
Where? When is it from? I just I would imagine it's not like
super recent. I'd imagine it's an older VOD cuz I remember her
talking about moving months ago. One year ago. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
Two weeks ago. And and my mom had not been believing anti-semitism
was a real thing anymore and stuff. And like now she suddenly
she was like horrified and now she's like maybe we should go
back. Yeah, it's hell on earth. Well, can we do we know what
the almost pilgrim was? I would love to know. Why did go to cit?
I don't actually testimony about any of this. Um I just thought
it was strange.
Oh, you're talking about like on vacation and like why does No,
like a bunch of them or when they were getting bombed a bunch
of them gone on boats and left a creek. Um, I guess cuz you could,
it's one of the places you could take a boat to. It's like right
there, right off the coast. Just seems weird, huh? Uh, I Googled
it. It was a Palestine protest. Okay. Um, yeah, Laticious Gamer.
I just I think she got I think she was just very biased after
October 7th, which I can kind of understand, but like then I'm
going to criticize basically like I would need to see proof of
what was going on here. That's all. That's my life right now.
Like right now, literally this second I'm negotiating for an
apartment. People be like, "Oh, this this person was canceled
because they were critical of Israel." It's like, you know what
critical of Israel meant? It meant literally denying the rights
of Israeli women. That's not crit Okay, that's not critical of
the government of Israel. Okay, that's called being a bigot and
an So need to stop taking sides so much and criticize everything
that needs um
maybe I don't What is that relevant to that somebody complained?
It sounds like somebody got cancelled or something for for like
what you could you could say they're bigoted opinions, right?
You're going to deny because it's Israelis, right? You could
say they're bigoted opinions. Maybe bigoted on nationality, but
they're bigoted opinions, right? But it sounds like they got
cancelled. It sounds like the levers of society work perfectly
there. Criticism. Yeah, I have a side 100% because I'm Israeli,
right? Cuz I just at the end of the day, I don't want my family
to get killed. Um but I don't expect anyone else to um got to
make that necklace. Yeah. Okay. So I I'm So the way I operate
in Toronto is I I'm on what I call historic. This is the real
historical term from Portugal, right? Oh god. It's going to be
it's going to be something about blending in in a society that
is like hateful towards them that would like hate crime them,
right? And she's doing that in Toronto, Canada. Is I am a um
a crypto in the city. So I wear a ring that says Hebrew and no
one She got a ring. She's got a necklace with a cold storage
wallet on it. Okay. They call her a crypto. Else understands
what it says. And uh and I also have uh I I have a bracelet that
I'll like wear underneath my sweaters or something like that,
but I hide it. I hide it because I know someone who on their
way to university two 3 weeks ago, they're on the subway and
he's wearing they're on the subway in Toronto. He's wearing a
star. Just a normal je.
Now, here's the thing.
I would if I were if I were living in Toronto, I would probably
right after October 7th not wear like Stars of David. I would
probably go like, you know what, it's not worth the hassle. It's
not cuz I think they're going to get attacked. It's not cuz I
think they're going to get punched in the face. It's just I think
if there's somebody who's on the other side, let's say there's
a Palestinian living in Toronto and they see that and they come
to fight with you, argue with you, right? I would expect it to
go to words and I just wouldn't want that at all. I just wouldn't
care for that, right? But like it's not like I would think I'm
going to get like killed or that I think I'm going to get like
some form of insane harassment. I I'm just like yeah I there's
like emotions are running really high. Yeah. I don't want to
I don't want to be involved right now. Now should people have
to hide like that? No. But I would expect that if you somehow
had the demographics flipped you just much more likely to run
into I believe Muslims than
in Canada. Right. If the demographics were flipped I'd feel the
same way. I just wouldn't want to get into arguments. You should
have pride in being people are the best. Well, I'm not Jewish.
I'm Canadian. I'd wear a Canadian flag, but I also live in Canada.
Not nothing Israeli on his shirt. Not that that would justify
it either. And he's just walking around a shirt. Not that that
would justify it. Not nothing Israeli on his shirt. Wait, wasn't
it a Star of David? On the subway. And he's wearing They're on
the subway in Toronto. He's wearing a star. Just a normal like
a necklace. A Star of David. A Star of David. Like the the symbol
on the flag of Israel. I I hope you understand that if you're
like I'm super proud to be you're going to get conflated with
you're going to be conflated with people who are Zionists especially
after that like attack. Yeah. Unfortunately, that's just a totally
reasonable conflation to make. Like it's a reasonable conflation
to make and not only that, it's like an especially
it's an especially expected conflation to be made right after
October 7th. Right. Also, I don't think this would be October
7th. This would be like uh like weeks after the ground operation,
right? It sounds like I'm saying this is like after October 7th
as in like people were mad at for getting terrorist attacks.
No, it was it was the response after weeks or months of the response,
right? It was not it was not just October 7th alone. I should
be very clear on that. It's not nothing Israeli on his shirt.
Not that that would justify it either. And he's just walking
around. Um and this very religious Muslim guy kind of comes up
to him and just starts praying right in front of him. It's like,
okay, you know, whatever. This is a pug. Okay. This Muslim guy
walked up and started praying in front of me. This son of a [__]
Everyone's there a lot of religious people. Have fun. Um and
then he starts looking at his um the star and then he starts
yelling about the gods and children. We're in like the guy I
know's face and he just starts yelling him and then he starts
chasing him down the like down the court and the guy's like running
and eventually guy finds this like these Brazilian soccer players
that defend him. Thank god for Brazilian soccer. Did they Did
they know the break dancing fighting? Did they Did they do capoera?
The Brazilian soccer players
doing like windmills on the ground and defending this Jew. Sounds
like the most story. I don't know. Sounds like a cartoon. I don't
Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. Hey, anti-semite.
Not so fast. Anti-semite. Not so fast.
Not so fast, anti-semite. Not today.
Not today. Absolutely not today.
Ah Jesus.
What is that? That is uh Full of Hell. Gifted up sub to Shabbite.
Thank you very much. Full of hell. Appreciate it, buddy. Appreciate
it. Super cool. Super cool Brazilian guys who started defending
me. Oh, okay. This is, by the way, this is like way too exhausting
to actually do. These guys are supposed to be like experts and
they're not even remotely close to like going at fighting speed.
How is any of this supposed to hit somebody or be like a fighting
technique? It seems more like an art form. I don't know. Whatever.
Whatever. It's fine. Okay, we're back to back to the video. Players,
the true defenders. That was a crazy situation. So, yeah, it's
wild, man. So, yeah, I'm not So, basically something openly LGBT
people experience all the time from super religious people. Yes.
Yeah, that's true. Right. If you like literally I would expect
this to happen in some places. If you like kissed your if you
were a man and you kissed your boyfriend in public, I'd expect
there's a decent chance you get like a lecture from some religious
person, that's like probably wrong, but or women trying to get
an abortion with the aggressive praying of clinics. Yeah, psychos.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Going to wear my sard. My dad's like, "Oh, you
should be proud. You should be proud. You should wear your juice."
It's like, okay, I'm not What? Also, am I crazy or do most Jewish
people call it a star? Is that just an Is that what people call
a star of David? A star? You should wear your star. You're a
You're a proud Jew. You should wear your star. I I will I just
be your painting.
Reban Ruben donated $3.
An AI meme in stream chat for you. D. Okay. Thank you, Reuben
Ruben. I'll check that out after this video or remind me in chat
as well. Not going to be proud after I'm dead. So, no, I just
I'm sorry. That story right there is like the Muslim guy started
praying and and yelling about gods and children or something,
which I totally believe. I believe that could happen, but then
started chasing him down the street for no reason. Why didn't
he just get aggressive right off the bat? Why did he start so
passive? I actually don't understand. I'm going to cover it up.
Every here who is willing to be I I'm just saying that like he
I assume he would get aggressive and talk to the guy directly
right off the bat if it wasn't them having a back and forth.
totally out and proud. Good. I admire you. I admire your bravery,
you know, um, all of that kind of stuff. But, you know, I'm afraid
of anti-semites, man. I'm afraid especially that they I feel
like they could like rip and murder me and then they just go
tweet and be like, "Oh, I just murdered a Zionist."
That's not funny. That's not funny. That's not funny. That's
not funny. I shouldn't laugh. That's not funny. Ever happened
once in Canada? I don't I've never heard of it. I it like if
it did if it did I would imagine it was like somebody who's widely
denounced and like like a psycho like a literally somebody having
like a a psychotic break, right? If something like that I don't
think they'd be going to to brag about it. Yeah, I've never and
like Yeah, I've never heard about this. Nothing like this. It's
like we've Oh,
I think I think she would have gone past a lot of this now. What's
the violent crime rate in Toronto or wherever she is? Uh it's
probably not that high. Like, man, I don't I really actually
don't know. Yeah, I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I
don't know what's happening. Yeah, it's Canada. Like, no. Nobody's
murder murdering somebody and then saying I just did that. That's
just not a thing. That's not a thing
Uh, true. Be very vic. Yes, you can tell. Is this maybe a little
group that doesn't go out that much? is it's like, bro, a sober
Muslim holy person, like a solo a sober religious Muslim person
was chasing them. It wasn't even a crackhead with like a needle
chasing you down the street. Dude, you got the premium experience
right there. Okay, I'll take the I'll take the hyperreligious
Muslim guy any day of the week over the average crackhead in
Canada. Okay, the average methhead, bro. I walk down I walk I
walk downtown where I live, bro. It's crazy. Okay, you just and
you have to do this thing. You have to do this like this like
psychic domination thing where like you have to not show that
you're bothered by them, okay? When they start yelling insane
at you, you have to not show you're bothered by them, right?
You have to keep walking and like not quite acknowledge them,
but not totally ignore them or like pull away from them. You
just have to be like, "Yeah, you keep pushing." Exactly. You
like you Oh, sorry. Full of hell is talking about religious people.
But the tactics apply to both religious people who are yelling
at you and methheads who are yelling at you or crackheads who
are yelling at you. Okay? You're just like you need to play this
game where it's like I'm not scared of you. You're just kind
of like you're slightly annoying but not so annoying that I want
to offend you. Okay? Cuz I swear to God if you get people who
like turn the other way, they'll they pick that up instantly.
Okay? That's like that's like fear to like a crackhead is like
sound to something from um oh what's the what's the John Kazinski
movie? Quiet place. Okay. It's like like they they have like
the sensors. They will they'll pick that up instantly and they
will sprint at you. It's crazy. All right. And then everyone
would love them. There has been like this mass exodus from a
lot of leftist spaces. Oh my god. Just imagine how it is for
gay. Go on the subreddit gay. Okay. and like listen to their
stories. It's awful. Um, and they're all voting conservative.
I I would just love to know for those gay dreams, what do they
get more hate for? Being gay or being queen subre
not cool, not funny, not okay. Uh, rampant rampant rampant homophobia
in this chat right now. You guys all need to settle down. Stop.
Stop. Because it's like even like my trans friends like they
would ra rather lose some of their trans rights and vote conservative
than like have literal pilgrims in their neighborhood and their
family like destroyed. Like there's priorities. It's so sad to
see that there's still so much anti-semitism in the world today.
Yeah. Yeah. For sure. Um but you know what this is what the original
Zionist predicted that there would be times when that there's
a cycle of hatred. Right. If you read the original Zionist literature
that uh that will do very badly and the world loves dead like
when die then they're like oh we feel bad for you. Um, and then
sorry. Oh, that's not funny. That's not funny. That's not funny.
But also, that is like a victim complex on like a level we have
no idea.
And they start doing well. Um, the minute they start doing well,
jealousy forms and then they become like I would say before 5
years ago, it was almost a golden age of in America and Canada
and the West like a golden age. um to the point where we were
almost being a golden age where like literally any comment about
any comment would get you like banned and canceled from everything.
Okay.
You you have negative comments, negative thoughts about the state
of Israel. Uh yeah. No, no, no. You don't get to I can't I can't,
bro. I I'm going to push too far. Okay. Cuz as we all know, light
anti-semitism tends to be very funny and a form of exposure therapy
for certain people. Okay. And I just I'm going to push too far
and it's going to get reallyed up. I don't I'm not actually anti-semitic.
I swear being treated like we are white. Dio Jane, thank you
so much for subscribing, but you just broke the rules. You broke
the rules. I'll have to pay the Timmy tax. So I I don't think
Aerys I don't think Aerys is quite this I don't think she looks
at it the same way anymore. She might she's still like aligned
with uh Israel. I think she still feels like get um outsized
hatred in the West, but I don't think she's quite at like this
stage anymore. Uh and but naturally when Jews start doing well
uh we become the perfect because we're such a minority there's
a bunch of reasons we become like the perfect um scapegoat and
such a good example of this is how like leftists make the Palestine
Israel issue into an everything issue. Now you can be extremely
pro at Palestine and extremely anti-Israel and that's does not
mean you're an anti-semite. Not not I don't believe that at all.
Um especially if you're connected personally to it like as like
a Palestinian or something like of course I totally get that
but okay so what does she think the religious guy was? Uh but
when you see comments like we won't have all rights no one will
have rights until Palestinians have rights or like or like that's
it was a clip but like Uh-huh. Okay.
Um the joke that oh why did this just reset? What the or like
the Israel issue is an environmental issue. a bunch of reasons.
We become like the perfect um scapegoat. And such a good example
of this is how like leftists make the Oh, Palestine Israel issue.
We were a little before it was in America and Canada and the
West like a golden age. Um to the point where we were almost
being treated like we were white. Dioynes, thank you. So,
you were being treated like you were white. That's that's literally
like literally nobody knows most people are Jewish. Especially
in Canada, they'll never know you're in Canada unless you outright
tell people because you just look white and they're a bunch of
white people and not that many people. Like in America, there
are enough Jewish people, especially in some cities, that they
might actually be able to tell you're, right? In Canada, they
will never know you're unless you point that out yourself. Yeah.
I mean, this is the whole point of her like having to wear her
like star or whatever, right? to show pride or whatever. Like
they you are just white. You would still be there. So much for
subscribing. But you just broke the rules. You broke the rules.
I'll have to pay the Timmy tax. So uh and but naturally when
Jews start doing well uh we become the perfect because we're
such a minority. There's a bunch of reasons. We become like the
perfect um scapegoat. And such a good example of this is how
like leftists make the Palestine Israel issue into an everything
issue. Now, you can be extremely pro at Palestine and extremely
anti-Israel and that's does not mean you're an anti-Semite. Not
not I don't believe that at all. Um especially if you're connected
personally to it like as like a Palestinian or something like
yes. So this is where like I would expect that religious guy.
But here she's like oh somebody who's wearing a Star of David
and no symbols of Israel. And it's like, okay,
listen,
one might say that that is a tactical decision by the state of
Israel, right, to incorporate ideology so that Jews feel compelled
to defend and be a part of the state of Israel, even if they're
not from that country, right? Like that's a conflation that's
going to happen. If I wear a maple leaf on my if I wear a maple
leaf on my backpack and I say, "Hey," and I go around to a bunch
of places in the world, they're gonna assume I'm Canadian. If
it's not the Canadian flag, can I just go? Uh, excuse me. Did
you just assume I'm Canadian? You disgusting piece of What? What?
Did you just Did you just assume I was Canadian because I have
a maple flag or sorry, I have a maple leaf on my backpack. I
just like the hockey team. I just like the hockey team. You're
a piece of [__] Of course, I totally get that. But
uh but when you see comments like we won't have all rights, no
one will have rights until Palestinians have rights. or like
or like the no harmononey she was she was talking about a story
where a friend of hers a religious Muslim man approached a friend
of hers who had a star of David of some kind maybe on a shirt
or something or a necklace I can't remember and guy stopped in
front of him and started praying well yeah we don't know apparently
started praying in front of him and then started praying for
guys and children in front of him and then apparently chased
the guy at the start of David thing down the street until some
Brazilians some big Brazilian soccer players defended him Yep.
Israel issues sounds like something out of a Jackie Chan movie.
It's so stupid. I don't know what you're saying about or like
the Israel issue is an environmental issue. It's a race issue.
It's a um gay issue. It's a this issue and they're that that's
classic scapegoating just with modern lefty language. But that
is what scapegoating is. It is saying that all of these problems.
Wait, I think the Israel issue, I don't think it's like insane
to feel like the Israel issue is a race issue. The Israel issue,
the issue with Israel is if you support a country that is by
definition trying to be an ethnostate, you have to accept other
people's ability to do that when they feel threatened, right?
Otherwise, you're like, "Oh, no. Only only these people are allowed
to feel threatened because of like the Holocaust. It like all
has to go back to the the Holocaust." So, or because of this
group that just happens to be the only in the world. That's I
mean that's like the most classic scapegoating ever. I feel like
some people lose their collective minds when it comes and then
I walked home. I did my walk of shame home. Yeah. I And I broadly
just don't like I think if you accept that if a if a minority
group feels threatened um and they have a justified reason to
be to feel threatened that they're allowed to have like an ethnostate.
If you accept that, I think there's no reason to also argue that
you have to actually face pgrams or some kind of holocaust for
you to need that ethnostate. Right? As soon as you say that that
fear of threat, not not a persistent threat, there is no active
holocaust happening, right? But that fear of a former threat
is enough to I think you've immediately given up that every white
supremacist white supremacist in the white supremacist in the
US is correct in thinking that like their demographic is being
replaced and they will face like some sort of backlash for the
crimes of white people. I think you I think you give that all
up to them. I think that's true. Um it feels like it became cool
to dunk on a lot in leftist spaces. Oh yeah, for sure. So and
they literally said not Zionist. So that's uh um like joke of
shame. A what do you mean? She said she did a walk of shame.
I'm just wondering what that looks like. Uh I don't know. Yeah,
I don't know. Was about how lucky they are to meet that aren't
Zionists. Like that's like what it was about. Um which was terrible
abusing. Um Toronto's anti-Semitic. I was raised in the North
York community. Did it get really bad? Yes, it did. It did. It
got really bad. And it was not like this like 10 years ago. was
not like this 20 years ago. It's gotten crazy. And by crazy,
I mean there are multiple times a week at schools. Okay, we finally
have a harsh claim. There are multiple times a week at schools
in Toronto. Now, now I think that has to be fake. That had to
be false. There is no possible way that that could be true. Now,
could you could you find the barest? So, in order for her to
not like be basically like in order for this to not be insane,
you would have to find a week where two happened. I feel like
I don't even know about happening, but I I don't live in Toronto,
so maybe I wouldn't care about them. I would definitely hear
about like a pattern of at schools or something. I I would just
want to know what those are. 30 in months at Toronto school.
Okay. But what does this mean by right? I I need to know what
this means by does it mean like a gun went off at some point
in the direction of the school or around the school or does it
mean somebody was shot? And then does it have to do with Judaism
at all or is there for some reason like a high crime high crime
area around the school? So third school third school. Ah third
Jesus Christ. Sorry. I am uh I took some cold meds and I'm I
think they're hitting me. Third in months at Toronto school.
Government officials have to understand that the time for thoughts
and prayers is over. Stated CIA, an agency of Canadian Federations.
JNS staff. So this is JNS.org. I don't know what jns.org is,
but it never mind. I do know what it is. Okay. IDF air strike
thwarts imminent terror attack in Janine. Israel carries out
air strike on West Bank city Janine. Oh, okay. Uh-huh. Oh, how
you tell the story matters,
dude. Their advertisement gives away exactly what they are. Look
at this. Here's here's what the headline is. Israel carries out
air strike on West Bank City, Janine.
How you tell the story matters. Here's our here's our title.
IDF air strike thwarts imminent terror attack in Janine. Yeah,
how you tell the story matters, guys. I definitely trust this
website. I definitely trust this. You'll have to you will have
to go and look at like what the police reports say on these incidents.
Yeah. I mean, if you're gonna try and argue that you're more
impartial than the I'd like to see that. I don't think they're
arguing they're more impartial. I think they're openly saying
what they are. I think it's very clear what's going on. Uh Chris,
thank you for the raid. What What's up, Chris? What's up? How's
it going? Okay. A at Ba Shaya Mushka Elementary School on early
Friday morning, early on Friday morning marks the third time
the shots have been fired at the Shabbat girls school in Toronto
in recent months. One second. Okay. There was a at the school
on May 25th and another on October 12th on Yam Kapoor. So video
shows vehicle and at Toronto girls uh with suspect. Police released
footage of a dark-colored car with two individuals inside who
fired at the by So they fired at the elementary school
causing damage to the building but resulting in no injuries since
it was vacant at the time. Okay. At 4:50 a.m. So again, multiple
at schools every week. Okay. Middle of the night, nobody awake.
Fired shots in the direction of the school that caused damage
to the wall of the school. Now, is that a threat? Can that be
perceived as a threat? Yes. But that is not what we would call
like any kind of pogram. That is not anything like that. Okay?
It's not like that.
Um, it's not a nothing burger. It's not a nothing burger because
you can argue that this is absolutely
like a threat. It is a threat. It is a threat. It's not nothing.
Okay? It's not nothing. I don't want to I don't want to go ahead
and say that it's nothing. I just want to say the framing of
it where I was told multiple at schools that we all know what
that means right you're implying multiple schools multiple people
shot kids dead there are no kids but I would say lucluse it is
a threat of violence yes it is saying hey [__] you
major
just $5
shalom as you can see chat there is a rampid pram going on in
Canada but when I conquer Canada it'll only be the ordinary school
Uh-huh. Listen again. Not what she said. She said multiple at
schools at schools every week. So, first of all, she said every
week. Okay. Who Who am I arguing with here? It was
uh someone said that's not what she said. Where was it? I missed
it.
You guys know exactly what I'm saying, which is why I'm saying
that obviously there's a threat of violence to
right. I'm willing to give you that and say it's obviously a
threat of violence,
but well, hey, let's let's go back and listen. I don't want to
I don't want to
um which was terrible way different than it was 10 years. It
was not like this like 10 years ago was not like this 20 years
ago. It's gotten crazy. And by crazy, I mean there are multiple
times a week at schools. Multiple times a week at schools. So
first of all, multiple times a week is clearly false. Yes. Like
very very clearly obviously false. We are seeing over a period
of a year three times which is a lot and it's clearly a threat.
But I'm I'm looking at this as like these are people who are
not escalating to violence. Um and I I want to see examples of
escalations to violence. That's that's what I want to see because
we're we're talking about
She said that basically somebody would and kill her and tweet
about it. I'm not say there's a massive step up from what she's
describing
to what is saying or to what the reality is, right? She's describing
something sorry step down. She's describing something insane
and is like clearly a massive step down from that. I'm not saying
that she can't feel scared. I'm not saying that she can't feel
like that's a threat. It is a threat. I'm saying that she is
in one of the safest place for in the world. I mean, unless she
goes to school, I don't think she needs to feel personally scared,
does she? Um, I mean, they aren't. Also, is she going to school
at 4:00 a.m.? I don't Yeah. Well, it seems like it's clearly
So, I think basically anybody looking at this would see this
as a you fire if I went and fired at like a like if there was
a Muslim girls boarding school and I went and fired shots at
the school, I think it would be reasonable to infer I'm making
a threat towards Muslim. There are some there's some anonymous
vague threat towards Muslims. Yes. But there's a difference between
feeling some level of concern and being actively scared
cuz one's like you're actually in a period of risk and the other
is just like oh this isn't good. Not really close. Yeah. And
I I would be careful not to describe it as multiple a week at
schools. Yeah. When it's like three in a year that did apparently
nothing. I wonder if any of these were a firearm discharge from
a car targeted this school at 4:05 a.m. on Yam Kapoor. These
are different ones, right? 4:50 a.m. So, this is clearly in the
middle of the night, somebody is going and firing shots at the
school, not intending to harm people, but intending to send some
kind of threat, right? To cause fear amongst people. Okay, she's
allowed to be concerned. Yes, concern's fine, but then you're
speculating. You have to add the parameters. What if your niece
or nephew was there? Is that the case? Obviously not cuz she
would have mentioned it cuz she said everything else. Yeah. I
I just think like it's so I don't want to misstate what it is.
It's clearly it is very very very clearly a threat to Jewish
people. An anonymous threat for somebody who's like too scared
to take any real action of their own, right? They're just like
they're they're clearly like a a coward who wants to be scared
but doesn't want to risk getting caught, doesn't want to make
any kind of statement, doesn't want to stand behind anything,
right? They're like a cowardly loser. So you can be you can be
like uh I think you can be upset about that, but I would worry
that if you give cowardly losers like that power over you, you
will just be very very unhappy in life because it costs them
nothing to make those threats and to remain anonymous. It it
goes the same with threats on the internet, right? If somebody
is anonymous, there's no weight behind their threats. They're
just totally anonymous. There's nothing behind that. Like I'm
not going to give somebody who is not risking anything to make
a threat power over me, right? Or or you could you would just
be scared for the rest of your life, especially if you're a public
figure of any kind. Anyway,
so now we know multiple
every week means three in a year. Okay. I mean, like literally
almost every other day, I'm hearing from a friend of an anti-semitic
incident on the subway, on the street. Just Friday night, I was
at an event where the person who was talking was insanely anti-semitic.
And when I say antisetic, I don't mean just anti-Israel. I mean
they literally were talking about they said the word they didn't
they didn't say the word Zionist, okay? And everyone laughed
and was like, I I would love I would love
if we could, you know, believe that if they said Zionist that
I'm sorry, Aris, I I'm just saying if they had said Zionist and
said these same things, I know for a fact you would still say
it was anti-semitism.
I And I hate to I hate to just call that out, but it would still
be anti-semitism to you, right? Even if they said Zionism. Now,
let's see what they said. Are they criticisms of the state of
Israel or are they criticisms of the Jewish people? And I had
to walk out. I was like, am I is this 20 24? What world am I
in? It's crazy. Absolutely wild. But my psychoess still wants
to live. Three is a lot for Canada though, right? I thought guns
weren't a thing up there. No, I mean, so people don't do outside
of gangs, people don't do violence with guns that often, but
people do have guns. It's not very difficult to get a gun in
Canada. Well, sorry. It's not difficult. It's not like it's not
difficult as in um it's not like particularly like a high bar.
It's just like bureaucracy. You have to register. You have to
get a license. Yeah. People Well, I don't think Eastern Canada
I don't think like the Greater Toronto area has the same level
of guns as a lot of the rest of Canada, but um but like people
aren't using guns to carry out violence against civilians in
the same way. It's just not a pattern in Canada. There are blanket
bans on some of the more like high-capacity uh higher lethality
weapons as well. Like I don't think you're allowed to own an
AR-15 in Canada in like any case essentially. I think that's
just like autobanned in every case. So here because I don't really
have another option. Um oh I can talk about it. I just like the
problem is I don't know. Oh, I will say as well for people who
are willing to break the law, almost all,
as Jude points out, almost all crimes in Canada are done with
illegal guns. No, most most handguns are most handguns are either
illegal, only pis or I can't remember. So, a lot of pistols got
banned recently by Trudeau like two years ago. Before that, you
could literally only have your handgun out of your house if you
are going to a shooting range. Otherwise, you are literally you
have your uh you have your gun. It has to stay in your house.
If you have it out of your house and you're off the path between
a registered range that you've registered with the police and
you get caught with that gun, you are breaking the law. You are
okay. That's like what you have to do with a handgun in Canada
to maintain a handgun license. Damn. I've never seen a handgun
cuz they've been banned in the UK for so long. They only have
shotguns and rifles. Yeah. The issue is we share a border with
the US and it's like a poorest border that you can get over pretty
easily without like tons and tons of inspection. And so realistically
like there are a lot of illegal guns in Canada and they do come
over from the US. If you're if you're like a criminal and you're
trying to buy illegal guns, you can buy illegal guns here. Yeah.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Know if I want to get that person canled cuz I
don't really believe. Sure. Americans don't know that handguns
are the biggest violent offenses. They think AR-15s are the worst.
Well, the issue is that most of the time if somebody is going
on a spree, it's with an AR-15, a high-capacity like high lethality
weapon, right? Like the the the high casualty count civilian
events, like the the mass events, I believe usually would be
carried out. So, when I say mass, I'm going to put a bar higher.
Seven or higher deaths in those cases where somebody is out to
like put everybody down, I think those are like AR-15s.
Now, obviously, I I would wonder where where it shakes out if
you get rid of all gang violence
because that's like most lethality from guns in the States. It's
just like pure gang violence. I'd wonder where it shakes out
if you get rid of all even cancel culture. So, I don't know if
like I want to like advertise to the whole world what happened
that night, too. I might say what I just looked up why we banned
handguns and I'm like, "Ah, yeah, that makes sense." Probably.
Yeah, it was a really bad DL massacre.
Yeah, like 16 kids and then hurt a bunch of others as well. Jesus
hell.
So, Aerys was just telling us about she she had comments about
at an event that she was at. She's not getting it seems like
she's not getting specific about anything about it. I just like
the problem is I don't know if I want to get that person canled
cuz I don't really believe in cancel culture. So, I don't know
if like I want to like advertise to the whole world what happened
that night too. I might say what happened and I'm just not going
to say who the person's name is, but uh it was someone it was
a comedian thinking that like and they were not doing actual
comedy. It was a comedian not doing actual comedy and they talked
about Jews. Bro,
what? She went to a comedy show and she was like, "They made
comments about that's up." I don't know what that symbol was.
I might say what happened and I'm just not going to say who the
person's name is, but uh it was someone it was a comedian thinking
that like and they were not doing actual comedy. I don't know
what that symbol was by the way if someone subscribed to my Patreon
or something like that. Um isn't Drake half? Yes, he is. So,
but we don't claim him. Okay, we don't claim him. What?
Uh no protections for Drake. Okay, Drake, we're kicking you out
of the bomb shelters. Get out there. Tank a rocket for us. you,
Drake. All right, Drake, you're up her ability to blend in with
the whites. All right, you also
your kid is way too obvious. You got to be Cougar. Um, but you
know, it's fine. But yeah, it was a comedian. It was a comedian
that made the comments, but the thing is is that I'm normally
I'm a super I am an old school girl. Do not do not come to me
and say comedy was a thing until it targeted a group I cared
about. Do not come to me and do this. Okay, this entire thing,
people always do this. It was funny until he went after a group
I'm a part of. It was funny until he started making fun of my
people. Okay, it's so embarrassing. This happened to so many
white people when Dave Chappelle did his jokes about the opioid
epidemic. So many white people went, "Uh, yeah, it was funny
and now you you took it too far." Okay, Dave Chappelle, you took
it way too far. It's like do you listen to any of this guy's
jokes from the '90s and 2000s with the crackheads in black communities?
Do you see him making fun of his own community in this exact
way? And he's literally doing he's just recycling the same jokes
on white people. And you're like, actually, this is way too far.
I don't approve this. This is unacceptable. This
And she's she's doing it right now. She's being the uh the white
chappelle. I am an old school girl when it comes to humor. Like
I'm a anti-SJW humor girl. I like I grew up playing video games.
I like my really dark runchy humor with the like the most up
jokes. I will laugh at a Holocaust joke. Okay, I will do. So
this comedian was doing something worse than a Holocaust joke.
What was this comedian saying? Do that. I have no pride. But
so I've never been the What is this entire then? Don't wear your
star and just pretend to be white. What? This whole thing This
whole thing started for like you didn't want to feel like you
had to hide. Well, you don't have any pride in being just hide
your start. You're fine. Person who's gotten like offended by
comedy before. Like that's just not me. And but there is something
that really feels different when you know the person.
Uh, by the way, I really Okay, I really hate to point this out.
Oh, it's rough. You could totally figure out comedians who were
in Toronto on like the weekend before this happened or like the
week before this happened and super narrow it down. Yeah. No,
you could easily narrow this down very, very, very easily if
you wanted to. I'm not going to, but you could very easily narrow
it down. I could. She said all the lines, too. Listen, guys,
I'm I love comedy, and comedians should be able to say whatever
they want. But like, have you considered that when they say this
about a group I'm concerned about that it's actually like racism
or anti-semitism or religious bigotry? Did guys I listen I've
laughed at Holocaust jokes before but that when they talked about
how like people do this X that was really up. Okay that was really
up. Not a lot of comedians in Canada if you could narrow it down.
Well it's somebody it's probably somebody who's touring right
bro I don't
Yeah I don't I don't get it. Um the joke anyway that was cool.
That was fun. Oh man. Are we ready to go on to the Tom Foolery
stuff? I think we're
wakes up
the content
for a job board in his hand while Kelly's just thinking his head's
poorly planned. I drop 10 quid from J.
If I could you see
all my homies hate
and join the decree. Oh, Kelly Gina angry British Queen screaming.
Let's add a key right through your screen. Got Kelly range syndrome
is plain to see. Oh, now you know how it feels. Believe me, the
popcorn jer
bags of milk real. She muses with a sigh. Why is Cherry so small?
As the moments fly, left for 3 hours, came back, nothing changed.
While Ethan's become the monster he once through. This [__]
is annoying. No punches she'll
We hate in a lot of hateful way.
That's her rule. Oh, Kelly G and an angry British queen screaming,
"You don't keep right through your scream." Got Kelly derangement
syndrome. It's plain to see. Oh, now you know how it feels. Believe
me. I demand the popcorn. Get me back, bro. Another line in her
fiery chat.
How is it my fault? She'll exclaim there's a delay. You clunker.
It's part of the game.
is we never
says he will later then forgets the whole coral I'm going to
do angrily if you can't stand by your words then just let it
be she commands with a merry cat on
the battle rages till dawn
Oh, Kelly G and an angry British queen screaming, "You don't
Right through your screen. Got Kelly derangement syndrome. It's
plain to see. Have a laugh. Now you know how it feels. Believe
me, I demand the popcorn. Give you back. Another line in her
fiery shadow
getting sued. YouTubers. Can we just can we just stop or can
we just put emphasis on the butt and then just disregard literally
everything before it? And then when Dan was making his argument,
Dan said, "But I don't care because anti-semitism.
I am I have to think about my children's future." And Nick was
like, "Yeah, no. This is my career." Yeah, true. Why? That's
why Twitch is a unique problem. That's his goal here is to try
to say Twitch is a unique problem. And it's not like you like
you said. Obviously Chud basically reacts to the exact same content
across both YouTube and Twitch. Yes. It's like I I can I'm sure
at some point he goes, "Um, yeah, I don't know, man. This this
could be dangerous, I guess." But I'm sure the rest of it is,
"Oh my god, I'm so glad Casey drops be financially ruined. Oh
my god, dude. Then they don't even give a they've got malicious
intent. Like how can this not be infringement? It's going to
be that like endlessly."
I had this Nick Deoro tweet up here that we're going to cover.
Um cuz I thought it was I thought it was pretty interesting.
Okay. I just thought it was a very interesting position that
we sort of described on stream a couple times
and I get it and I reply to No, he didn't reply to Auggie. He
just threw like an opinion which I was just like that's an interesting
opinion. Okay, it's an interesting opinion.
Uh lawsuits and court rulings could potentially have scary consequences
for us moving forward, but I find it really hard to empathize
specifically with any of the streamers getting sued. YouTubers
complain. Can we just stop or can we just put emphasis on the
butt and then just disregard literally everything before it cuz
that's now now we can see what he's actually saying. Uh, sure,
sure, sure. Um, I just find it very funny how this maps onto
Willie Mac's thoughts about um death threats. This is very it's
like this uh but I find it really hard to empathize specifically
with any of the streamers getting sued. YouTubers complained
and practically begged these Twitch streamers for years to just
do the bare minimum. In return, they gave increasingly smug responses.
Uh, I believe it was like mostly XQC was giving the most smug
responses. Okay. I believe XQC was the most offensive. Again,
um, okay, it's fine. The culture on Twitch allowed for these
guys to use YouTube content as their lunch break or lunch or
bathroom breaks without any permission or meaningful interaction
with the material. It's comparable to Tik Tockers getting ripped
off by people exporting all their content on Insta reels. On
Twitch, people watch full TV shows and movies while collecting
ad revenue and donations. It was an absolute clown world. Uh,
I think this culture had broadly ended, right? Was anybody doing
this as a big streamer other than maybe Caseyron? Isn't he also
just giving you the exact reason why he has a hard time empathizing
cuz he's now portraying the us versus them mindset that he has.
Twitch vers YouTube and I'm on YouTube. So, actually, I can't
empathize with these people being targeted.
Well, I think it's uh the other thing is it's like the narrative
by which you can like still support all these lawsuits, right?
Oh, it's like Twitch streamer. It's Twitch culture. Yeah. Yeah.
I pointed that out because they're not going versus advertisers,
right? When Dan was going to the advertisers on Twitch, uh Dioro's
like reaction was like, "Hold on, hold on, cuz this happened
on YouTube and I'm not with that." That was like, "Put everybody
at risk." Blah blah blah blah blah. So now,
yeah, I don't know. I I think um yeah, I think this is broadly
like attacking a the the weird thing about to me about this is
it's attacking a Twitch culture that is like old like a Twitch
culture that basically I think the what do you call it the 2023
react stuff actually changed a decent amount. A lot of people
stopped doing precisely what was getting called out and started
becoming better about it. Asmin goes better about it. Realistically,
one of the only people who got like about it and didn't change
at all was XQC.
I think like
Everything Nick saying just seems totally worthless cuz he like
Ethan could literally like show up and and just one of these
women and Nick would support it.
I know you but I'm having a hard time
having a hard time empathizing when they're like outright deniers
and they just get on stream all the time and deny the of Israeli
women. I just really can't empathize if like guy just goes and
rescue to be honest. I I think ultimately, you know, you know,
maybe you shouldn't deny of that's that's the mindset he's on
right now. This just isn't even honest because this has nothing
to do with Twitch. This the things that Ethan is complaining
about could have been a YouTube streamer. He's just talking about
streamers versus people who upload curated content, right? His
buddy Logic is
on YouTube.
This last point's going to kind of differentiate, but it doesn't
really No, you're correct. But he's like trying to mislead here
because he's going to point out content ID. And Content ID exists,
but Content ID, as far as I know, is not anywhere near as accessible
to small channels. Like, am I crazy or do you have to pre-register
your stuff with Content ID in some way that most people can't?
Like, you don't just get the Content ID things live on streams
unless you have some sort of like additional access, right? Like
I know you can I know you can go to the copyright tab and pick
out your videos and being they're being used somewhere else and
you can DMCA automatically, but I don't think you get like the
live copyright um content ID stuff unless you register a video
in a specific way. But I am I
have no idea. But he like Ethan went out of his way to register
with the Library of Congress before he had his nuke go live.
So, if he was going to be preemptive about that, I imagine he
would be able to and he has like the size enough to get his video
content IDed, which would would have prevented streamers that
were on YouTube from reacting to it. Many that did or like not
hit or anything like that, not flagged. I just don't there. This
just doesn't mean anything.
Yeah. Well, he's trying to say that like Twitch is a bad platform
because they didn't implement Content ID, but it exists for songs
for one thing. And then it also I would say like I think they
try to do some kind of content ID version with like reports
like they will they will dock you offline if you are streaming
movies and you get reported right but I think they do it more
manually they probably spend money doing it but uh he's trying
to point out that like YouTube is just better and that's why
that's why Twitch is a unique problem. That's his goal here is
to try to say Twitch is a unique problem and it's not like you
like you said obviously Chud basically reacts to the exact same
content across both YouTube and Twitch. Yes, it essentially doesn't
his job. And then the argument that oh well what happens to Twitch
streamers won't affect you as a YouTuber. That didn't that's
not how Nick felt when it was Dan going after Twitch and Dan
Clancy and advertisers. Nick Dioro felt like no no like doing
that has bad implications for me as a streamer, as a YouTuber
on this platform. So no, I'm not going to support that. So, the
fact that he would literally when it's it's Dan going after specifically
Twitch say, "No, that has implications for me as a YouTuber and
I'm I'm not going to just like act like there's a difference."
But now he's going to sit here and act like there's a difference.
It just feels really dishonest. Yeah. And I think Well, hold
on. It's a little dishonest, but he does do the but right. So,
this is right that you can ignore it. But I'm telling you, he's
in terms of like what he's going to say if you were arguing back
to go, "Well, no. I I acknowledge that there are downsides for
all of us, potentially scary consequences,
right? I I I admit that this is disingenuous. I'm telling you
that's what he would argue, right? And then when Dan was making
his argument, Dan said, "But I don't care because anti-semitism.
I am I have to think about my children's future." And Nick was
like, "Yeah, no. This is my career." Yeah, true. That didn't
work on him then, but now it's Ethan's kids. Okay. Now Ethan
at CPS called on him now. Now all morals are out the window.
Okay, that principle that that wasn't a principle. Okay, now
it's Ethan's kids. He didn't care about Dan's kids. Cares about
Ethan's kids. Okay. Did you know that there were skulls sent
for every one of Ethan's kids, Cherry? Did you know that? I didn't.
I didn't. Was it his kids' sk schools? No. And I don't think
it's true, actually. I think that was just something somebody
said. But I
What's actually crazy is that you believe that for a second.
You believe that could be true? Isn't that the crazy part? I
just don't know why his empathy is important to need to disclose
to anyone. Like, uh, you're a sociopathic
fat streamer on YouTube. Why do we care what you feel empathetic
towards, if anything? I would never call Nick fat. Okay, that's
up, Kelly. Why would you do that? Why? He's gigantic. Yeah, I'm
just glad that he felt empathy for Pixie. I can at least point
to one woman he had empathy for. Very cool. This is actually
a common destiny take strategy where you make an emotional argument
that sounds like you're making an argument on principle where
so like you might say I don't care if you get shot at Trump rally.
Uh that's not actually saying anything. You're just saying how
you feel about it. But it sounds like you're saying it's justified
or something like that. Something edgy that you can like defend
on logical grounds. It's actually just a statement of your emotion.
It's the same thing Nick's doing here. He's going to constantly
make the emotional argument because it means because he well
he's lost the intellectual one. That's the reality. He knows
he always will a loser cuz you're I mean that's evident when
you turn to us verse them back up. You're like galvanizing people
to support you in a dishonest way by implying that the other
side is actually against you. Kind of like Ethan saying I'm saving
the commentary community by going after these people because
they're actually jeopardizing you even though he's the one who's
putting them in jeopardy. Well, I Yeah, I I and I can't stand
that. I I can't stand when somebody is like uh
like I want people to lie to me better sometimes. You know what
I'm saying? Like if you're going to lie to me, could you not
make it like the most obvious lie that I can like see the window
dressing on it? Like I could see I could see that this is an
illusion. Just lie better. Lie better. I don't really have to
lie to you thankfully because you're funny and all of your jokes
land and make me laugh. Huh? That's what I That's what I'm talking
about. Okay. Just lie better. See, you said that with feeling.
You said that with gusto. I believed it completely. Also because
it's true. Mostly because it's true, actually. Yeah, mostly because
it's true.
I'm still waiting for Second to respond to me. Second said, "Oh,
if you wanted an example of one of those times where you can't
criticize Denims and Co side without also full throatly criticizing
the Ethan side, uh, I don't see where that happened here, and
I asked you what the criticism of Denims was, and you still haven't
told me, and I'm specifically not scrolling up cuz I want you
to tell me from memory, but it seems like you're not telling
me from memory, so I'm very confused." What was the criticism?
I don't know what the criticism was. It's still not coming. It's
still not coming through. I don't know if you're telling me or
not that the Twitch community's response. No, no, no. He's not
even saying the Twitch community's response. He says some streamers
were arrogant about it, but it wasn't it wasn't the Twitch community's
response. That wasn't most streamers. There were a couple streamers
who were arrogant about it. This is about Twitch's response,
right? Twitch is a platform didn't respond. This isn't a criticism
of Denims. I just want to point out that it's clearly not what
you just said it was. But anyway, we can keep reading. Like thing
is that the things Twitch should do the Twitch's response being
poor is like their copyright and DMCA system isn't as developed
as YouTube. So they should probably, you know, have better tools.
Okay. So what does that have to do with Ethan Klein registering
his copyright with the Library of Congress in advance of his
video to get statuto damages on these people? What the does DMCA
process or any like that have to do with the Library of Congress
filing? It's got it's like totally irrelevant. No better process
would have fixed this because
complete bad
like no but he actually explicitly like this the DMCA thing through
Twitch does work. He literally could have DMC it intentionally
did not right and it took four hours created before it was it
was Annavir. She DMZed me. Yeah. But then she took it back. Awesome.
But thank you. I don't know. I like so obviously when he's when
he knows he's going to try to sue when he knows he's going to
register it. He easily could have DMCA. just explicitly didn't.
So yeah, this isn't even a good It doesn't matter that the system's
not good. He didn't even attempt DMCA. Unless he just hasn't
told anybody about it, but I don't know why you wouldn't put
that in the lawsuit. Seems kind of like an important thing to
include in a lawsuit, right? Whether or not you DMCA this guy
seems sort of important. Hold on. I also, if you guys could talk
for two seconds, I'm going to switch some onream overlay stuff.
I'll read the rest of the So, we agreed there's no reason for
him to think about Twitch as a platform right now. This is just
um you imagine him and like where's Sumo wrestling?
No. No, I don't want to imagine that. Okay, hold on. Okay, Kelly's
working now. Queen is Queman
Okay. Yes, everybody's working. Everybody's working. We're good.
We're good to go. All right. So, when I think about Twitch as
a platform, I often look back I oftentimes look back to a truly
absurd email I received in back in 2021. In 2007, YouTube launched
its content ID system in uh system in and it allegedly cost $100
million to develop by 2018.
On May 28th, 2021, Twitch fired off a panic email begging their
users to learn about copyright and saying they were caught off
guard by automated content claims. YouTube created Content ID
after a lawsuit to tackle a growing copyright problem on its
site over a decade before Twitch sent me this this email promising
an ability to view your strike count in Twitch Studio. This is
absolutely
Um, okay. So, so what would these change have done to prevent
this?
What?
This lawsuit isn't suing Twitch. It's not going to cause these
changes.
So, uh, total nons. Do you consider this is just to bring up
Twitch bad, but yeah, obviously it's just like, wow, isn't this
so terrible? Anyway, I'm going to get on stream tonight and uh
betray all my previous stage values and say this is awesome.
Actually, that's all it is. Uh, do you think he did that on his
stream? I didn't get a chance to watch his stream at all. I haven't
been sent any clips yet. I haven't watch.
It's like I I can I'm sure at some point he goes, "Um, yeah,
I don't know, man. This this could be dangerous, I guess." But
I'm sure the rest of it is, "Oh my god, I'm so glad Casey drs
be financially ruined. Oh my god, dude. Then they don't even
give a They've got malicious intent. Like, how can this not be
infringement? It's going to be that like endlessly five." I actually
last night. You honestly can't check it out. He's like doing
the
I don't know if it's a strategy cuz it's maybe being too um thinking
too highly of him, but he's doing longass streams and he's doing
like lore dives. So, it's just I think the the stream talking
about Ethan was like a 12-hour stream cuz he wanted to look up
older content. Streamers can literally say whatever they want
cuz they put out so much content and no one's ever going to sift
through it. So, exactly. And they're going to be like, "Oh, they
just clipped this moment out of a 12hour stream." Like, okay,
buddy, but can I not say anything unless I go over all 12 hours?
At which point, what do you then then you just like I don't know,
strike me cuz isn't that what Ethan is doing? They went over
the whole video. Now I got to get them. I'm going to go now.
Good night, Kelly. Good night. Good night, Kelly. See you. I
was kind of hoping when I went and looked at Nick's uh this post
from Nick, I was going to see some responses. So, he he goes
on to say, "I genuinely think Twitch and what it's allowed is
pretty bad for the entire content creator landscape. I've been
saying there would be a huge lawsuit eventually that could threaten
all content creators for little years. And the response from
streamers has been, "You want me to react harder? Why not make
better content?" Is this going to change? Is this going to change
like the Twitch landscape right now?
I mean, it's So, it could open up to lawsuits, but it like it's
not fixing the problem. This isn't going to make this isn't suing
Twitch for not having a good Why do you think YouTube is any
different? Why do you think YouTube is any different? It's not
well you you couldn't make a a differentiation right at maybe
at this old content ID system but the content ID system has nothing
to do with this whatsoever. It's totally irrelevant. I think
this is just an old argument cuz YouTube used to not be able
to compete with live streaming. But that's changed over the years.
So if you're just falling back to uh Twitch versus YouTube arguments
uh from like four years ago, you're outdated. YouTubers absolutely
compete right now when it comes to live streaming. Wouldn't you
say? Yes, it absolutely competes. But like I would say to me
more the the issue is like none of these people have ever really
wanted to kind of complain about live streaming. I think most
of these people conceded in the 2023 debate that they they thought
live streaming was like kind of a gray area. Uh that audience
is going to be more interested in the streamer. The issue is
always the VODs and where the VODs were going and where the VODs
like if you're competing on YouTube with people who have like
curated content on YouTube. And none of this lawsuit has anything
to do with that. All the people who do that can still just do
it, right? is basically only if this lawsuit goes the worst way
it could for creators unless it all creators by like changing
totally what fair use is going to mean then no XQC who's the
primary I guess primary offender here is still taking all of
the YouTube revenue he wants from all of these people like literally
the the stated target the stated like worst behavior worst um
worst offender for this problem from 2023 is literally not going
to be affected by this unless it all creators I don't understand
what the goal is so I understand the differentiation with like
VODs. I think XQC brought that up and then like Ethan
acknowledged, okay, there there could be a thing there if the
Twitch VODs pull away viewership, but that's not as utilized
on like the Twitch platform as it is on YouTube. I think he said
I think he said that VODs basically don't compete. Like he he
created like a gray area for Twitch and said like I don't really
think that counts because like they're not competing in the same
Like nobody like Leo's not point. Go ahead. Oh, Lemino is not
um Lemino is not like streaming his videos on Twitch like it
is a separated audience was like the argument Ethan was making
back then. Yes. And I do believe that with the feature of YouTube
premieres and understanding that um the viewership that you get
during your premiere will boost you in the algorithm and can
affect your video going viral and like to the degree it'll go
viral. I thought that was the huge thing that he's actually like
zoning in on right here. are live streamers. They are live streaming
my live premiere and that's like a market replacement because
it is a live viewing experience with a live chat. I thought that's
what was going on.
I don't think I unless I'm mistaken, I'm not sure that Ethan
makes that actual argument. I like I don't I don't recall that
from the document, but I think that is that is the argument he
should be making. I think. But in that case, I I literally don't
know if fair use changes at all for streams versus uh like stream
versus stream versus like a curated video. Yeah. I'm just I'm
really not sure. But I don't I actually don't know that he made
that argument in the marketplacement thing. But yeah, I don't
uh like it is the best argument. I know Cherry made that argument
like that that is why it's the most offensive when we first covered
this, but I don't know if that's I don't know if that's the argument
Ethan made.
Yes, because you can track the the actual market that's being
replaced by looking at what Denim's regular live viewership is
and then where it spiked to when she started watching the live
premiere, how much it spiked, how they retained, and when she
stopped watching it that they go away, and that the next day
that she streams, they do not come back. you did effectively.
I I don't know if she can take it from Ethan, but you can argue
she had an audience to do this and it's because she did this
um stealing this like live premiere, not because these are people
invested in her. Sure. And then yeah, the counter-argument to
that is the Hassan and and H3 Stark people literally boosting
her in those communities to try to pump viewership to her and
and for that could be her argument. Hassan wasn't streaming.
Hassan
uh advertised me and so Hassan viewers were watching me and that
could be a perfect like justification on her part. I think that's
fair to say. Yeah, I think it's going to be interesting to see
which way it goes cuz I do think I I've kind of gotten more convinced
that I think there's a decent argument that she did not actually
create a market replacement.
I think I've like okay intellect in terms of intellectual honesty
I actually believe she did not create a market replacement because
she doesn't go and like upload it to YouTube uh herself and like
create uh like I I just don't think she did anywhere near what
like somebody like XC does in terms of competing in that same
marketplace. I think she is explicitly being watched not because
it's the content nuke but because it is opposition to the content
nuke. I think that people literally want opposition to it and
it's like watching, you know, I wouldn't watch a Trump rally.
This is the comparison I use. Wait, were you here earlier? You
might have been here, Cherry, actually. But I I wouldn't watch
a Trump rally personally just to watch a Trump rally, but I might
watch it through a political content creator hypothetically,
right? Who's going to oppose it to explain like why it's like
I I hate this guy. I'm not going to watch him just talk. I think
that's how most people think, right? It's why political streamers
are so big
as well. This one as well. Um, Aerodite was live tonight. 170
viewers. If I stream sniped her, it'd be what, 500? Uh, maybe
higher. Higher. Be honest. I'm
Oh, yeah. Yeah. For airight content. And if you had I mean, I
assume if you were going to stream sniper, there would be like
a large impetus. There'd be some reason you were doing it. And
you get people who like aren't even regular viewer. Like, there
are people who will watch you. Probably there's like a decent
cohort of people who will watch Queen just for like airite hate
content. Soating that perhaps she could come after anyone for
reacting when it's like literally no one wants to watch your
stream. It's just you.
Yes. It is like um
it's like a different
Christian going after people for like making videos on on them.
It's all her. It's like uh no one's no one's there to watch you,
bro. Okay. They need it filtered down.
Yeah. And I think there there is something when it's like critical
when it's criticism. It is like a fundamentally different product
you are creating like totally at a base level. There's nobody
who's like I'm a big fan of this person. I like their arguments.
I want to watch them cuz I think all of us do this. I remember
I used to do this for political streamers all the time. I turn
on like a rally or something and I hear them say something stupid
and I go, "Oh, I got to get out of here. I got to go just watch
the rally like this." Right? Like I think when it's criticism
of the content, it's like it becomes fundamentally different
from the underlying content. I think that is a fairly solid argument
for denims. Who's watching Hassan if someone's not criticizing
him and like you know Dior or Willie Mac or Destiny or whoever's
audience? I need to sit on this for a bit because there's like
an analogy right at the tip of my tongue and I just can't find
it. But I get what you mean. You should have to actually do something
to prove market replacement because you can identify here there
is a flux of people that is coming to watch this streamer review
this content. Why do they never go to that content to actually
see it themselves or
well the H3 snark subreddit is actually the proof of this in
and of itself. There's a large community that Ethan argues is
huge right and is the primary community supporting like denims
and the creators against him. That's a huge community who regardless
of if Denims was doing that would have been watching it through
like the YW YouTube thing would have been watching it in a way
that wasn't going to pass revenue onto Ethan, right? Like they
that's why you bring up uh what is it 4chan or a Kiwi Farms because
for someone like Chris Chan to look at all these people talking
about him and being like, "Oh, somebody must be taking viewership
away from me because look at all this like uh discussion of me.
Other people are getting views of me but my live streams aren't
getting any."
that person's like completely missing the reason why people are
watching.
Yeah, it's just like a hater content, which I mean you could
argue that the haters should have to pay you in some way to use
that. You could make that argument, but it's like it's not a
market replacement argument. No, think about think about can
you or should this be oh this person you'd have to prove that
they are actually doing something malicious by criticizing you.
You'd have to argue I need this content taken down for bullying
and harassment or something. Maybe maybe I'm just describing
like uh like as long as it's fair use, right? As long as it's
transformative enough, as long as it's not uh I think the market
replacement thing is the hardest one to argue. I feel like that's
fine. Yeah. Well, and especially when it becomes political, which
all of this stuff was, right? I think politics in terms of the
nature of the work itself absolutely opens up basically a ton
of political content to fair use. Like I think that becomes a
very important pillar when it is political content. You shouldn't
be able to make significant political crit criticisms of somebody
and then stop them from responding. Um and stop them from responding
maybe even in full to like something like that, right? You're
you're criticizing their movement, multiple people in the same
movement. I don't know that you can necessarily say, "Well, I
don't want them to I only want them to react to my criticism
of them." It's like, no, if you're criticizing like these people
and identifying them as a group, I think that's I think that
group might gain, you know, some ability to respond to that.
Now, I think like you're right, but I do believe that that is
what makes people feel like it's uh even more justified to do
so. I don't think that you have to
have initiated by criticizing a group to to open yourself up
for other people criticizing you. No, you don't. You don't. But
I'm saying that like it's an additional thing that you're like
advertising this as major criticisms of uh you're advertising
this this as major criticisms of this entire group, this like
ideological group that streams together. I think that group might
gain through those criticisms some right to respond to that work
and possibly the entire context
because this is obviously going to be different from video content
creation and like people earning revenue through views. But what
about critics who post bad reviews and then all of a sudden a
restaurant is like, I got this bad review from a critic and now
people don't come to my restaurant. They haven't even tried my
food. They just listen to what this person says and he actually
ruined every he ruined my career because of what? Maybe it was
like a bad day for him. I think that is some something close
to the criticism that they're making right in the lawsuit is
basically because this is like lying or damage. actually because
it's lying. It's like malicious and it's like actually hurting
my business for no discernable reason. No like no reasonable
cuz you would think that the person in the who owns the restaurant
runs the restaurant, he is so devastated. I'm assuming it's a
man um cuz emotional. He's so devastated because these people
are going to read a review about his food without ever trying
it for themselves. But here is this person who is reacting to
your entire content. They can see the viewers can watch your
entire content through them. And you believe that that's hurting
your reputation, ruining your career? Yeah, I don't Well, I mean,
he's technically not suing for defamation. So, I guess it's not
necessarily that's not his primary complaint, right? It is just
that it's infringing on his copyright. Yeah, but no, he doesn't
actually care about his copyright. He cares about how malicious
people were for doing what they did. If he could sue them for
defamation, he would sue them for defamation. like that. He would
rather sue them for defamation to have that on the record that
they're lying about him, right? But he's suing them for copyright
infringement because he can't get them for defamation.
He's probably been told as much multiple times now. Uh this probably
doesn't have a good overlap, but that's like the closest thing
I can think of. Yeah, I think um cuz you can argue that a food
critic can actually ruin somebody's restaurant and reputation
without anybody
uh without even being accurate, right? Cuz it is just like your
opinion.
Why does it have so much weight to it? I don't think that YouTubers
or streamers have that much power, but maybe I'm being naive.
I don't know. Yeah, it uh I mean, it depends. I think it's more
about the group. They think they they're basically taking This
is like actually something a lot of people do online. They'll
take the actions of the whole group and they'll hold a single
person responsible, right? Regardless of how much sense that
makes. It's like Dennis is getting blamed for like coordinating
with Snark and causing like all of those viewers to like by announcing
that she was going to do a replacement causing all of those viewers
to go to her channel. Like it's she's basically going to be held
responsible for the actions of like tens of thousands of people.
Seems a little crazy to me.
And for And for what? Because his video got millions of views,
right? And his videos continue to get millions of views. It shouldn't
he actually I don't know be hurting in some way for him to be
able to make an effective change? I usually but that's the entire
purpose of registering with the Library of Congress so that he
can like do sue statutoily so that like usually it would just
be actual damages like what are you what are you would you how
are you harmed show me that you're harmed and I will you could
just get restitution through the courts but he knows that he's
not going to actually be harmed by these people he knows there's
no real actual harm there and so he is just suing for statutory
damages to try to hurt these people as much as possible he's
a mean vindictive bully principalist loser yeah Okay. Is blowbacks,
y'all? How do you say? Is it blow blacks or blowbacks? Bo Blacks.
Bo Blacks. In his Only Fans bio, it said
Yeah. When you're on one side, that's why we quit the channel
ultimately. It's just because like it just wasn't like sustainable
for growth. I was I remember like DMing Dior. I was just like,
"What the [__] Why is everyone supporting this? If
Hassan said the same thing, everyone would be up his ass." You
know? Hassan said like America deserves 911 which I think is
actually a much more defensible position than like the Destiny
firefighter thing dream. It was like the Destiny conversation,
there was Bax and then there was Kinetic Kell and it's like I
instigated all three of those conversations, dude. The kinetic
kel that was awesome,
dude.
Dude, no before that dude. Tommy see he's a you know he's a commentary
OG. He comes from a different time, you know. He's uh Sometimes
you got to take the dog old dog out back. I have people saying
that I need to give him a me and Nick need to give him a fireside
chat.
Dude, I'm just sitting here. I'm trying to figure out the lay
of the land because I'm launching a new show. It's going to be
called the third position with Augie RFC. And I'm just trying
to figure out like where everybody like stands with each other
cuz I noticed like a lot of people are like again it's all the
audience. The audience has really become one thing I've noticed
with 2025 commentary is the chatters have all the control. Like
the chatters like own this [__] It's weird. It's
like uh they kind of control what the narratives are going to
be and like who who's going to be at who. It's all instigated
by the chat. Have you guys noticed this? No. I think chats have
no agency. I think they're like literally like [__]
Maybe some people just let the chat have not there. You got some
commentary chatters who do who are like wellknown, but I've tried
talking to these people. I'm No, wait. I know what I'm I know
where I'm getting this wrong. It's the Clippers. Okay. And you
guys are very good at setting up Clippers, especially Queen.
And like I every day I go on Twitter, I just get like a million
Queen clips and I'm like, what the are these coming from? And
it's all these Clippers that the narratives like Chloic said
this, you know, Tommy C said this or whatever, Nick Dioro said
this. and they kind of the narratives of like, oh boy, like this
creator said this opinion about this guy. This is what we're
all supposed to think. I don't know, dude. It's It's very interesting.
Why'd you delete your tweet earlier saying I thought it was bad
optics. I don't know. I I uh I was worried that I was going to
end up on Ethan Klein's
You think you can't defend the NH tweet on H podcast live? Listen,
okay, I wanted my criticism to stand on its own and not be uh
dislabeled as anti-Semitic. I wanted it, you know. Wait, what
is NH?
What is that? I don't think I can say that on the stream. I would
if I could, though. Oh, we're actually on kick. You could totally
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait. It just never mind. I know. I just
never mind. Can I say the on kick? Uh, soft day a Yes, I can
actually say that. You can actually say the soft day. Yeah. Oh,
it stands for pile. Thank you. Yeah, there you go. It's a good
song. Did you guys review it? It's not bad. Yeah, we reviewed
we listened to that multiple times. I can't believe Wait, you
can actually say the soft day on kick. That's awesome. I got
to start streaming a kick. Yeah. Yeah. It's good stuff. It's
good stuff. Yeah. Interesting. So, uh yeah, I was just trying
to figure out like the lay of the land with like the uh commentary
community versus I don't know what you guys call each other,
but I feel like there's a lot of like chat instigation there.
And and it's it's weird too cuz like I'm giving all my text on
Ethan Klein tonight and everybody's like, "Oh, fatty." Very interesting.
the uh the the bot wave that comes whenever you criticize Ethan
Klein right now. I've seen Is it Are they bots? I don't know.
I don't know if I'm just saying bots as in they don't have any
original thought of their own mindless
sneak bots. Not Yeah, exactly. They might be robots as well to
be fair. But well, it's weird because I've been making anti Ethan
Klein content for like 5 years now. Six years now. And it's like
I thought we all you know obviously So you've been an anti-semite
for six years. That's a separate No. I've been criticizing Ethan
Klein for six years. That's not also anti-semite, but it's unrelated.
He has not let it affect his criticisms of Ethan Klein. Yes.
I am anti-Semitic separately. I save that stuff for later. But
um yeah, I don't know, dude. It's just been very weird that like
like he's using dead people to attack everyone that he doesn't
like. And it's not, you know, well, I mean, it's just they've
already accepted like the whole um like drop kiwi farms logic
basically of well, this community is harassing him and they they
called the authorities on him. So,
he has to take him down and that's just just fine. Well, I'm
sure you can make the same argument for like Ke's like, oh, I'm
sure Kiwi Farms I'm sure one guy in Kiforms is something up to
Keles. You don't think that happens? Yeah. I mean, yeah, but
the thing is it's the same with with Keel. It's exact same as
Gaffles because when Gaffles was crying about Kiwi Farms, there
was no proof that Kiwi Farms had had swatted her. There was there
was no proof of that. Obviously, you can't tell which anonymous
user saw something online and decided to take action on it. There's
no way of proving that. Uh so, you couldn't prove it was Kiwi
Farm. So, you can't just go and blame the entire website for
something that might not even be someone from there. But in this
case, we've totally abandoned that and we've said, "Well, no,
obviously it was Snark. Obviously, it was Snark." Uh, so Ethan
can do literally whatever he wants. Yeah. And I had some people
saying like, "Oh, no, he's just attacking like the hypocrisy
of like how Reddit allows one community but doesn't allow the
others." But I'm like I feel like Ethan Klein's war has been
pretty obvious that he wants Snark communities banned. I feel
like I've heard him say that before, you know, that he want like
the the whole point of his crusade against Snark is that he wants
these communities and like these styles of communities like just
removed from the platform altogether. Has he not said that? Um,
yeah. He said, wow. He's I don't know if he's ever said, "I want
all these hate communities gone, but he said, isn't it like disgusting
that you can have a community like this?" And all that sort of
So, no, he holds them responsible. I have a screenshot of an
Instagram story where after the CPS call happened, he's like,
"I'm getting permits to protest outside of Reddit HQ." And then
I saw another and then like when the Taylor Loren's Ethan DMs
leaked or when she was talking to the producer, she was she was
the one that helped get him in contact with Reddit and she was
saying like there's channel like to to get the Snark thing taken
down. And that's when that's what led to that clip of him being
like saying that Reddit said, "Well, your community has engaged
in harassment, too. So if we took action only on like one side
of it, it would be like unequal enforcement." I mean it's just
obvious they do like any any degree of well I won't say any degree
because you can't prove obviously you know who's called authorities
or what but by the posting they do the exact same type of harassment
as any other hater community H3 is perfectly accurate well he
he can't be held liable for that nor can he that's what he said
during the Ryan capital not officially their their
he doesn't control what people post on the subreddit he can't
control that that's not to do with him can he control that this
entire subre that's calling you up. It's not to do with him.
It didn't matter then. Yeah. Well, see, this is why I was talking
about earlier like I hate like I mean I probably said political
on the internet like a million times, but like I really try to
keep my content like apolitical and just because like I hate
political communities on the internet because the problem I have
with political communities is they sort of encourage like the
insane behavior because the stakes are so high. Everyone's all
in cuz they feel like it it actually matters. So that they're
like willing to go to the absolute like Yeah. Exactly. I mean
they just they justify anything because it is actually like to
them it feels like super important. Whereas in like when I'm
talking about like stupid commentary drama of like oh this person
called this person a you know what you know it nobody cares cuz
it's like just stupid petty. But on the internet it's still petty
but they don't view it that way. So that you know the stakes
are raised to a much higher degree where like all this like unethical
behavior is justified even if you're against that same behavior.
You know you can you're allowed to be a hypocrite. I hate it.
Well, he assumes at this point everybody who criticizes him hates
him for unfair reasons because there was a content creator called
Vanilla M. She's like a big Tik Tocker now. She does Twitch streaming
and she mentioned that Teddy Fresh had reached out to give her
like free merch to wear or whatever.
and she on Teddy Fresh for like a minute straight and Ethan rips
the video, puts it on his Instagram, and he says, "Here's another
I need to deal with. Why can't y'all take a day off? So brave
to dogpile a creator who has had the CPS and skull sent to his
house in retaliation for thinking Israeli civilians shouldn't
be slaughtered 2 days after a terrorist executed two Israeli
embassy workers." He literally posted this. It's not satire.
It's not a mocker of him. people making fun of my dog ABDL
diaper lover merch where opted two is running short to death
really while anti-semitism exists is really up is so up it's
crazy and it's like again it's like if somebody on Kiwi Farms
literally was like swatting Keles I would still be against Keel's
campaign against Kiwi Farms because that's just one guy you know
Kiwi Farms is not like a monolith Kiwi Farms is not one guy doing
like one action against somebody. You know, it's a community,
it's a free speech community where people do whatever the they
want. There's really no terms of service on that site. And so
what if like one or two people and they're crazy, you know what
I mean? I'm sure there's crazy people in my audience. I'm sure
there's crazy people in anybody's audience that are willing to
like do some harassy
harassing crazy against other people. And I guess now you're
held responsible for that if you're My audience would never do
that. Denims, what does she do? She like watches videos where
Ethan Klein is talking about how um all of his kids and his wife
and his dogs all have the same disease and you can only get it
through eating the someone that's already got it. And then people
and then Denim's just like, "Oh, that's disgusting. That's like
really disgusting. That's gross." And now it's her fault that
CPS got called for some reason. I quoted Ethan from that clip
and there was a comment underneath my VOD being like, "You're
you're spread." Oh, so we're just spreading lies that that's
how we get Giardia.
Not. That was not a joke. They did not realize. No, I was literally
just repeating what Ethan said. I wasn't saying that. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, I'm just like thinking about this like how if I was covering
this, would I have made the same mistakes, quote unquote, right?
And it's like I would have, you know, when I cover people's videos
and I hate the video, I always say like, "Oh yeah, I'm glad we're
you guys are watching this on my stream instead of giving this
piece of [__] some view." You know, the same thing.
It's just hooking. Yeah. So I just think about it as like would
I say the things that Ethan Klein is like criticizing to to such
a strong degree. Yes. You know if if I was watch if I hated Ethan
Klein I was watching a video of him talking about his dogs like
and his kids eating from the dogs like would I watch that and
be disgusted and talk about would I sensationalize it to a degree
that's funny? Yes. Of course I would. Well, what's weird is that
he goes harder on denims for that than bad empanada for making
the video in the first place that she's in Argentina and there's
no laws in Argentina. So, but he said at the beginning of the
video he doesn't give a about how much money he has to spend
and you can technically sue people internationally for this kind
of stuff. No, there's no there's no laws in Argentina. I don't
think I don't think you're aware of this. He's uh hired mercenaries
in Argentina to deal with bad empanada. Okay, we're not going
to get much more bad empanada content. Okay, that's his recourse
there. Money is no one. RIP furious George. So, what do you all
think of Bad Pinata? Is he like do you all think of him as badly
as Ethan Klein thinks of him or like what's the full story? Cuz
I don't know that much about bad crazy,
you know, doctor political radical guy, but I mean he's had some
funny moments and some of the he is
a you say you like Nick Fuentes cuz he's funny. Vanip Panata
is like leftist Nick Fuentes in the sense that I know a bunch
of leftists and liberal and even like liberals and progressives
watch him but he's so embarrassing to affiliate with publicly
or to say that that they they pretend not to or they just they
say that they don't but I know secretly they are in the same
way that like I know a bunch of like MAGA people and conservative
people they have to be ambiently consuming Nick Fentes cuz he
has to be coming up on their timeline but they'll never say that
they watch him feel like that's Ben Bonado but just for the left
interesting okay cuz like I don't know that much about him and
I don't So, you know, I I tried to look him up on Kiwi Farms.
They didn't really have that much information on him. So, like
I was trying to figure out like what has he done? Like what is
he what is the crazy [__] that he's done? I'm sure
he's done crazy. I just couldn't find much information on him.
I think it comes down to doxing and then supporting his community,
doxing people. Yeah. Like those those seem to be the worst allegations.
And I think most of the people who treat him like he's the biggest
baddest boogeyman on the internet um will defend people who do
those exact same things on their side or will associate with
them. So I just don't tend to take it that seriously. He talks
like somebody I actually like as a creator so or I've heard this
at least. So I'm like not a huge fan but he's also funny. So
well I mean psychopaths psychopaths tend to be very funny even
if they're like totally like morally reprehensible. a clip of
him playing that terrorist game that you play as Okay, I had
a debate with Connor about this on my own show cuz I I talked
about this multiple times like I know Ethan Klein talks about
like when bad bada like you know played the video game where
he's Ethan Klein there is a very similar moment where like Nick
Fuentes was playing GTA V and he
watched that on stream a couple times. Yeah. Yeah. Ben Shapiro
is like I'll never debate Nick Fuentes because he killed me in
GTA. I always thought that was the most in the world from Ben
Shapiro. But you know, is it similar to what Bad Appanata did
or is it like different there? Yeah, 100%. It's the same. Yeah,
because I was debating with Connor. I was debating with Connor
about this cuz Connor was like, "No, it's reasonable for Ethan
to hate that." And I'm like, "Is it though? That sounds like
weak." I don't know. Oh, it's reasonable for you to hate that
like somebody joked about like your wife. Like you could be mad
at I don't even
say that to cry about this. It's like actually just okay to complain
about it. It's just like, well, it's like a video game. It's
like Ethan himself said, what was it? If there's another Holocaust,
Bench Pier should be the first one. Hey, he was suspended for
that. Gas Chambers. Yeah. First one in the gas chambers. Yeah.
He said that and we're supposed to take it seriously when he's
like, "Oh, Ben went around in a terrorist game and said he was
hunting for secretaries."
Ethan Klein barred from video sharing platform for a week after
saying that if there's another genocide of he hopes the conservative
pundit quote gets gassed first or last. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, he
said like crazy, but again, I I've said crazy, but I still have
like standards and whatever, right? Like, I'm very anti-doxing
and stuff like that. So, it's like,
you know, starts crying about doxing if you were doxing, you
know? And that's the thing, right? Is it's like you're making
statements about, you know, political statements about how you
think someone should be for their beliefs or statements they've
made or propaganda they've pushed or whatever. And bad's done
the same thing. It's like you can't really cry about that when
you're engaging in the same. Yeah. Also, did I hallucinate this
or did weren't there leaked messages where Keeles admitted later
that she was like intentionally trying to antagonize Kiwi Farms?
Like she was traveling and taking selfies of herself in different
like hotel rooms and places uploading it to see if Kiwi Farms
could find her. Did I just make this up? I swear I saw these.
I feel like I'm pretty I I very
I remember that. Yeah. Yeah. I know. I mean, she was obviously
like just saying like the pretty much like I I remember like
like a week after she uploaded that video like I'm being hunted
by Kiwi Farms, she was posting where she was in Ireland. So,
I don't know. I remember that poutine and Ireland or whatever.
It's like there's like three places that serve poutine. Yeah.
But yeah, I don't know. Yeah. Yeah, I'm not trying to like defend
Bad Impot or like whitewash like anything that he's done that's
terrible, but I'm just trying to like figure out I remember that
one argument about like the video game stuff and I'm like is
that really what we're focusing on? Like if he's doxed people
and like done terrible [__] like that, that should
be like the thing that's focused on. But like him playing a video
game where he pretends to Ethan Klein's wife like who the who
actually cares about that? Well, he does because when Hassan
talked to him on Noah Samson's charity fundraiser, he was like,
"What happened there?" And I'm kind of not just lied about it
cuz he said I only talked about he said he made a joke about
Ethan Klein being onic or something and then he said I never
said uh Ela Klein's name and that's true but it's slippery cuz
he said I'm looking for secretaries while he's like playing and
but Hassan didn't know that to catch him on it so he just moved
on. He's slimy. I mean he's a he's a troll clearly right? But,
you know, and and the one thing I don't like to defend Ethan
a little bit, like the one thing I don't like is how like Hassan
and like none of these people that watch bad empanada's videos,
like they'll never admit like what bad empanada is or who he
is as a person, like the terrible [__] he's done.
They'll always like play ignorant, be like, "What? I'm just watching
a video. Who cares?" You know? They'll never admit like, "Yeah,
this guy is like the number one thorn on Ethan's side." like
they'll never like actually like be honest about like the the
type of character that he is. Has um before Hassan started watching
his stuff, he was saying how insane he was and then now that
watches stuff he says something like, "Oh, we've got differences
in tactics. I don't think all the stuff he does is good." This
sort of stuff. That's that's usually how he handles it. I don't
think he just totally ignores it. Well, well, still even still
to that point, it's like he doesn't admit that like he's playing
the video cuz he's like, "This is the craziest that, you know,
really will piss Ethan off." You know, he always like is like,
"Oh, this guy's fine." Or, well, I don't know if he says that,
but you know, it's kind of like it's just because it's the craziest
guy that will piss Ethan Ethan off. I don't think that's true.
That's the only reason he plays videos. I think they are like
um are they good? They're quite popular and um you know, they
are watchable at least like he's not a bad content creator if
you know what I mean, right? Are his videos good against Ethan?
Like his critiques,
they're mixed. Sometimes he just like will just run with something
because he knows he can. Um, some some of them are better. Time
the stuff that he sources like, you know, sometimes you can't
trust exactly what he says, but like the source might be good.
Like, you know, it's like, "Oh, I didn't know that clip existed."
That sort of thing. It's like again to the Nick Fuentes comparison,
like Nick Fuentes like probably has a lot of good information
in the Middle East, but like he obviously has like a bench or
like an agenda. Exactly. Exactly. Exactly. So, it's like the
same thing where it's like he might have like good information
or like knowledge on the topic, but he clearly has like a very
like devious bent to it. You know, I will say the only bad videos
I've ever watched is like his Xanderhal videos.
Xander is just so funny to me. The Cameron F5 video went hard
on the whole time. He made a video on Cameron. Yeah, dude. I
need to watch that. That's crazy. Yeah, I feel like I watched
also his video on like the Billy Mitchell drama and stuff, which
is very funny to me that he was just covering that at all. But
yeah, it was good. Just Doug, did you skim through this article?
No, I'm not skimm through it. I was trying to get these avatars
working. For some reason, Augie isn't working with my uh overlay.
I have no idea why. Wait, you have like a picture drawn for me?
Uh yeah, I've got a guy in my audience who does runs this like
really fast. Um but this is crazy. Who he drew this tonight?
Well, I mean, he uses like impaint and like AI to make stuff,
but yeah, he
I just noticed I have one. It's so cute. It looks cool as Yeah.
Augie the There's supposed to be a speaking face, too. When you
speak, it's supposed to switch to this. But here, hold on. I'll
uh I'll move you in and move you out and maybe it'll Dude, this
looks awesome, though. I don't even Yo, let's see. Sorry. I moved
you and moved you out. See if that'll fix the overlay. Oh, nice.
Dude, this looks awesome. What the Why are you a frog? Why are
you Why are you Kermit? Uh, I don't know. Uh, we have I have
muppets for people. He sounds like Kermit the Frog cuz he's Canadian.
Yeah. Also, I sound like Kermit the Frog. Did you guys see Bob's
Only Fans link tonight? His official Only Fans. The official
Bolex Only Fans. No, stop. I I tweeted on Twitter that I was
going to dox anyone that sends me like the videos from that page.
I sent a picture of
dropped. You did?
[__] I mean, he deserves it, but that's still sick
as That is terrible. Is Blowbacks, y'all? How do you Is it Blow
Blacks or Blowbacks? It's Bo Black. Bo Blacks.
In his Only Fans bio, it said Blowbacks.
That's how he typed it. Oh, okay. He like Boax. Yeah, Boax. Well,
Tommy C says Bobacks.
Like the new Christine Weston Chandler to me. Tommy D. Why are
you guys so mean to Tommy C? He's a good guy. Yeah, he's a good
guy. Kind of a good guy. Total unforced error. Just I I got to
be honest. On a live stream just out of nowhere. I fully plan
to review the Chud logic drama. I haven't like died. You're laziest.
I saw you tweet like two weeks ago. I'm streaming next week.
Like, okay, man. Dude, I'm I'm very busy guy. What can I say?
You know, but uh yeah. Why you guys Well, okay. I don't want
to talk about the current drama. Like, why are you guys hate
him in the first place? Like, what what's wrong with them? I
hate Tommy C in the first place. Yeah. Um, why do I hate so much?
I don't I didn't really hate him. I don't even really hate him
now, you know? It's just like he's just really dumb.
Commentary is just really bad. He's got unearned confidence.
He has this whole um like uncle dynamic with Nick where he's
like you know sees Nick as like this little baby bird that he's
raised up and allowed to leave the nest and just protect him
all the time and takes his word as as literary sight like oh
well Nick thinks Nick thinks Nick thinks every five seconds when
his live stream he does do that a lot dude I got to be honest
I watched bro Tommy sees like basically the reason why I stream
as like that might be like a horrible thing to admit. I know
you guys did what was it that Instagram [__] or something
and Tommy saymed you for it or some [__] like that.
No, no, no. Okay. Well, first of all, that was like the one time
me and Tommy were ever fighting. He completely screwed me over
in that situation, by the way. I was totally in the right. I
had all these like losers come on and admit to the up of ring
and then everyone that covered it was like auggie ring and I'm
like no I brought the people on and question them about it and
held them accountable for what they did to it up and for some
reason I got blamed for the whole situation even though I was
never involved. I got over in that situation. But uh dude, no
before that dude. Tommy see he's a you know he's a commentary
OG. He comes from a different time. You know he's uh yeah sometimes
you got to take the dog old dog out back. I have people saying
that I need to give him a me and Nick need to give him a fireside
chat. Is that I again I need to review the Chudlogic drama. I
haven't seen it. I I know he's like upset at Chudlo Logic. Um,
probably because you go after him, I assume. I don't know. Well,
yeah, but I mean the the justification is like the New Year's
stream basically.
The best was he blamed Chud for all of the New Year's stream
and then we had to go review it and it's like all you starting
but Yeah. Well, okay. I was going to see you say that. It's like
I was a my behavior on that stream was atrocious. Like I basically
did every sing like at the same time. Total Destiny Death. Total
Destiny Death. That was it. Okay. every there was like there
was like three things in that stream. It was like the Destiny
conversation.
Uh there was there was Bax and then there was Kinetic Kell and
it's like I instigated all three of those conversations, dude.
The connect the neck. That was also
dude. Oh man, I I kind of felt bad for that cuz I was like I
was like that I was going to be I was kind of being a little
bit gay on that whole thing. But it was funny, dude. It was good.
But no, it's like I did everything. Like why why am I not getting
the same amount of um cuz you're one of the boys and Chud's not.
Ch's on the outs. Willy Max said Willie Max said that or is okay
but Chud's not. So Tommy's acting on Did he say that? Uh no he
didn't say that. I'm just assuming Tommy C said it so it means
Willie or Nick said it basically
sentient thoughts. W
uh the twisting there. Tommy does say a lot of the time he's
like I told it's like he kind of confirmed some of the memes
where it's just like we were talking about this guy in the group
chat. We were talking about this thing in the group chat. I was
talking with like these guys about this thing the other day.
It's like why why are you why would you what what were they talking
the group chat being but they were they were talking amongst
themselves basically
um about Willie and Tommy have been having conversations about
how Chud's a snake because Chudum
when Willie was responding to the criticism of his first Destiny
video if you remember all that stuff uh Chud messaged Willie
and said hey Willie I heard you're crashing out do you want to
come on stream and talk to people about it or have a conversation
about it. And Willie took that to be Chud snaking him, I guess,
farming him for content. Yeah. And Willie was upset about that
until Tom. I mean, you know, my criticism won't be like super
accurate cuz I barely remember this. I remember agreeing with
your original criticisms. You guys like
in that debate about the first video, right? I remember the debate.
Yeah. Yeah, I remember the debate, of course. But like you guys
went on Willie for like a while. I do remember after that debate
you guys were like very hard on Willie after that. I don't know
if that was like I don't know if that was like deserved or not
but I remember it was what did he do after that whole situation?
Why did that continue for so long? Well, he just kept acting
like a [__] He was on Twitter arguing down with people
like 50 replies deep with morale. Um and he was just saying like
the most un Wasn't it like the next day though like after the
debate? Um, it happened for like it was for like at least 3 days
after he came on my stream and then it's been he is like endless
like snide comments here and there. Um, was he not allowed to
have like
distaste of you after you down for so long? You can have distaste.
Talk about it though. Say it with your chest. Defend it. Don't
do some snide because I'm here. I'm willing to talk to Willie
M anytime. Willie M just isn't willing to put up and face any
criticism. That that's the issue. He won't sit there and make
snide remarks and say J and Queen should be grateful that I put
Destiny's death rate to them in my video cuz it warns them. It's
like okay okay you are like actually do you have a mental disability
or he's saying like I I take um firstir firsthand evidence to
be better than secondhand evidence and what he means by that
is I prefer talking to people involved rather than getting screenshots
from the internet even though obviously one is external evidence
that can be verified and the other one is just testimony just
like the the most absolute things that you cannot in in good
conscience claim to be like some you know researcher who owns
Hassan for getting everything wrong and epically debunks people
all the time while saying that just portrays that you have a
fundamental lack of understanding of like how to process evidence
and like read a situation. Interesting. Yeah. So he I remember
like one thing he said was like Destiny had made some comment
about how he wanted he wanted to like shoot you guys or kill
you guys or something like that and really was like that's he
wanted more than that. Said he wanted to like there was like
a whole gay fantasy about slicing your balls off thing. Yeah.
that that made it into court. They talked about cutting the balls
off or some that's crazy. And Willie was like, "That's awesome."
or something. Willy Willie basically said um he's laughed. He
he said I don't care that this happened because Queman said he
wants to stomp Yeet into the dirt, which is obviously me talking
like we got to destroy this guy. It's not me saying I want to
go to Yeet's house and shoot him in the head. That's obviously
not why I'm saying that. Yeah. Um so he just drew a false equivalency
and then said, "Well, so I don't care." So it's like, okay, you
just swipe. I think he said, I should care. I think the direct
quote was something like, I should care about this, but I find
these guys really annoying or some like that. He's like, these
guys are so annoying that I don't really care that Destiny threatened
them, that he pushed for their death. That to me that like first
impression that comes off as like honest though. It's like, you
know, he he feels he's like, I should be against this, but I
[__] I hate these guys. Fine if it's just that, but
I think and pretending that Yeah. Well, sorry. Yeah, you just
draw mad about skulls at us. You Yeah. Okay. I heard you guys
say sweeping. This is like a different discussion. Do you guys
think like Turkey Tom swept for Destiny like back in the day?
Cuz I've heard this before and I've never understood this argument
cuz I always felt like Tom like distanced himself like before
like this came out. But no, 100%. He swear for Destiny. Just
go watch his like Destiny documentary. It's like the most like
the IRL video he made. Yeah. Yeah. Um like he does he there are
like so I mean I don't know how associated you ever were Destiny.
It seems like Nick and Tom at least compromised serious positions
to hang out with this guy. I don't feel like it would be cool
by Nick and Tom's usual standards that they would lay out in
like videos and live streams to be hanging out with someone who
knowingly at the age of like 26 messaged a 15year-old girl got
photos from her said about how it was so hard to say no talked
about how massive to her and sent the photos around in his group
chat talking about you know wanting to her basically yeah I remember
this I I knew about that situation cuz I used to watch the kumate
back in the Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I used that was on the Kumat. I
used to watch that show. And did he know the girl's age or Yeah.
Yes. He knew he doubled down on it multiple conversations after.
Well, I remember like after the DM at some point he learned her
age and then like after 100% at the time of conversation. At
the time of conversation. Okay. Cuz I remember at some point
he figured the age and then he was like he met he miss a message
where he was like like it's so hard to like say no sometimes.
But yeah, that that was the point. He's saying like but she was
15. Dude, it was so hard to say no. That's his quote when he's
talking to his friends afterwards. So, at some point that conversation,
he knows she's 15. She wants to Yes. say no. Damn. And so, yeah.
I mean, yeah, that is hard to defend. The thing is like I remember
like I watched that back at the time, but then like I don't know.
I guess I just didn't care cuz Destiny was making good content
at the time. So, it's like it who cares? Yeah. So, it's one thing
to watch the guy, but when you're going to make a video doing
like doing a documentary on him and it's like you're just like
sucking and you don't like ask him about that and like press
him. Well, I mean, it's not it's not even that. It's like Tom
would take a strong like condemnation stance on that with other
people, but there is not a condemnation where he's like this
guy's a piece of on Destiny. Nor is there for, you know, any
of the politically radical speech that Destiny's engaged in that,
you know, Nick now claims to have an issue with when it comes
to her son. you know, Destiny saying the the um firefighter stuff
happened before any of them sort of cut off. Um there's uh accusing
President Sunday and Donut Operator of being with no evidence
which hit minimal criticism. Um there was man like threatened
DOS kid. There's the endless examples of doxing. There's the
um fact that in Turkey Tom's video he literally just totally
skims over the Mr. or Destiny report and said it says, "Oh, well,
everyone says there's nothing to this, so I don't really care
about it." Basically, is the gist of what he says about it when
if he' actually looked into it, he would have found out more
information about, you know, how Destiny was essentially abusive
towards Anna and um Mhm. Anna was perfectly happy to talk about
that stuff, by the way. Yeah, perfect. I attest to that. Yeah.
Yeah. So, like there there's just a laundry list of things that
were ignored that would usually
uh set off like the alarms or the I I would have a problem with
this alarms to all to I think a lot of commentary creators that
that were just totally happy to like hang out with him. Willie,
Tom, Nick. Yeah. Interesting. Yeah, I know about some of that
stuff. Um the firefighter like with the that he threatened to
kill or whatever or sorry, there's two situations. There's like
one situation where like he threatened to kill the kid that was
dosing him. I kind of sympathize with him on that take cuz I
don't know. Okay, but here's the thing. You realize like the
solution to that was literally stop using Skype and use ventrillo
instead, right? Was it a Skype only issue? Yeah. Yes. Interest.
Oh, I thought he was dodoing him on Twitch. No, he was doing
there was a way you could grab people
Starcraft via Skype and if you added them to your friends list,
you would get their IP or some interesting. Okay. Cuz I've had
people like So I've had similar situations where people would
just like spend all day long just like flagging my YouTube channel
and like every day I'd try to go live like I just wouldn't be
able to stream on my YouTube because people would just be constantly
sending in like false reports and stuff. Yeah. And I have felt
that murderous rage, you know, I'm not going to lie. Like I have
I have felt that before. So when I saw that situation even about
streets, no, I didn't go that far. But I as far as I went it
was just like DMing my friends being like, "Oh, I want to kill
this guy." But it's like, you know, I have felt that like sensation
before, but it's like, so when I heard about that on, you know,
the kumate and stuff like that, I was kind of like, okay, I kind
of I empathize with this a lot. But it's easy to empathize with,
but I mean, it's just like if you interrogate the actual story,
it's just like it's like the idea that you were like, cuz he
doesn't just defend feeling that way. He defends the act of going
in theory, right? Yeah. Well, he defends it as if he was like
planning to do that. Yeah. And he says he was planning to do
it. multiple times that he was planning to do it and he's doubled
down saying he
never the exact gun that he bought. No, wasn't it the first?
Yeah. And he said he literally got his firearms license to do
that, you know, everything like absolutely. So, but it's just
an issue of use ventrillo, don't use Skype and that that was
it. But he has somehow convinced everyone convinced the entire
commentary community for years that actually no, he was just
being he had no other choice. He had to go and kill this kid.
That's just not true. Right. Yeah. I remember hearing about the
story. In my mind, I was just like, ah, I've wanted to people
that my channel, so it you know, you know, but it's Yeah, I see
what you're saying there. There's the other thing like the the
moment where I turned on Destiny. This might be a soy argument
for me, but it was the firefighter kid. Like I know you guys
are probably pro that stuff, right? Like we're Yeah, I don't
give a [__] about that really.
Or fighters or anything, so I'm like very like
[__] from a business perspective. I think he burned
a bunch of connections he didn't have to burn. Oh yeah, for sure.
I don't like it either. Well, that's fair. But like I I just
remember like when he was like, "I don't give a about this guy
dying." And like I remember I was like arguing with Aiden about
this like one night or something and Aiden was like if you have
like political positions like it's okay to like be fond of you
being I don't see that. I mean I can see it's like funny and
base but it's like that's awesome. I don't know. I don't know.
I just like I can I can just see like the problem is I just see
like my you know grandpa or something just being like a MAGA
boomer and it's like would I be fine with him being like just
gunned down just because he likes Trump like you know and and
Aiden kept bringing up like oh well he had tweets on his account
like subing like Ukraine stuff and I'm like so he had a bad take
like who the cares right like I'd say at least from Desessie's
perspective there he did say he'd be fine with his parents getting
gunned down at a similar thing. Well see that's psychotic to
me that's psychotic to me too. I like that. That's just the kind
of stuff that I'm just like that doesn't make it better. But
I mean, hey, if he's
if he's consistent, you know, it's like the people who would
like uh applaud that. Like I understand the consistency there,
but it's like I you're just totally inhuman. You're like a lizard.
I such a weird Well, I mean, if you just blocked his son on Twitter,
to me that's inhuman, you know, like I don't know. Uh that might
be a kindness, but Well, it depends like why he blocked him.
Maybe it's cuz he blocked his son cuz he's like, "Holy, you're
going a little bit." Have you guys seen Destiny's son's Twitter
recently
about that? Yeah, we try not to do that as well. Yeah. Okay.
Is that a bad Sometimes. Well, like sometimes there are things
that are just so funny. But yeah, I just try not to.
I've discovered it today and and learned that he followed me.
I didn't know that and I didn't know whether to like soft block
or or what cuz I'm pretty sure he's a minor and I felt like it
it feels weird but I didn't do anything. Yeah. No, that's fair.
I mean Yeah. Yeah. But no, I saw that. But um yeah, I don't know
like his take of like, oh, I don't give a my parents for like
just gunned alive on a Trump rally just because they support
Trump. I'm like 50% of the country supports Trump, you know?
Like to me that's a crazy position to hold. But I don't know.
It's like you're cool with like 50% of the country just being
gunned down just because they like Trump. Not even like I don't
even think like everyone that likes
when where it came down to his argument wasn't just that if you're
a passive Trump express if you're going to rallies like you're
showing active support to Trump then then you're a fair target
but at that point you are basically just saying like what then
like a Twitter post okay like you go and hunt someone down for
a proTrump Twitter post like what are we saying at this point?
Everything breaks down if you're going to let people target each
other for political speech. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. Like if if well
that's the that's an interesting distinction cuz like if you
go to a proTrump rally does that mean that you endorse like you're
super first of all that you're super cognizant of every position
that Trump holds or every position you must hold as a MAGA voter.
Yes. Destiny's position. Yeah. Well I here's the thing, right?
So I saw like commentary commentary swept super hard for that
take. I do agree with that. Um, this was before I even returned
to the internet, but of course I still saw that. And so I was
I remember like DMing Dior. I was just like, "What the why is
everyone supporting this?" If Hassan said the same thing, everyone
would be up his ass. You know, Hassan said like, "America deserved
9/11, which I think is actually a much more defensible position
than like the Destiny firefighter thing." Uh, but Destiny says
this and everyone just like immediately like is totally like
understanding of nuance and everything and they they can sort
of defend like where he's going with that. I just thought it
was ridiculous to me. So that's kind of when I turned on Destiny
when I was just like, "All right, if this was the song saying
it, if this was Ethan Klein saying it, because remember at the
time Ethan Klein was very disliked by commentary." Yeah. I mean,
everyone would have like lost their [__] So, I don't
know. That's kind of when I turned, but then the revenge stuff
came out and I was like, "Yeah, this guy is just a loser." I
don't know. But yeah, it's not on the non sharing of sexual imagery.
Oh, what did you say, Queen? I said it's not it's nonentual sharing
of sure you get terms right glasses pushes up glasses true you
mean like the the brutal the community exactly dude people getting
mad over
there Tommy hates the as well Tommy I did I did see that part
like I was like I've literally I have a tweet that has like 30,000
likes on Twitter calling Destiny a for that whole situation
with the people who are criticizing this Yeah, dude. 30,000 people
like that. I'm like, there's no way Tommy didn't see this. Like
the I don't know. I think it's fair to call Well, I mean, I don't
think he's literally like a but like I think it's, you know,
it's a form of consent violation. Yeah. Well, I that's what I
felt like the, you know, the the commentary was is like he doesn't
care about a woman's consent, you know, in this context. So,
it's like you can say that about him and it's not that crazy.
He's spiritually.
Yeah, exactly. I try not to be hyperbolic about him. I wanted
to respond just like absolutely spiritually and like as he continues
to commit bad acts, he loses his beard and his hairline and looks
more and more like a like every day. Yeah. I haven't been following
him recently. Have you you've been covering like the the court
stuff? Like what's been going on with that lately? Has he been
um I mean is he like just completely destroying Pixie and Core?
Like what's going on there? Uh it's basically like it it sort
of like bogged down in
Pixie wanted to basically block him from talking about the case
as much on social media and it bogged down in like a hearing
over that. So, it's been like that's basically been all of it.
And through that, somebody came forward who said they were sent
a video of Pix Pixie in November of 2024. And Desi's previous
argument to that had been or sorry, videos of Pixie, like the
same videos that got released, I think. And Desi's argument to
that previously was, "You can't sue me under this law cuz it
started in October of 2023 and I sent the videos in April of
2023 or 2022, whatever. I think it's 2022." Um, yeah. So, it's
like he sent the he sent the videos like 8 months before the
law came into effect, so he can't sue me. Um, and then a woman
came forward and said, "No, no, no. I was sent the Pixie video
after this date." And they have logs like telling their friends
about these videos, but not cuz Destiny deleted his messages.
They don't have the actual messages from Destiny. Right. And
so,
cope after that. A woman different than like the person in the
leaks. Yeah. Well, I mean, we're going to say we can literally
say Pixie cuz she's named in the lawsuit and stuff. Oh, okay.
Pix here. Okay. Okay. I see where you're going. But um but yeah,
this woman came forward and said like I was sent these log or
sorry, I was sent these videos and here's logs, Discord logs
of me talking about it. And I still have these logs. I have like
screenshots of these logs and it's like basically contemporaneous
evidence for in March of I think it's March of 2023,
she was talking about videos that you don't learn about until
November of 2024. Yeah. So it's like how the did she know about
these? But now Destiny's basically said that like now he's trying
to cope and say like oh well she went through my computer and
found all these videos actually and so that's how she knows about
them and it's like why does that what does that matter like how
she found them? Wait, say that again. It mean it seems to have
been like sent them or something, right? It can't just have been.
Yeah, cuz the allegation isn't that they were recorded non-conensually,
it's that they were shared non-consentually. Yeah, but this the
same woman Oh, so she found them on his computer but just on
like the hard drive. He says he says that he's claiming but like
he has no evidence of that that I've seen. He hasn't introduced
any evidence of that in court. So I would love to see any evidence
of that potentially. Well I mean wouldn't that be like proving
a negative like how like proving that he didn't send them or
something or am I missing something here? Uh it wouldn't be proving
that he didn't send them. it would give a like plausible deniability,
like another possible explanation for how she'd know about those
videos. Cuz otherwise, she basically guessed two women that appeared
in non-consensual
uh audio or video with him. And she she guessed these names before
anybody could have known about them. Okay. And she didn't guess
any non-names. She didn't guess like, oh, it's like this person
or this person. She guessed like actual people who were in some
of the leaks. Yeah. And so it's like, well, why did she tell
somebody that she was sent videos super recklessly by Destiny
um of people that she recognizes from the stream and then those
videos later came to actually we we found out they exist through
another leak. Yeah. So, it's like it's I don't know. It's uh
probably going to go to Discovery, I think. I don't know if he'll
win or lose. It'll depend on if they can find probably like real
evidence of him having sent those videos again. And realistically,
if he deleted them soon enough, uh that evidence might not exist
anymore. So interesting. Okay. You might get out of the Pixie
lawsuit. Uh kind of scot-free. Other people have lawsuits. I
don't know if those are ever going to move forward. I have no
idea. A lot of people are just like, "Yeah, I don't want the
harassment from this guy. I'd rather just move on." Yeah. Well,
he's got like a really like highprofile lawyer working with him
too, right? Like Yeah. The guy who was the lawyer for Prince
Andrew. Yeah. Andy B. Andrew Breler. That's crazy. Yeah. He got
the He got the lawyer, the guy who makes me. Yeah. The victim
blamer. Um, yeah. So, I don't know. It's like it could I really
don't know how it would go. And I assume that if you if it's
like a tossup that that kind of goes to the defendant, right?
So, so have any like legal YouTubers been covering this? Like
all the Nick Reca Orbiter guys, have any of them been covering
this? Potentially criminals done a couple of them. I think because
of where it's like bogged down, they try to only do like updates
once in a while. Yeah. Um, yeah. It's just like it's going to
take a little bit. will get the ruling on this like what they
call like a preliminary injunction soon. Legal mindset did look
at it before. I don't think he's looked at it recently. Um all
of them looked at it like initially and then I don't know if
they've all looked at it recently, but stuff just is moving forward
slowly because of this preliminary injunction hearing. So, we
just haven't seen I think they're also battling each other in
Discovery like a lot. Like they wanted uh Destiny's like Google
Drive history for the past 5 years or something and he's like
fighting that. He said he'd rather kill himself than give that
up. And interesting. Yeah. Yeah, I mean there's probably I guess
I can see why he would not want to show that. I don't know. I
don't know if that's weird or not to like restrict showing that,
but
um I mean he definitely wouldn't want it made public in any way.
And I think it would have to be like lawyers going through it
and determining what could be relevant to the case, right? Yeah.
Legal mindset. I only know who that guy is cuz Ethan Ralph did
like a really funny rant on him once. Lady boy mindset. Lady
sucker. More like it. I don't know who that guy is. What you
think about the Ethan lawsuit? Okay. Uh E which Ethan lawsuit?
The React lawsuits? Oh, we were talking about that earlier. Yeah,
I can't support it. I don't know. I feel like uh you have to
be like support this, especially as like a React streamer. Have
you Have you like actually looked into like um No, I haven't
watched Ethan Klein's video or read the lawsuit. I've I've I've
so I know Connor's looked into it. He told me a little bit about
it and bass one he told me or whatever. It sounded like complete
uh
he's very like neutral on like commentary stuff like he he's
he's more so like you know let's see both sides but he was telling
me he was like yeah like this is like turning on Ethan worthy
level and he was telling me a lot about it like the denim stuff
specifically. I mean I was talking about that a lot before like
you came in here but yeah it seems like pretty stupid to uh support
that. I I don't like the president that it could set. I don't
like uh who he's even going after. At least with Denims, I feel
like the Denims case I got I'm so glad that Connor took over
Twitter versus cuz like Boax can't even express his own opinion.
So the idea that he's going to be able to sift through and pick
out both sides of an argument on Twitter and present them like
relatively fairly is like that's that's a totally insurmountable
task for this. Yeah,
actually I've been surprised several times like wow this would
be very easy to just like
stance on this but no it is actually kind of both sides. I'm
I'm always shocked seeing that in Twitter versus Yeah. I mean
like to me like the I don't really watch much Twitter versus
or internet versus like to me the format is very just like you
just relay the tweets from both sides. Yeah. No, I I watch like
if I'm like super invested in a topic and I've got nothing else
to cover on it, I'll pull that up on stream and it's like, you
know, does he actually give us opinion there? No, but you know,
the opinion comes through. Boax's opinion always came through
in Twitter versus Do you know what I mean? Like you could always
tell which side Bob was on from Twitter versus cuz he's capable
of like fairly presenting the sides. It was like depending on
which tweets he shows for me. Exactly. always like here's a bunch
of epic sick owns for my side and it's like saying
but Connor is more like I've noticed like more there are actual
points from tweets on on both sides you know there'll be someone
making an argument and they'll present someone making the counter
argument like that where it's like oh my god thank there's actually
some like uh you know effort put in well I mean like that's how
me and Connor like so me and Connor like did RFC show for a little
bit and then back in 2023 we did like red fox comms where we
just did like 10-minute commentary videos and like whatever the
trending topic was. We love just like looking at the topic and
just like actually thinking about it critically and seeing like,
okay, where are both sides coming from? Where do we stand on
this? Blah blah blah. Stuff like that. I feel like nobody does
that. I feel like people are just like, okay, what's the side?
What's the pick? You know, where we where are we uh what's the
move here? And it's just it's much it's much more fun to analyze
drama when you're just looking at it like just okay, what do
we actually think about this? And rather than just Yeah, exactly.
Just go and let me know like what you're going to say before
you even look at it. Yeah. Oh, no. It's It's brutal, dude. When
I make anti Ethan Klein videos or anti Ethan Klein tweets or
even like when me and Connor used to do our like daily commentary
channel back in like 2023, our channel would not grow because
we kept like switching sides every video. Not because we were
like grifting or anything, but just because like every time we
make a video about like an ongoing topic is Yeah. Perfect. Yeah,
exactly. So we couldn't really grow. Yeah, exactly. That's the
growth mechanism is when you're just add the dick. Yeah. When
you're on one side, that's why we quit the channel ultimately.
It's just because like it just wasn't like sustainable for growth.
but uh yeah, and it's so stupid to me cuz the content's so much
more funnier. Like if I'm subbing to a channel and I never know
what their take is going to be on something, that's like super
interesting to me cuz it's like, oh, like I actually am getting
like a surprise every time I come. If something is too predictable,
if something is too predictable, I would just stop watching.
Yeah, it's like that easy. Like I I probably would still occasionally
click on a Destiny video. I don't I don't know to be honest cuz
I am just disgusted by the sight of him at this point. But I
might still occasionally video if I didn't like know 100% exactly
what this guy was going to say every time. Like I Why would I
ever look at his coverage of Assan? Why would I ever look at
his coverage of Ethan Klein? This guy is completely bought in.
Why would I ever look at, you know, Eerodite's coverage of Destiny,
for instance, other than to just like rip it apart on stream,
obviously? Like, if I was, if I was off stream, why would I ever
go go and watch something like that when I know exactly what
it's going to be? Why would I sit through an hour and a half
of something that I can basically write in my head before I go
and click on it? Well, it's funny cuz that's the same thing he
says about you guys. Like that recent clip of him, he's like,
"You guys are just
against me." Yeah, exactly. It's crazy. But no, it's like that
should be like what people are thirsting for. They should be
thirsting for a commentary channel that's like you never know
what they're going to say. You know, they could have a take on
anything. They could be like pro Ethan one day and then Aunt
Ethan the next day. You never know. But you know that their take
is genuine and something that they really believe in, not something
that's like, oh well, this is the uh you know, this is the the
take. This is the take on something. And the problem is is that
creators are not incentivized to have unique takes on anything.
Not just because it's harder to defend those takes. Like I always
thought the reason why creators like didn't have like unique
takes on something is just because like it's harder to defend.
But no, I know this firsthand from making content. The reason
why creators don't have unique takes and [__] is
because you don't [__] grow from having a unique
take. You just stagnate yourself. You don't make as much money.
You can't. It's just you need like flashoint moments, right?
Like you have to grow off of big fights with like bigger creators
and it's way less sustainable. It's so much easier to do that.
But it's like if you're a creator that just wants to have a unique
take, but you're not I don't want like for instance like I'm
not really like a big debater guy. Like I don't necessarily want
to have like a 5 hour debate every time I make a video, right?
But I feel like you have to do that because you need like that
huge moment, you know, of like, oh, this is where they stood
if you want Yeah. If you want to be unique, you definitely have
to. I think you have to do that. It's very hard to just be unique,
have unique takes, and have people like gravitate to them, but
you have to be unique, but also be like online like 20 to like
grow at all. Otherwise, you can just have unique takes, but nobody
cares because they just want that this they want a very safe
take regurgitated to them, you know? That's why like even in
politics it's like all the top creators on the left and the right
are like the most like [__] sloth like bare bones
like type of people. So
Brian Tyler Cohen or like you know just Yeah. It's like Dean
Withers or Charlie Kirk. It's like the people that are actually
like interesting like you know they're not really doing anything
like numbers wise. It's sad but uh Yeah.
You guys seeing this picture on screen right now? Yes. I I just
feel like when is this guy going to stop winning? Oh, Auggie
is going to hate this take, isn't he? When is this guy gonna
stop winning? This is apparently the guy who just won the NYC
primary. Okay. Oh my god. Hanging out with Hassan.
Wow.
That Sneo endorsed. Yes. Imagine being such a prolific political
influencer that you could get a mayor elected or through a primary
in a city. Okay. Destiny. Destiny could never. All right. Destiny
could never. Oh, you What do you mean, dude? Sne put in Dude,
Sneo put in all the work, dude. Like uh he's a Sneak's an NYC
resident, you know? Obviously, it was all his influence that
won him this. I don't even know this guy's policies. Like, why
is like I know he's Muslim. That's it. He's a Democratic socialist
part of the DSA. Oh, look who's in the replies. I didn't even
see our buddy over in the replies. Let me move the chat for you
guys. Mr. Dan can't stream over here not liking the Hassan support
for Zoron. I will lie again. He's even wearing a 9/11 truther
shirt. What is it? Paradise.
steel beams. It says about jet fuel melting steel beams, but
it's a t-shirt that said about conspiracies. So, it's like the
joke is that it's a conspiracy. Yeah, you hate to see it. Simultaneously,
America deserve 911 and it was an inside job. Okay. So, he believes
both those things simultaneously.
Let's go. Oh, man.
Oh, I forgot that. Um, yeah. Also, Anthony Weiner's election
was tonight and he got demolished. He didn't even get 10% of
the vote. God, pervert alert. Yeah. Well, I don't know if you
did you see him. He was on like the Adam Freriedeland show. He's
running for like councilman in New York City. He ran for the
[__] councilman of the second council district. City
member of city council, second council district, Democratic Oh,
is this just a primary then? And he lost. He got destroyed in
a primary with like less than 10,000 votes. This guy was This
guy was in the House of Representatives. Anthony Weiner. Got
a thousand votes. He lost to a guy named Harvey Epstein. That's
up, dude. That's Wow.
That's nuts. That's awesome. That is messed up, man. He got beat
by bigger pervert. Pervert alert. Wild. Oh
god. Yeah. I saw Sneo endorsed the New York City guy and everyone
was super mad at him. I had people in my community like they
were like, "We need to like in Sneo or something." I'm like,
I I don't even know this guy's policies. New York. I mean, New
York City, I hear it's a I've never been. So, I don't I don't
I don't know. That's the Democratic primary, I think. Right.
So, I think he won the Democrat.
Yeah. So, it's if it's a Democrat, he's going to be in New York
City is going to be a bigger, I guess. I don't know. Well, no.
No, but like I don't think the Dems don't automatically win,
right? Like the current one is a Republican candidate. That's
Eric Adams, right? Is he like impeached or something? Why? I
feel like he just got voted in. Um he
he did a deal with Trump to not get charged with a crime, right?
Did he? Okay. Yeah. He basically Trump Trump basically let it
slide because he allowed ICE to go into New York. Well, I wonder
if uh I wonder if Adams is Adams like automatically the candidate
for like the Republicans or something. I don't even know. I don't
know how go about becoming mayor of New York City. Oh, he's a
It says he's Democratic. What the I don't I don't know how their
elections work. He's independent. Okay. Weird. His Wikipedia
page says he's uh it says that he's Democrat in terms of affiliation,
but I guess in New York he must run independent. He was Dem.
Okay. All right.
All right. You guys got anything else you want to throw out?
I'll probably get it end. I'm chilling. I'm sorry I kept your
stream going all night long, but uh it was uh No, no, it was
awesome discussion. Actually, like coming to a natural end here,
so yeah, definitely good hanging out. Good hanging out with you
guys. Good catching up talking about Ethan Klein, the commentary,
Cabal War. Uh you guys need to lay off Tommy C. He's nice. Okay,
when you uh when are you going live? Uh I'll be going live very
soon covering the the conflict, the war, right? But yeah, no,
I mean uh you guys need to lay up Tommy C. He's a very nice old.
Okay, you guys need to uh respect your elders more. He's a good
guy. I literally can't cover any more of the the Tommy C stuff.
is like so boring and repetitive at this point in the game. He
has taken the knee off of his neck by just being too boring to
chug to death, you know. Damn, he owned you. He became too boring
for you to cover. He won. I didn't even
started mentioning.
I don't know why he he started talking about me cuz I'm like
I stream with Queenman. So I I feel like you don't really involve
yourself in commentary drama that much, but like you get mentioned
all the time as like because people just see you as like Queenman's
like second in something. Yeah, people are mad at Queman and
then they just they throw my name into and I I just happen to
be basically the same thing. I don't even know. Maybe that's
fair. Maybe that's a fair argument to make. I don't know. Maybe
you are
nice to everybody all of the time. I'm literally nice to all
of these people. Uh when I'm not nice, I apologize and I say,
"Hey, why don't we be friends again?" You know, here's my position
on spicy chat. You know, I like them because they're very nice
to me, but as soon as they become mean to me, which I know they
will because you guys are mean to all of my friends. As soon
as you guys become mean to me, then I would become very afraid.
But uh as of right now, they're very cool. I don't know. That's
my position. Oh, based I don't see why people have to even Scary
chat room. Very scary.
Yeah, it's crazy. That's my position to everybody. It's like
they're very nice to me and then when they become mean, I become
very scared and then I move on. So, you know, it is what it is.
You'll always have a place here. Okay. This will always be a
neutral ground where you can talk about whatever.
Yeah, totally. Neutral ground. You guys are going to snake me
one day. I know it. I know it. Tommy, I' I've been inflicted
with all this ball paranoia. I know it's going to happen. How
do you how do you snake people by literally on a public stream
saying what the criticisms are and then asking them if they want
to talk? This is like the most snake- like behavior apparent.
Well, you got to craft the criticisms, right? You got to like
come up with like the reason. It's like, why? How do we snake
this guy in a way where it looks like it's not snaking, you know?
Legendary stuff. Yeah. You guys crafted your reason. You guys
were like, "Tommy C, he's old. He's He's drunk. He's uh he's
gay." What do you guys hate Tommy C for again? He's drunk. He's
old. He's all drunk and and gay and Exactly. Exactly. You guys
will one day you guys come up with a reason for everyone. Willie
Mack, you know, he's uh Willie Mack, he uh he shields for Destiny.
Turkey Tom, he shields for Destiny. You guys keep coming after
all my friends. You guys got to chill and uh bow down and accept
the cabal narrative on everything. So true. Kiss the ring. Kiss
the ring. You guys got to Okay, you guys got to understand uh
this is my closing statement. Uh Dior always wins. Okay. Every
battle
is always won. You guys got to be careful. Pick the right side
every single time. He picks the right side. He picks the right
side. And uh you know, I feel sorry for anyone that's on the
other side, you know.
Not a good indication. Yeah, it's it's rough out there. All right,
I think I'm going to rate all relevant guys. We will talk to
you all tomorrow. Okay, go say hi to Yeah, we'll be back tomorrow.
Quick 10our stream. Yeah, thanks for coming on. We'll talk to
you later. Peace. See you. Bye. If if Denims on this platform
can't even advertise her only her only fans, Denims isn't allowed
to advertise her only fans on Twitch, but he's allowed to denigrate
her for having only fans and remind everyone she's a [__]
cuz she has an only fans. I Yeah. No, that's off. If Denims is
allowed to advertise her only fans, then I think it's fine. You're
right, Creamman. He should be allowed to say this. But she doesn't
get to advertise it, so he doesn't get to harass her about it.
I think she should be grateful for the free promotion, right?
We should be thanking Techone right now. Thanking Techie.
So, say thank you for the shout out, Techie.
I also have another piece of content. Techone got banned today,
guys. And he actually went live and talked about it and I wanted
to check that out. So, let's go. Okay. Banned for That's just
terrible. Seven days. Seven days today. That's just terrible.
He call someone else fat. Uh, I don't know what he did here.
Hold on. Can we get a Oh, is that not going to pop up? Hello.
Oh, okay. Can't can't get it. Never mind. 90 days. Sorry. We're
getting back to this. I was going to go play a clip, but I I
literally can't find it. So, they say 90 days. He said 90 days.
I started early. Whoops. Little early on the time stamp. Here
we go. Here's where it is. He's going to talk about his not 90
days. Not that 7 days is how long the ban is. We're a 7-day ban
for for techone. A little trap that I set for you, Twitch. Yeah,
I bet you didn't know that cuz I was waiting for you to do this.
Wait, 32. Oh, no.
Man, you guys, it's a new moon today. This guy thinks he's like
um This guy thinks he's like Yagami Light or you know, Leouch
or something. This guy is totally This guy's a total loser. This
guy thinks he's actually like playing chess out here. What a
f What a guy. Who Who thinks of themselves as that guy? And I
No, I can't bait you. Okay. I knew that you would do this. And
I knew the reason would be even stupider than the one before.
So, thank you for once again allowing me to showcase to the world
how truly stupid you are. Let's go ahead and talk about the hypocrisy,
the double standards, and the preferential treatment of every
single person on this goddamn platform uh running it behind the
scenes. So, yes, I have been banned once again. Found out about
what two
Oh, I mean Oh, no. I mean, no.
as [__] Oh no. It just takes it takes so long to
ramp. There's a shorter version of the clip, but I don't care.
I like the long version. Oh no,
no, no.
That's terrible. Oh, you hate to see it. Oh, boohoo.
Boohoo.
You hate to see that.
Oh, man. You hate to see that. Isn't that terrible? Yeah. Yeah,
that's a shame. That's a real shame. Go probably. Uh, we got
a nice little Twitter thread going over on
What don't you understand? Just watch. Uh, this is our reaction
to Tech being banned. No.
No. Over on X. Still not used to it being called X. Uh, here
we go. Yep. Techone been banned already. 2.8,000 likes. Uh, I
can't wait for everybody to call me the worst human being on
Earth and probably compare me to Adolf. I'm going to scroll for
two. How the this guy if this guy enters the victimhood Olympics
he's he's like the Michael Phelps. Okay, this guy is insane.
He gets banned from Twitter or sorry Twitch and he goes, "Yeah,
guys, listen. They're probably going to start comparing me to
seconds. Let's see if I can find anybody saying bad." Yeah. Claps
nice. Where where's the There it is. Yep. Great. Four times this.
He definitely he already saw that. He definitely looked at it.
Yeah, he definitely looked at it. Ger, crazy work. Just perma
this month. Well, just know this per this loser that you're calling
me made over $400,000 last month. Uh, and honestly, we're on
track to make half a million this month. So, uh, yeah, go ahead
and take that. She didn't shove it up your ass, brother. We are
killing. Money. Money really doesn't buy you. Can't buy you class,
but can't buy you class. No. [__] insane. 106,000
subs this month on YouTube, brother. That is insane, man. This
loser keeps on winning. It is nice. So, by the way, Asthma Gold,
if you're watching this and you said that's it, go [__]
yourself. Okay.
Anyways, anyways, anyways, anyways. So, I yes have been banned
once again. Seven days, boys. Seven days. Thought it was two
weeks. Two weeks. Oh, don't worry. It's only Oh, we saw the reason
there. Hold on.
and
derogatory request, graphic or derogatory statements or unwanted
content. Or it's only a 7-day ban and no pay for two weeks. That's
all right. I already turned off all the ads off of Twitch regardless.
And they can't take my sub revenue. So, I will be going live
on Twitch once I'm unbanned again, which I have a prediction.
I predict I will be unbanned in the next 24 hours. Yep. Because
I'm about to make y'all look really, really bad. And if I'm not,
oh, I got something even better for the follow-up video. So,
if you're new here, make sure to like, comment, subscribe, and
hit the bell for all notifications if you want to be ready for
that. I like to keep bullets in my chamber and only use them
when I have to. But, uh, you're kind of forcing my hand here
by me over. So, yes, I have been banned, uh, for seven days,
uh, of why. I had no idea uh until I was sent this which is obviously
why did I get banned on streamer VOD drama gaming reacted new
stellar blade great game by the way huge drama mega content what
is going on this time crazy date June 23rd 2025 at 2:26 p.m.
UTC I got to be let known why I got banned once again and I was
directed to this part of my VOD where you guys will never guess
what I was talking about. Are you like talking to somebody?
God damn it. Yes. Uh I'm I'm looking for where he got the time
stamp because this time stamp right here is content creation
date. Right. So direct time stamp UTC. So I don't know. I want
to know where he was direct June 23rd, 2025. I hope people don't
get this much info on their bands ever. Well, they said they
were going to add it and I don't know if they've added it yet.
So I hope he doesn't think this is a time stamp.
We'll see. I'm guessing he went through and found the actual
comments he made. Should be let known why I got banned once again
and I was directed to this part of my VOD where you guys will
never guess what I was talking about. You'll never guess. You'll
Was it making statements about denims again because you were
literally told not to do it in the first place? Were you doing
that exact thing you were told not to do again? Or maybe it was
um that other girl. What did he say about her? Oh, M. The Mix
one. No, I think that was 2 or 3 weeks ago. So, yeah. Yeah. I
also didn't he get banned for that? I thought he got banned for
that. No, I think that one skated by and he only got banned for
calling Froggen fat, right? Okay. And we watched and we were
like, "Wait,
that's a crazy thing to say. Isn't that sexual harassment?" That
was another crazy thing to say. I do wonder. This one I feel
like has got to be about denims. You'll never guess why I got
banned again. Guys, do we have any predictions?
I would love to know. I would love to know.
Who do you think got me banned yet again?
Yep. Yourself?
Yourself? Your own words? There it is. That dumb [__]
who's getting her ass sued. And I can't wait for her ass. The
denims make him harass her. Well, what was Denim's? Actually,
you know what? We should go see the VOD. We'll see the time stamp.
We'll see what Denims was wearing. Okay. He might have had a
He might have had a point. He might have had a point. Okay. Voodoo.
I think that's like actually Iron Mike's defense in Congress
as well. Listen, you didn't see what that was wearing.
Yeah, I had a grab. It's not my fault. Has to get perman. Yes,
I have been mass reported by Denim's community once again for
calling her a Wow.
Amazing. Amazing. And you know what's crazy? I didn't even No.
What's the What's the tweet about this? Lennis 34 viewers moving
on up in the world. Must have been doing some crazy drama. What's
up, Crispy? What's up? What's up, Chris Raiders? Hey, Chris.
That's huge. That's massive stuff, Crisp. I mean, realistically,
Chris, I know what Chris averages. That's like a big stream.
Everybody starts somewhere. I'm not talking whatsoever. I feel
like No, the more you say it though, the more I'm like, okay,
maybe he was talking.
Nope. It was fine when you first started.
Do nothing win. It is actually She is actually winning. All she
does is laugh at these people and sometimes she has her cleavage
out and they actually lose their mind. It's uh you hate to see
it. Well, you don't hate to see it when it gets techone. You
I love to see it. I just hate to see people losing their minds.
Okay. I want men to win. I don't want men to be like absolutely
like autonomous robots who see a woman with her out and have
to like make comments about it. Autonomous robots. Yeah. Like
basically just pre-programmed robots. Like hey, you can not comment
on her. That's easy. You can do it. You have the power. No, as
a woman, I love to see this. Uh, it is very hard. The need for
me to be right all the time is very difficult. I do enjoy watching
other women get to be wrong. Really, like always, just always
wrong. Terrible political takes and still win. I like seeing
that for my gender. Uh, and we hate to see it. So, obviously,
that's what's crazy. That's what's crazy. Is it crazy? Got banned.
He literally got told. What did he say about her? Well, he said
he called her a We'll see. He'll I hope he'll play the clip,
but he literally got told stop fixating on these women and calling
them or fat or whatever cuz it's really weird and they're they're
like upset like stop and he literally just keeps doing it. So,
because she said she was upset
that she was being called a [__] and then I said
if you don't want to be called that, don't have an only fans.
So, I didn't post cosplay. What about posting cosplay
or posting like cute pictures makes you Was your last girlfriend
your last living girlfriend?
Andrew also has an argument for this. If you use it's like if
you use your
in the furtherance of financial gain then you're by
Do you get to do you get to go on someone's like this? She's
not on only fans. She's on Twitch a platform that he shares with
her. Do you get to bring up
bring that up and
harass her for that? I think even if he did this, you're allowed
to harass women for whatever things you want to be honest. In
my opinion, no on a platform that has like crossplatform harassment
rules and
I think the platform is unjust for preventing you from harassing
women. Um I just want to point out that you can harass men either.
Techone ended his uh what eighty year 10y year marriage to date
a girl from only fans to date a girl whose profession was Only
Fans and to do who did like nude content as far as I know. So
I don't know where like he's standing on this as if this is like
him talking down but those are the women he likes. So it's just
it's really embarrassing when you have a preference for something
and you will talk other people for being that thing. Just shows
you don't have like a backbone. You don't know who you are. Kind
of embarrassing.
If this guy was like a Christian he was Oh, go ahead. No, I think
it's kind of easy because didn't he say he's got like erectile
dysfunction? He can't. So, it's really easy for other people
who are sexual. Uh he I think he's just gay, but yeah, he says
he can only get like dome from women. Yeah, there are allegations
of as well. I I can hear not allegations. These are in court
documents.
Allegations in court documents.
Okay. But they are Yeah, it's a little bit
allegations are a matter of public record. Yes. Yeah, that's
what we could say. Yeah. I don't know. I just to me I sorry I
want to echo the point though. I just hate when somebody is like,
"Yeah, you're so hot. I want to [__] you. I'm going
to leave my wife for you and your only fans. It's so awesome."
And then like once they once they see somebody else who they
can denigrate for it, they're like, "Yeah, shut up." Like, "Brother,
we I guarantee you didn't think your girlfriend was a while you
were like trying to date her, while you broke up your marriage
for her." Okay. Or you just hate all women, which is I mean,
I guess that's possible. Maybe that's even the most likely. Call
her that. Who knows? I got banned merely for saying if you don't
want to be called that, then don't have an only fans. No, I don't
like that. Hold on. If if Denims on this platform can't even
advertise her only her only fans, Denims isn't allowed to advertise
her only fans on Twitch, but he's allowed to denigrate her for
having only fans and remind everyone she's a [__]
because she has an only fans. I Yeah. No, that's off. If Denims
is allowed to advertise her only fans, then I think it's fine.
You're right, Queenman. He should be allowed to say this, but
she doesn't get to advertise it, so he doesn't get to harass
her about it. I think she should be grateful for the free promotion.
Frankly, you should be thanking Tech right now. Thanking Techie.
Say, "Thank you for the shout out, Techie." I mean, technically,
like, absolutely. Tech have the kind of audience. Be awesome.
Yes, exactly. That'd be awesome if posted like um new subs like
emails or something like
that. I think she could just maybe post a big revenue bump instead
of you know doxing the people who signed up for probably but
yeah. Yeah, sure. Thanks for the shout out.
She I she would absolutely farm so hard if she just posted like
a if she honestly denims just fake the bump in revenue. Okay,
sub to yourself like 500 times. Say TikT thank you for the shout
out. Post that to Twitter, get a million views, and actually
make all of your money back. Okay, super easy. Like clockwork.
It'll happen. Be very, very simple. Also, somebody linked me
this clip and said, "It comes from the man himself." Jerking
off. That's my That's my ritual. I wake up, I jerk off, and I
go do my job. But I woke up. Sorry that I I covered it up as
me scratching my leg. Thankfully, I have a very small cuz otherwise
I would have been in some Yeah, thank God.
Huh. He covered scratching his leg is what?
I'm so disgusted by men. That was what you heard there. He says
he's a very small literally literally backing his wife up. Backing
his wife's allegations up. Okay.
No, I know the it's the whole thing, right? It's like smiling
while you talk about your little while you talk about but I can
touch it without getting caught cuz I just looked like he scratched
my leg. It's all of it's like repulsive. Where where is Tommy
C? Tommy C tell us he's oversharing. He is oversharing. This
is too much. I don't know. I don't insane. If Te's gonna grift
like rightwing, I think he needs to at least be honest about
the fact that he was like in a showon bushy getting blown open.
What? I don't even know what those words together mean. Is it?
Yeah, basically. It is. That's okay. I didn't even catch the
whole thing. I just heard you say shodon busy and I I was checked
out for the rest of it. Was up. This guy was looking at um what
is it? There's some Genchin Impact character he like liked explicit
fan art of some [__] Yes. Yes. Yes. His likes. Yeah.
When he uh he went and unliked all of his [__] and
he basically was like, "Guys, I I unliked everything. Don't feel
bad." He like tal he literally posted about it, right? I had
to unlike all my [__] cuz I'm like a professional
now. I'm like in OTK now.
not smart. Wondering. Well, techie. Well, maybe you shouldn't
be saying that.
You're right. Oh, and by the way, this I'm taking you on a journey
here, right? There's levels to this [__] and I need
you guys to understand how up this is about to get. So, here
we go, guys. So, again, the woman, in case you missed last time
I got banned, which is about two weeks ago. Wow. Story time with
Techie. There's this girl called Denims who keeps on calling
me a predator, a abuser, a guy who beats women, and she's called
me a Her buddy Hassan has called me a familial obligated. That's
funny. No, you cried about that. You cried about that. You cried.
It's in his like genealogy or something, right? Yeah. Like genetically
epigenetic epigenetic memories of rape and her photos. Yeah.
Familial obligation. Do you think the is actually on the female
side? Epigenetic passing things on that they were and they're
just like, "Okay, we're not going to make this as painful for
the next person like reduces the size." Oh my goodness. Is that
possible? I feel like it's possible. Do you think they got It's
not even a What if he just has like a long [__] He's
never mind. Just keep
No. Soyone. Actually, no. We're on somewhere here. Tone has heavy
FTM vibes.
Tag. Absolutely. I could totally see Tagton being. He kind of
looks like the dude from Jubilee.
No, he kind of looks Yeah, he does. He does tell a gay story.
I feel like he kind of looks like the uh the FTM dude from Jubilee,
right? Remember the guy who sat down with Attitude?
No, that guy looked more masculine. That guy would never get
a berserk tattoo. That is the gayest nothing. They got zero punishment.
Zero. I explain to them why they're being called that. I get
banned for seven days again. I've even tried to cleave my language
when talking about this, but apparently I can't talk about Froggen.
I can't talk about Hassan. I can't talk about Denims.
I can't Was he banned for talking about Hassan? What did he say
about Hassan that got him banned? Can't talk about any of them.
Yet they can run my name through the mud for [__]
seven. No, no, no. He um he didn't get banned for talking about
Hassan, but he talked about Hassan and then uh Hassan made him
learn about his father being a or something. Apparently, he acted
like he did not know about this. What are you talking? My dad
did what? What? God
unfortunate.
Now, I don't I
in a just world. Okay. This guy and Plazookas switch audiences.
All right. In a just I believe a little bit of tinfoil hat here.
little bit of tinfoil hat. I believe that there might be some
preferential treatment going on for Hassan Denims and Froggen.
I might believe that anybody
Where did he get in trouble? I need to know. He must have somewhere
where he thinks he got in trouble for talking about Hassan, right?
Where did that happen? Cuz otherwise he's just blatantly lying
here. And I feel like I don't know why I pause and pretend that
that's absurd anymore. Thought he pushing extreme leftist agenda.
these extreme libtarss on the internet. I think someone on Twitch
agrees with them. But then that was my thoughts a couple of weeks
ago. I thought, well,
maybe they're just not aware,
you know, honestly. Honestly, maybe Twitch just wasn't aware
of what they're doing. I I I I gave them, dude, I gave them such
the biggest benefit of the doubt. I thought, you know what, Twitch,
do I called her a [__] but did you not know she's
a [__] She has an only fans. Maybe they just didn't
know. God,
like when I said I only watch her with my pants off, that's like
a compliment. I'm literally paying for her content. Twitch, what
what are you what are you doing? Why did you b me for compliment?
Positive review. That's like a 10 out of 10. Would recommend
her Only Fans to anybody if you're black. If you're backed up,
okay, Denims as Lee, that'll do it for you. backed up. He meant
black because Denim's Denim's a thick and he just assumed all
the black guys are gonna want to watch that. We know where you're
going. There's a lot of people on this platform. There's a lot
of big streamers. There's Asmin Gold, there's Faze Lacy, there's
Kai Sat. There used to be I show Speed, but they banned his ass,
too, cuz they're uh you can go watch Mizkiff. Uh Speed shouldn't
have got a perma ban, but Speed should have gotten banned for
this. He said Speed kind of went off. Some awesome [__]
dude. The one where he just tells that girl that he's a he's
just like a defender. No, no, no. Not that one. There's like
one on Valerant where he's saying he's a defender. He's like,
"I'm a sex defender." She said this guy
You can go watch Msk. The Bodez sisters. What are they doing
this time? Msk's journey to LA. Very pog. You can watch Sfan
play. Um he's playing variety games or what was he playing today?
Uh he was playing like u Death Stranding number two. You can
go watch Seir Quirk out. Uh you can go watch Sodap Poppin and
they have us. That is actually a good question. Every person
he listed before that is a total piece of [__] What
the did Sen do to get included in that list? I don't know. That's
relationship. Just kidding. Uh you know what? And many of these
YouTubers maybe they just don't know. And I genuinely believe
that. I thought there's no way there's actually a leftist agenda.
No way. Why did some Why did a sub in his chat say goon Clancy?
The comment just scrolled up. Dan Clansancy really is a gooner.
Okay.
We have to defend Dan Clansy's gooning pendant these days. No,
I'm not defending. I'm not I'm not defending, but I feel like
we only know that because of, you know, we we only know that
because of Dan Clansancy. Dan Clansancy going on like multiple
tech shows and being like, look at Twitch's new streamer like
reels, okay? And he just shows a bunch of content. Dan Clansancy
is a that's who he is, okay? And God bless him. But I don't think
these women get these women got pre preferential treatment before
Dan Clansancy joined the company. They'll get preferential treatment
after Dan Clansancy joined the company. Okay? People will do
favors for hot girls. That has just always been true. Stop complaining
about Stop pretending that it's like one guy doing it. Okay?
It's like all of men collectively. Shut the up. Don't blame Dan
Clancy for that. That [__] was there way before he
got there. Will be there way after he leaves. Sorry. Go ahead.
No, I'm just recalling this stream where like uh a different
Dan
uh was on like some some podcast with a bunch of like the streamers
and literally just had them sit there and listen to him yap about
Dan Clansancy in Twitch and the anti-semitism. Yeah.
As much as they want because that's the only way to funny. Yeah,
cuz now look at this guy and his chat is like all of a sudden
I know where chat's calling him goon Clancy.
These people are actually like two brain cells programmed. Yeah.
Yep. So I set up a little trap. I did. In case you guys are wondering,
last time I got banned, I made sure to inform you guys that I
sent them a folder. And I made and I want to let you guys know
that folder was seen. I wanted to let you guys know that something
big. Bro, he's so pressed that Hassan called his dad a He is
so pressed that Hassan like broke this to the world and he cried
about it. He He actually cried to Twitch, too. He didn't just
cry on stream. He literally took those tears, put them in a little
nice little neat folder for himself and sent them on to Twitch.
Godamn
was going to happen. giving them incredibly good faith. And I
want to let you know
nothing happened. Wait, hold on. Cuz we are remembering what
his dad did. And we remember he is uh a victim of rap himself.
But like there's a third thing where he tells everybody that
his dad put like a gun to his head and told him, "Give me a reason
not to kill you." Yep. Do you remember that story? I can't forget
that story. That's burned into my head more vividly than it's
apparently burned into techones because he decided to reconnect
with his dad after that. Yeah. No, I remember. Wait, what what
is your point? That his dad's a piece of Yeah. Obviously.
Yes. And that he has probably like a lot of uh trauma from his
childhood from his dad doing that. Yeah. Uh and so his hatred
for like all these other people who are pointing out that your
dad's kind of a piece of they're all probably right. Um they
are all right. Yes. And I don't I don't understand where the
impetus comes to defend his dad over this, but it's interesting.
I can say that
nothing. Zero things happened. Now, why do you think that's a
really big issue? Well, let me tell you why that is. Inside of
this folder that I made with the help of my mods, I had a plethora
of videos and screenshots that went on for quite a bit, ranging
from everybody from Mike now. There's no way. His get the [__]
out of here. His argument his argument for this is Mike from
PA called for Destiny to get shot. It's or sorry, maybe to hit
him. It's on site. Listen, you should ban this guy. I know I
called Denim's a but if you considered that Mike from PA did
this guys come off idiot. He actually did something to get banned
and he's like there her community spam reported me trying to
get me banned but here's a folder of that I tried to get them
banned on. Uh here's my backlog that other people gave me clips
of so I can be a gay op and get these people banned. That's insane.
You know what somebody should do? Somebody should get the clips
of every time Techone took his dad around female streamers that
he either lived with or was rooming and boarding. I think Techone
really put Emir at risk of at least seven times. He put Cuckoo
at risk of like four times. Okay. I think he should get at least
a weekl long ban for each of the times he he exposed any OTK
adjacent female streamer to from his father. Okay. Without informing
them of the dangers. That's just that's obvious. Okay, can we
get a clip compilation going, guys? Like someone in chat said
uh Hassan saved Tee like by saying that so Tech should thank
him like no no if anything Hassan helped save all the other people
that Teone was like normal normalizing his creepy dad too. Thank
god Hassan saved Emiru guys that's if you ever needed a reason
to be a Hassan fan just know that Hassan saved Emir, okay? From
the most disgusting of fates. That went on for quite a bit. She
was the one that Techone said his dad had a big crush on, right,
while he was like living with her. Yes. Well, not living with
her. Um, they lived he lived a couple houses down, right? Well,
they did the podcast. Yeah, cuz am live with Miskf. Yeah. So,
it' be two houses down. Wait, but I hate too.
Uh, well, then you might hate Hassan. Ranging from everybody
from If you're if you're willing to say that you hate Hassan
because he stopped Emir from getting that is that is on you.
Okay. I don't put that juju anywhere else in the universe. That's
some weird to say. From PA, Hassan, Denims, Froggen, uh Casey
Trron makes just to name a few with wonderful little clips like
this. The reason Techone can't sue me is because he did that
[__] Clips where Denims is saying that I'm a and
I can't sue her uh because well, she believes that I did it.
You didn't include the part where she called you over and I'm
pretty sure the chat that she pulled up and she responded to
also didn't call him over. He's just inserting the thing that
would be offensive and make this egregious and it it just isn't
there. Yeah. What is she She's just saying I believe the allegations
against him, right? He did that. Yeah. Somebody was um just complaining
about her uh believing the the stuff in the in those allegations
from Freeman Pink. Yeah. Yeah.
Assan is calling Asold a
clips where Denims is calling me a
abuser. Going in on Naku going in. Wait, did Denim's call a too?
Denims is more informed than I would have expected. Damn on Mudahar.
Going in on all these streamers. All of these streamers going
in on all
of these uh you know content creators with complete blasphemous
language. I think this is base. I think you should defend mid
Harourmore. I call these people fat. I call a girl with an only
fans and I get banned now for a total of a month.
None of them have been banned. So maybe they didn't see my message
and maybe they didn't do anything with I think if Tech isn't
a he would post his whole folder, right? Can we get the Can we
get the folder? I need the folder. So here's messages with official
Twitch staff.
Uh obviously I've blurred them out. These are messages with official
Twitch staff. This is them. I gave you a nice little title here.
I completely get it. Trust me, you should report her and send
me whatever clips. And by the way, this is me working with the
one good mod uh that Twitch actually has or send me whatever
clips or tweets you feel are violative and I can report them
myself and bring them up to the powers that be. It's the same
situation as the Frogen thing and you know it is. You know how
many people were talking about Mink 72 hours ago. The mod that
he says knows what he's doing. the mod that he says cares and
it's like actually good mod is like bro it's the same as the
frog situation you know you can't just be calling these women
like the mod is literally like dude just stop actually like losing
your mind and calling these women and you'll be like fine just
control yourself a little bit have like the smallest modum of
self-control and you're fine zero yes 100% but bro her tweet
had a million views out of nowhere and told me to ignore something
that big after she went after me and my family same thing with
denims and you've reported them both on Twitch with the links
and enough because it is according to our guidelines that we
will perform action on or a offplatform behavior which means
Twitch would I am sorry but he went after his dad more than anyone
else. The story of his dad putting a gun to his head is like
the worst thing that I've heard. Oh, you think you think that's
like worse than
Yeah. The the harassment and like no offense to the women in
the military. Um, it's not that their things are like light or
nothing to me, but the idea that your kid you would put a gun
to their head and make it so that they have to justify why they
should stay stay alive or you're going to take their life. I
am sorry. That is that is evil. Wait, do you remember why Mike
did it? Why Tech's dad did it? Do you remember? I don't remember
why. That makes it so much better. Uh, he left a an empty soda
can on top of the trash can. You'd think and realistically took
out his own family. Get the out of here. And realistically, all
I'm gonna say is realistically that clearly had no effect on
him. He is some kind of like psychopath because how the is he
still a grown he's a grown adult now and he still doesn't know
how to clean the up. So much so that his girlfriend has to go
and talk about how disgusting their house is and he has to talk
about how disgusting their house is. Okay. If somebody if my
one of my parents held a gun to my head because I wasn't cleaning
up and told me to justify why they shouldn't kill me. me. You
know, I'd probably be a little bit more tidy in my old age. All
right. Do you think it might be to believe he's not just totally
lying because he lied about like the whole, you know, staying
a separate That seems like the most likely scenario to me, but
yeah. Yep. He probably just totally smeared his dad with a complete
story about having Kung Halter's dad just to Yeah. make himself
a victim. He's always He's willing to say anything to make himself
the biggest victim in any scenario. Oh my god. If he is lying,
can he get his dad to just go on stream and own up to it? Like,
dad, dad, play into this. play is a big epic online meme. Tell
them you put a gun to my head as a kid. That has to be a line
that people draw, right? Oh, wait.
Uh, it could be. Sorry. So, he's reliving trauma every time he
clean. Yeah, I was thinking that. Evil Morty. Every time he picks
up a can, he has to put it back down cuz he just thinks about
when the gun was at his head. Listen, I can't eat your or you
because I was raped as a kid. I can't clean because my dad tried
to kill me. I can't do anything. Listen, it's trauma. It's childhood
trauma. Stop asking me to be anything close to a man. Stop.
In fact, if they thought it was bad, whether the action was committed,
then is adding Shawn to Black to the
Okay. All right. Um, that's one way that you can beat the misogyny
charges, add racist to it. I'm I'm just kidding. That doesn't
automatically make you racist. M off the platform or on the platform,
you would get banned if Twitch thought it was bad. Actually,
if it violated their terms of service, right? I think like misogyny
is a I don't think is like a what do you call it? Um
yeah, class like a protected class. Gender is a protected class
and well hold on. But would like a gendered insult. So I can
see them they they have a chance at that one. Yeah, they have
been sent tweets. They have been sent clips. They have been sent
videos. They have been sent screenshots.
Everything has been sent and received via offscreen violation
or on platform. Oh yeah. Horus harassment. Oh yeah. Violations
and on platform violations. They have all received them based
on their own words. according to our guidelines. We will action
on or off platform behavior if it's egregious
labeling people saying they believe the allegations against you
not against the
Um the thing maybe that could be against to but I don't know
for te unfortunately there's another basis there to call him.
Do I believe he's he likes watching little boys get in terms
of like drawn cartoon images? No, I don't I'm not going to call
them. I don't know. But I do think might be might be weird for
Twitch to ban that and be protective of people getting qualify
like gone through the ringer for some weird activity that's gone
on their platform. Do you remember that? Yeah, they might be
gunshy. I think BX I think BX Bullet was part of like exposing
some Well, she also reported Max. So, what does that have to
do with what I'm talking about? She reported Max for interviewing
a bandom. She was the one who did that. I believe she was the
one who did that. No, I was referring to the the ring or whatever
that she was saying was happening on Twitch and I think ABBA
and pulled up her report and read it. Yeah. So, I think like
I think things already exist. It's probably really weird for
you as Twitch to become uh protective over people being outed
as possibly being uh like weird social degenerates in like an
illegal way. Yeah. I they Yeah, they could just be gunshy protecting
people over that, but it would be I think like I'm trying to
think of why they I don't know what there would be there that
um like I don't know what guideline that interferes with. Again,
it's like based on their guidelines. We'd have to see what their
guidelines are. abusers
going after Asmin Gold's dead
mother. He's just screaming about people being mean instead of
citing the rules that they're violating.
Probably if you just want to go tie each of those like uh obviously
I'm guessing the physical violence ones, any threats of physical
violence would probably be the easiest ones to get people reported
for. Unfortunately, again, just being like Asmin Gold probably
killed his mom because he he uh let her keep smoking or some
[__] which is an insane disgusting thing to say in
my opinion. Um,
I don't think being mean like that is actually against the rules.
I compiled a folder. I submitted an appeal. I made all of this.
Appeal sent. Here's the info on Hassan and friends. Or should
I send it elsewhere? This is great. I can try to pass the powers
at me. Uh, can we just copy that URL? Let me go find an OCR thing
really quickly. Said it elsewhere. This is great. I can try to
pass the powers at me. And he did. an official Twitch staff member
took this folder. This was also reported them by 40, 50 members
on Twitch, probably from my chat because obviously when my chat
sees someone breaking the toos, they're going to report them.
They've been reported by my chat. They've been reported by their
own mods, sent and received with confirmation that it was sent
to official Twitch moderators and staff. Nothing was done with
this. We have 100%
assurance.
Uh oh.
Can anyone imagine if someone just got on stream and started
admitting to like wanting to get people banned? Like deliberately
trying to get people banned for saying bad things about him.
The tech is just here saying, "Yeah, they they call me a I'm
trying to get him banned. Chat's reporting. Nothing's happening."
For saying that he's a terrorist. Like literally saying bad things
about me. Yep. Like Dan Clancy at acts a video of him and staff
singing happy birthday to Hassan and people are like see he's
loved so he like uses his
uh relationship with these people to get us banned and it's all
just um favoritism blah blah blah blah but yeah if he ever did
even like an ounce of what Tactone is doing here it would just
like solidify everything that they already believe with like
not even half of this. The weird thing is is like it would be
oh
some people have been like uh what have they been doing the the
whole like brothel thing. People amplify that all the time. Should
that be like a ban automatically for anybody because they're
like lying about Hassan. Anybody who says the brothel thing should
just be banned from Twitch. I guess like it's just such a weird
line that like again these people talking and then they want
to report it to the authorities. Hey, Tech's been talking. He
doesn't like that he's facing some consequences and the other
people are within the guidelines. So now he's like trying to
actually report them to the authorities. I wonder if we've seen
this pattern before. My talk, my bullying isn't working. Okay,
that Twitch is okay. Now I'm calling the police with terrorist
sympathizers. They are okay with people breaking the law. They
are okay with people labeling people as criminals, attempting
to defame them, harass them, ruin their life with false allegations,
as well as go after people's dead parents. and they are okay
with all of it as long as you are pushing a leftist extremist
agenda. You know, starting to think some of those supremacist
people just have a point. Okay, if you can just go up to like
a random [__] like this and tell him actually you
should just lie about Hassan cuz uh progressives don't have any
consequences anywhere on the internet. You can just say that
and he just like like the golem that he is just starts repeating
those talking points with zero critical thought. Maybe those
supremacist people actually have a point. Okay, maybe they do.
This is embarrassing.
This is embarrassing on so many levels.
Why Why can't this guy just have a critical thought for himself?
I have once again been banned. And by the way, guys, I've shown
you proof of everything. And maybe I'll do that one more time
right now. Oh, that would be cool. Uh, I do believe, by the way,
yes, the the them not like banning people, them not doing anything
over the threats, that was stupid, right? I understand those
threats were against Destiny, but not banning not banning those
people for those threats was stupid on Twitch's part. Um, and
obviously against their toos. Can we also bring up how he did
he just get banned today? That's what happened. Yep.
Or something that he said in a stream like 3 days ago on the
20. He said 23rd.
22nd or 23rd. Yeah. Yeah, I think so. Yep. So why the time stamp
in the VOD it start if you want to just see the screen capture
of it in 4116.
Why are all of these links for this recovery library? Why are
all these links from 20 days ago? Oh, sorry. This No, no, no.
It was in response. It is in response to like his first ban for
calling denims over I think. Not in response to this ban. He's
saying nothing was done because if you go back to like the discussion
with the mod, it's like back a little further and it's uh that's
not it. Where's the Discord chat with the mod? Right here. Oh
yeah, the Discord chat would be for what happened what happened
this time. You would imagine that those links that he grabbed
or whatever, wouldn't that be in response to how she banned him
the last time? I think this is in response to the ban from last
time. So it's like I think this is the this is possibly the Minkx
and Denim's comment yesterday. 9. Oh, the 6th. June 6th. Um,
not June. Um, June 5th. June 5th. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And
then he sends it the next day. June 6th. So, the links would
be from Yeah. 20 days ago is uh Nandra just told me, did you
see Shamu's update on Techone? Nope. I didn't see it yet. Okay.
I was confused. I thought he was making this library to send
to them after this one, but he's already sent in sent this to
them previously and he's just upset that even after he sent all
of this information about them, he's the one who gets banned
again. Yeah. Yeah. That's what he's about that he's the one who
gets banned. Even though he showed them proof that these people
have been talking [__] off platform too that that
Twitch decided it wasn't that big a deal when they did it. But
he only one clip. He's only showed Wait, he's only showed one
clip so far. I think he said he might be about to go through
this proof or something.
Oh, right. Right. I I think I typed I typed out the link and
give it to you. You can open it. Oh, wait. Can you You can open
it. Yeah. I just I typed it to you. Sick. Show you the screenshot.
Awesome. Recovery library. Sorry. I went and I put it into like
an online thing and I didn't I didn't type it. I knew that you'd
have to do that. I I just screenshotted and typed it. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, we could go through all of these
and see which ones like actually violate. Also, if you're ever
going to do this, if you're going to send Twitch proof, why would
you not basically send them like a text document that has links
and says like here's the here's what this is violating. Here's
what this is violating. Why name it recovery library? I don't
know. He's a loser. So, June 5th, this is in response to his
June 5th ban. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Screenshots.
These have to be toos, right? I would imagine they have to be
toss. Oh no. What will anyone do if this bald if the bald pervert
leaves the Twitch platform for good? He's he key searched.
He key searched bald. Bald. He key searched bald. He did key
search bald. He's like, "No, no, no. I am bald, but these people,
they call me bald." Why? Why? Oh, maybe it's the fat thing. Like,
oh, if I can get banned for calling Frogan fat, I guess, right?
If you're going to insult my appearance and I insult Frogan,
maybe that's where he's coming from. Okay. He doesn't like it.
He doesn't like it that he gets called bald. Don't make my me
call my dad. Male humor be like, uh, that is a funny response
and that is an accurate response. Yeah, I I'm sorry you're Why
would he include a denim's W as well? Cuz like honestly, if this
Yara VT person is on Twitch, Teone should have been banned for
this. He's literally implying he's going to call his dad to assault
them. Like that is that is the actual implication. So you can
say it's a joke. It is kind of a joke, but you can't be mad.
If we're going to take it literally,
you got to take it literally on both sides.
How much of that 400k that he made is like from denims? Cuz I
feel like he's just making her look so good like over and over
and over again. Keeps paying them off. Judge me by my enemies.
Yes, I got What? Why is this included? Why is this included?
Look, Twitch, she she quote tweeted me. That's harassment.
Maybe maybe this does go with like a document or something. Maybe
I'm just missing a document here cuz like this makes no sense
to be included. Do Oh, this is included. Do nothing win. Oh,
Denims is hitting us with a classic again. She I didn't know
Denims was following up on a old tweet. Okay, it's the same one.
Do nothing win. Do nothing win. I sent them a scattered folder
of images and videos with no context and they banned nobody.
There's no way that's what really happened, right? He also cried
on stream that he was uh a victim and had a gun pulling to his
head. So
he did do this kick. Recruiting a fest during pride month is
so brave. Fest is just accurate. This is literally after you
talked about jerking off to her on stream. Why is she attacking
the gays? Twins is so crazy. I I think it's hilarious for her
to be like a leftist progressive and make that joke. Honestly,
it's just funny to eat rapist. Okay,
dude. This is What is this included for? Parading your dad around
like he's an honorable man, but when he's exposed his te responds
by saying he has cancer irrelevant to being was only 17 years
ago when he was a young man 50 plus years old. It's all alleged.
Serve prison time. I again do not understand. This was his trap
guys. This is this is his meticulously crafted trap to show that
Twitch is broken. Okay, their system is broken. I sent them all
of these tweets of Denim's owning me and they didn't even ban
her. What the [__] What the What the [__]
I will also point out that I do not believe Teone was banned
for calling Frogan fat the first time or the third time or the
fourth time. Okay. I believe it was like after a week or two
weeks of just calling her fat every day. Yeah. Then they're like,
"Hey, you got to stop." PTSD comment. Hold on. Let's uh I'll
zoom through these.
I don't even know. This is just a random chat log. They k They
cack L at him. That's harassment. I don't even
Oh, hold on. Yeah. current path recovery library. Is this it?
There's no like we go back to there's no thing before this. I
There must be a document explaining that we don't have cuz if
there isn't that none of this makes any sense. This is a Jake
Chinatown thing. The logs of a screenshot showing Hassan showing
the Jake Chinatown tweet about techone crime. He just said he
sent a folder, right? Uh I guess he cut your dad on crimes in
the congressional record. Man, why are you still chirping? I
that's [__] up. He didn't know that his dad was convicted.
He just found out. Ignore
Ignore the fact that his ex-girlfriend
uh said that his dad said that those women were lying to her.
He just found out. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. The ex-girlfriend did point
out that he had brought it up or it was some topic of conversation
from before. I like this one where it's like trying to basically
say it's trying to say like look, she says this is bad, but also
look over here. So Denims talks about you, dude. I only watch
Denim's clips offline with my pants off. I can't watch those
on stream. Amidst abuse allegations, Techto harasses another
streamer. And she quote tweets that and says, "Interesting move
to harass a streamer after trying to disprove your sexual abuse
allegations, but we can see what at Twitch at Twitch support
think." And then the response to this is she has an only fans
in a fans list. This is like a This is like This is comically
bad. This is like um oh, I can't even I can't think of a good
comparison to this. This is like embarrassing that he was bragging
about how he caught Twitch. He got them guys. They fell for his
trap card. Makes me think he needs a caretaker. I Dude. Uh-oh.
This might be not a good one. Asmin Gold is crying about Assan
again. Son is retweeting people calling me a mom murdering. He's
calling Teone a generational familial obligation to Where's the
lie though? Said Palestinians are an inferior culture that deserves
genocide. Promotes the AFD.
Wanted to dress up like Ash Ketchum and stream a deportation
ride along with ICE. demands I get banned. Defends Techone, but
I'm the villain because I retweet someone who was mean to him
on a separate tweet. I'm sorry, but didn't Asmin Gold already
lose to Hassan? Asmin Gold literally stopped streaming and cleaned
his house. He lost, right? Yeah. Yeah. Basically, yeah. Like
he self flagagillated right there. He did. He's like, "All right,
guys. I'm I'm going to clean my house. I never do this. I'm going
to clean and I'll give you guys photos." Yep. Yeah. But Asmin
Gold was bent. Yeah. Hassan got preferential treatment. Absolutely.
Hassan got preferential treatment. I hope that's over now. But
he did get preferential treatment before. Why did you assume
this was about you, buddy? Oh, hold on. Hold on. So, I'm genuinely
considering full swapping to YouTube if this terrorist propaganda
isn't punished harshly and immediately on Twitch. My father,
my brothers, and our soldiers did not bleed.
There's uh his father's a shield, by the way. My father, my brothers,
and our soldiers did not bleed. Sacrifice and died for this to
be allowed and promoted on Twitch. This needs to be changed immediately.
Why did Oh, sorry. Oh, no. What will anyone do if the bald pervert
leaves the Twitch platform for good? He responds, "Why did you
assume this was about you, buddy? Is this because you're, you
know, you're pushing terrorist propaganda, which is directly
against to kind of weird, big guy." Uh, no. You You like hang
out with people who rail on him for the same thing. No, he it's,
I mean, it obviously most likely is about him, but Hassan's literally
just like laughing at somebody, threatening to leave. It's like,
"Hey, your presence is like hardly wanted." like, "Oh no, what
will another terrorist propaganda thing?" He's just like, "Tech
sucks. Who care if he who cares if he leaves?" That's a good
point. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Wow. It's like when um it's like when
the the hot tub streamers complained, "Oh my god, they banned
me. All I did was wear a thong." Like, okay. Oh, how how terrible.
Oh no. What are you going to stop streaming on Twitch and only
stay live on your Only Fans? Oh no, Twitch is really losing out.
Oh no.
Tech literally had a video he made about Hassan under that tweet.
I Okay. Oh, so basically under this tweet it was a video about
Hassan.
That was directly about him and then he's like, "You think this
is about you?
God, this guy is a this uh this guy is special needs." And honestly,
there's a decent chance if you saw these two walk past you in
the in the mall, you might think this is like her brother, right?
That she's taking care of, like her actual caretaker. Oh my god,
he put the beanie over the glasses like that. Yet another Oh,
whoops. We are not on good terms. Free opens up about her ex-husband,
Tee says, "Some things shouldn't be used for content." Yet another
male victim of divorce court. Send your thoughts and prayers,
everyone, so that he may recover one day. This is not against
any toos.
Why is this included in anything?
What is happening? That this would be This is his, by the way,
this again to remind you guys, this is his folder of like shot
evidence that Twitch is super biased in not banning these people
for off-platform behavior, right? He's shown them the evidence,
all the evidence they need to ban all these streamers for off-platform
behavior. He has not proven out his case once, except maybe with
somebody who called him bald. But realistically, again, it was
a repeated thing with Froggen, the fat thing. So, I don't know.
Sorry. Why is he crying? Knew about his dad essay saying women
followed in his footsteps and is trying to blame it on Hassan
Lau. Okay, this is Minkx saying she believes I guess the allegations
because Jaki is so he thinks he's being banned for being mean
not for to
Yeah, I don't I don't Okay, we're almost through the screenshots.
We're almost through it. He's not He literally said his viewers
don't care about this. His viewers will never stop supporting
him. He could do whatever. They don't care. They're there for
the video games. They kind of are. He knows he's those games.
Uh, this one. I remember this one. This one kind of was gross
to me that Casey Tro was talking about her his like dead mom
to try to go after him. That was so stupid. But this is really
November 2024. Jesus, how was that so long ago? Cry at Asminold.
As your type always says, facts don't care about your feelings.
Also, how's your other allegedly buddy techone? Oh, she added
the allegedly. So, he's totally good here. Yeah. No violations
possible. Cool.
Smart. Smart.
Okay. This is a one minute clip. I need to go get a drink really
quickly. I'm going to play this clip. I'm listening. Okay. I'll
be right back. Okay. Clip. If there is no crime, you cannot go
after someone for simply speech that you don't like. That statement
inherently is contradictory. You can't just be like, "Well, I've
decided you can deport people uh who are legal permanent residents
because I don't like their speech." Okay, then you're not for
free speech. Then you're not you don't like the current existing
American free speech protections. You don't want non-citizens
to have free speech protections. Maybe that's what you're trying
to say. Okay, I guess that's what the the statement is here,
which is still ridiculous
because the standard of free speech isn't just like what you've
chosen that you don't like. It's across the board, at least in
America. There are some exceptions to it, but it's like Mahmud
Khalil did not violate any of those standards. Okay, I what is
happening? That's like that's that's
how Tech is taking one of the few cases where Hassan's making
a political point that is correct and valid and he's putting
it in this thing that's proving that people should be getting
banned. I don't understand.
This is like how did you find the one time Hassan was correct
and valid in a political opinion and put this in your complaint
folder?
Couldn't you found any of the trillion times he's been a complete
not? Are we sure this is Tech's folder? Yes, it's literally called
Recovery Library. It's all about Teone. This point is actually
good. They found a point Hassan was making that isn't okay. Oh,
maybe that is the point. Don't ban me because Hassan would disagree
with it. To the nail, but it's it's gross as Okay, that wasn't
the part I was talking about, bro. Keep watching until you bring
up the content nuke to see his reaction. I don't care about Ethan's
reaction. I don't even want to see it anymore. I'm so off. What
are we doing? What the are we doing? How How are we so goddamn
cruel? You know what I mean? How How is that allowed? How do
other people in the community don't check these people? You know
what I mean? Why is that Why is that appropriate? Why is that
in any way, shape, or form appropriate? Like, that's a peer.
Okay. Yeah. I'm sorry. She doesn't have [__] 30
live concurrent viewers. Nope. I don't have any right access
to this folder. Then you would suck up to her and respect her.
Gross. Gross. Dude, I I I actually have no idea. I I kind of
want to go back to his video cuz I hope he's going to take that
folder that he said he was going to look at and look at the folder.
Now, now I'm going to feel bad if he has a document he's going
to pull up. Uh I see his kick dashboard. I don't see him pull
a folder up. Yeah, I don't think he pulls We'll just watch for
a second. We'll see what he says. I I'm going to ask you guys
to take my word for it because I have honored myself.
Oh, take his word for it. It was nice of him to show the folder
on screen of the things he's complaining about. Guys, I'm just
gonna ask you to take my word for it, okay? They really did up.
Twitch fell into my trap. They up and you just take my word for
it, okay? They embarrassed themselves massively. And I pride
myself by always telling you guys the absolute truth and providing
you proof with absolutely everything that I possibly can. And
if it's requested enough, I suppose I can show you more DMs.
However, I'm very angry and I don't feel like censoring these
things out again because my brain hurts and I'm doing this live
and I just got another DM right before I made this video that
I didn't edit. They sent me a DM on how to deal with this and
they told me to just ignore them. That's their solution. They
want me to just guys which
you telling me to just ignore them is you telling me to have
people send me careerending false allegations going after my
friends going after my friends dead parents and just ignore it.
What type of disgusting
monsters do you have to be to expect me to be able to be defamed,
slandered, have my livelihood ripped away from me?
Defamation, error, or slander. You can sue. You should sue. Why
don't we sue? Can we sue? Can we just sue? Have them go after
people who I care about so much, more than I care about my self,
including their dead parents, and say, "Well, oh, he definitely
cares about Asgold's dead mom. He's not pulling something up
from 2024 to try to make a point at all. He definitely cares
way more about Asmin Gold's dead mom than himself. Actually,
now that I think about it, he totally talked about his like multiple
as a kid when Asmin Gold's dead mom. When Casey Trump made fun
of Asmin Gold's dead mom, right? It definitely wasn't when Hassan
just made a point to like dunk on him and then he trauma dumped
every single bad thing that happened in his childhood. I just
ignore them. That's not how this works. I would be able to ignore
them if you did anything. I gave you three weeks
with a compiled, easy to read folder,
dude.
Uh, a compiled, easyto read folder, guys. We've been I've been
waiting for weeks that this is the folder, by the way. We've
been looking at the folder.
This folder is embarrassing. None of these people ever talk uh
have none of these people never had anyone talk [__]
about them in their lives. I They have. They they like deal with
it once you get to a certain size. I don't know. You just stop
like actually engaging with reality. Like this guy's a big streamer
now. So he's like, "Oh, this is defamation." Because they talk
yet I get banned in less than 24 hours after my quote unquote
infraction. You're going to have to keep banning me over and
over and over and over again. Because if these people are coming
at me, coming at my friends, coming at their relatives, coming
at my relatives, coming at their
Wait, did he just say coming in my relatives? Ah, why? You're
going to have to keep banning me over and over and over and over
again because if these people are coming at me, coming at my
friends, coming at their relatives, coming at my relatives, coming
after their deceased relatives, I'm going to have to say something.
What the [__] is wrong with them? Uhhuh.
Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
He said, "Coming in my relatives." That is what he said. Yes.
Um,
does he have more than just a dad? No. I think his mom was culpable
in some of the bad stuff that happened to him. So, I don't know if
he talks to his mom at all. When they're blasting this out to
millions of people every day, and yes, Twitch, it bothers me
if they're promoting terrorist propaganda.
What I take pride in living in the United States of America where
many of my friends and relatives were soldiers who I care about
very much they were united in
ah god despite everything I don't care despite everything I don't
care by the way if you don't know that is his original dad tweet
right my family my dad my brothers my family bled for this country
I won't allow terrorist propaganda and at Twitch. That's just
his tweet rewarded. And then because he knows he's been blown
up for bringing up his dad, he actually says after that, I don't
care.
States of America.
What I that flag wasn't there behind him like last week. My friends
and relatives were soldiers who I care about very much despite
everything. I don't care. Yep. I respect our soldiers. I love
our troops. And I don't
Wait, can you catch me up? I got lost. What does he care about
and what does he not care about? He cares about his family members
who are soldiers like his dad. Despite everything, I don't care.
So he's like, I don't care about other people getting mad about
my dad. I still care about him cuz he was a soldier. Um,
US Army because he was a soldier. Cuz he was his dad. Because
he was a soldier and a family member. But he's trying to say
because he's a soldier, he hates terrorist propaganda. That's
why he hates Assan. Maybe he has like a fetish for soldiers as
like his thing.
Maybe maybe that's why he plays all of these uh like Japanese
games where you can have the little girls be soldiers. Little
girls and little boys. Yeah. Take their sacrifices for granted.
You all know this is happening. This is undeniable proof. You
know this is happening. And yet you still do nothing. It's pathetic.
Undeniable proof this is happening. Wait. Undeniable proof. Wait.
What? Wait. I respect our soldiers.
Respect them. I love our troops and I don't take their sacrifices
for granted. You all know this is happening. This is undeniable
proof. You You all know this is happening, brother. Your thread
has like your This This folder has no like discernable thread
other than these people don't like you. It's like here's here's
like me getting owned multiple times. Here's me getting owned
dozens of times. Twitch, do something. Twitch, stop them. Twitch,
you got to stop them. Please
stop them. Stop them. This folder really is a Denim's highlight
reel. I didn't know that she could make like the the gay pride
jokes that just um that actually humanizes her even more. Uh
I it's about to become a Hassan highlight really. I think the
next couple clips are all Hassan. Can you link the URL in chat?
I'm too lazy to type it. Uh, hold on. Let me um
let me go to the top level and download. Unable to download too
size is too large.
Oh well, somebody should go and download all of this. Hold on.
Can I open this in another thing here? I just don't want to lose
any of this stuff. I don't want to not have it. So, okay. Can
you let me download something else? No, you only let me download
one thing at a time. Just open up all the tabs, right? Well,
you can. Uh, whatever. You can
um there's like a download button that wasn't letting me go through
some of the other ones here. Oh, was just a once you click one
of the download buttons, they go away on all the other ones,
it looks like. Oh, no, they don't. Oh, what the Oh, I think Okay,
I'm clicking through. Give me two seconds to click through all
of these. And I can't believe I'm doing this manually. Really
grinds my gears to do something like this manually, not just
find something to do it automatically. Let's see what Smelly
Jean in chat has to say while you download. Smelly says, "This
stream is just all three of you." Oh, excuse me. Um, acting like
kids in a circle
competing
who can spit up in the sky the further. What game is that? And
then got the audacity
to look at your parents and tell them we were just changing the
word. Lowkey hoping Ethan win. What the does this have to do
with Ethan? and set a president of He's going to set a president
of of what? The United States with this lawsuit. He's going to
set a president. So, you are forced to swim or drown. Just love
to hate watch this community get burned. Um h I'm Those are the
people supporting Ethan and they couldn't be less intimidating.
Oh, this guy posted some other stuff that was funny tonight.
Hold on. Let me let me read this. I saw this get posted and I
I didn't read it because it seemed incomprehensible. But let
me see this guy. He sniped out president.
He did talk the well racism is an old thing. So is okay is I
say it and to call other black person calling a woman a wow.
Get that woman hater out of Twitch. Him and his dad are going
to rap every woman. Good pathetic act, my boy. Uh actually no.
I don't think you could do this on Twitch. I think if I was a
white person I call a black dude on Twitch. I think I would I
think I would get banned. I don't think I could do that actually.
I think that's against to I am his friend and if he ever called
me up, I would kill him. I thought of several ways that I would
do it. Seven to be specific.
This is weird. I don't even know what this guy is saying. This
guy like watches a lot. Trying to see who this is. Jesus. He
said he said not. I'm Dominican like Jerry. No, you're French
Canadian almost certainly. I'm sorry. This is like French Canadian
typing. I'm almost I'm almost positive, bro. Tell me the truth.
Are you French Canadian? Smelly Jean, be real right now. What's
a what? What's a Bapt? Somebody said who wins. Cherry v Bapka.
Uh that is
someone who streams with I think. Yeah, I don't think I've heard
of them. They might be in the Discord here. I'm not totally sure.
Oh, other people want the link. Oh, right. I wanted to download
all the stuff before they accidentally before they actually get
rid of it. There's no way this could actually this dude's chat
so you you could uh do that. I did download Yeah, I downloaded
all of them. Okay, you're done. Okay. Yeah. Yeah, I'm done. All
right. There's no way. What? Uh I don't know. I don't even know
what I was saying. But we're uh we're good. We're good to continue
on with Tech Tone. See what he has to say. Jesus. Proof. You
know this is happening. And yet you I'm like dehydrated for this
stream now. I uh I need more water. You still do not drinking
enough water. You still do
nothing. It's pathetic. You are pathetic. And the only thing
that you're doing is you're going to make me grow and get bigger
and bigger and bigger because I'm not going to let you bully
me. I'm not
um when Twitch doesn't ban When Twitch doesn't ban Denims for
making fun of him. Okay. With no intrinsic traits at all, that
is teto. That is Tecton being bullied by Twitch. Okay. When they
don't protect him from the big mean brown lady just laughing
at him or saying that he's harassing her, that's actually Twitch
bullying him. That's crazy. Going to let This is This is the
power of like self victimization. Okay, this man can turn himself
into a victim in any situation.
It's totally broken. Do you guys remember that we needed like
the nerf on Hassan and his race swaps? how he would switch races
all of the time to whatever he needed to be to be like the victim
in a situation. Teone is like the omni victim. He can make himself
the victim in any situation. And he's white. He's a white male
and he will just be like it'll be like techone. Um it seems like
you lied here and he's like I was twice before I was 15. And
it's like people ask me play America JT Stalk. Yeah. Well, he
probably qualifies as trans if you have a They're trying to make
this guy go in the women's restroom. You realize that that's
what Trump is trying to do right now. And you're all It's probably
more convenient. Sorry. No, they're going to take his testosterone
away. All right. He's already He's already lost the hair. They're
going to make him go bald and then they're going to take the
testosterone away. It's crazy. You silence chat said macro. I'm
sorry. I'm having a really hard time. Uh, okay. Play by play.
I'm not going to let you encourage me to just ignore it and not
talk about it. How about you get your head out of your ass and
you do your jobs? You have a toos. This guy's so brave. Enforce
it. I'm tired of my friends getting harassed
every
day by these disgusting human beings
that call themselves streamers when in reality all they do is
pull up CNN and walk away from their chair. They will be replaced
by AI in the next six months. No, they won't. They are like the
demographic that won't get replaced by AI. People making scripted
videos
um
and trying to give like political commentary in scripted formats
are probably what's going to get replaced. I don't even know.
That's what you'll be able to AI generate with scripts and stuff.
Dams. Denims probably could be replaced by AI. No, denims can't
be replaced by AI. I don't think so. She doesn't really She doesn't
do very much. They like her because it's like it's watching a
VTuber but you know it's real. They like they specifically want
the real aspect of it. You can go watch a fake one. They got
the real misogynist enough. I didn't think Cherry was misogynist
enough to give the right take there. But that is exactly what
I was going to say. How does this guy doubt me? That is what
people I am misogynist enough. I'm racist enough. I'm bigoted.
I'm ableist enough every time. Okay. You Yeah, I shouldn't have
doubted. Yeah, I shouldn't have doubted. Pre-planned code. Pre-planned
code. If there's a terrorist, just make the streamer pog. Great.
I don't know what the you
are doing there back at Twitch, but I suggest you try enforcing
your toos equally. That way, you get some of the credibility
you would had back cuz I assure you, you do not have it now.
And thank you Twitch because I'm sure once this video gets released
and this will be talked about by everybody once again. Thank
you for giving me 1 million subs on YouTube. I'm going to go
get a golden retriever in celebration. Quits. Go yourself. May
God have mercy on your soul. Do your job. Unban me. That's the
video. Like, comment, subscribe. See youall next time. Peace.
Oh, I forgot that he does that. that now he has people who write
his scripts and he just has like scripted segments and he just
does scripted segments the whole time. I forgot that he does
that now. That's always so jarring that he does that like through
stream. It's so effective though. I really need to do better
about this as long as seven days. That's what Papaot would do
or maybe he still does. I watch his streams but um like his live
streams he would be doing takes to cut snip and edit and put
on um Tik Tok. Oh, that's smart. He never he never made his Tik
Toks like off stream or anything. People just be there while
he's like running his takes to do it. Yeah. No, I think that's
smart to be honest. I think it's smart to find a way that's less
Maybe this is smart though. I don't know why you need to do that,
but maybe it feels more authentic. Why you wouldn't just have
like a like a ending real or whatever, but maybe it just feels
more authentic. I'm not totally sure. Uh, what are you going
to name it? Oh, right, right, right. Uh, we don't care anymore.
I'm going to name it Mango. That weird ass guy from C9 made the
name Mango weird, which sucks. All right, let me tell I would
trust my if I had like a sister or something, like a 20-year-old
sister, I would trust my sister with mango way more than techone.
But there's no way that he's complaining. This guy was like creepy
and pushy and now the word mango is weird. Any self-awareness?
No self-awareness. Maybe if maybe if Mango went to rehab. Okay,
I wouldn't want my sister to be with a drunk. That's just that's
but that's more of a drunk thing, not a salt thing. I think she'd
be more likely to be she'd be more likely to run into those problems
with Tecttone. But with Mango, I it's just a drunk in general.
Okay. But he is also the goat. He is also the best Falco of all
time.
So, I mean,
you know, it's just goofy to imply like he's even worried about
how he's going to look. I Yeah, he he has zero thought about
it. It's like over. I I don't He already posted this. I don't
think this guy cares about looking or anything like that. Like,
no. Like, outside of this, I don't think that's like part of
his persona. Oh, no. I'm so worried. I want everybody I want
everybody to think I'm a good guy. Now, I can't be named Mango
cuz that's going to make me look weird cuz the weird stuff that
that guy did. I would never do those weird things. Anyway, now
let's go play this like gotcha game. Okay. They're not
They're not They are Okay, they're not Japanese people. Okay.
Oh, no. Hold on. Japanese people are super but not in the context
of I think it's always if it's No, because what you don't understand
is they are
spirits bodies of
they can't consent. Don't say no they it's only like uh it's
only in terms of the body types. Okay. In terms of the body
spirits but if it is it's always like the magic children that
can consent Jerry. Okay. That's No, thank you. That's basically
that's he gets it. The guy gets it. Go figure. Who would have
thought? You know what? They were trying to find the one area
where I'm not edgy enough and they found it. They actually
in games. It's just like, you know, there's like scantly clad
12-year-olds basically. What can you do? You guys win.
There's no I can't be wrong. Tell that to Denims and Teone. Okay.
Tectone doesn't even Tecton thought he could never be called
a His It doesn't even work if it attempts to enter an or an orifice
that isn't a mouth. Okay. He didn't think he was allowed to be
called a He thought he found the loophole.
Can't even get hard if it's going against a vagina, any vaginal
wall. Okay. He thought he was
He thought he was immune,
but he's not immune. Okay. I'm not I'm not saying this is I don't
know what TechOne did. But do you think there's actually a case
where a guy argues nope I didn't judge. Let me just show you
my cuz he thinks that if it's micro
like there's actually like this like Yeah. This is like this
takes both working together to like actually get something going
here. So there's like no Well, it's also her mouth, right? Like
literally No, you could literally hurt somebody by just slamming
your body into them over and over. You don't have to. Listen,
there's zero trauma to her throat, but her nose has been smashed
into pieces by his fa. Okay, it's up. That's assault. That's
assault. And if you're out, it's assault. You
[__] you. The fact that your go past one inch doesn't
matter. Assault actually makes it worse. Okay. He needs to push
back that like fat around his to get any entry into anything.
So, he's got to force his th force his hips forward hard. Okay.
It makes it worse because people cannot help if they have a micro,
okay? And they need empathy. They do not need the motivation
to believe that they could take their anger out of their birth
defect
out on every other woman in the world. It's just like I'm imagining
like a serial micro
right now. Yeah. Like
I hate this place. That was such a great Ah,
this Listen, I'm just gonna let that settle in on people. Uh,
they get it. The people get it. Okay. I don't even know if Cherry
heard me. I think Cherry heard No, I don't even know what just
said. What was just said? Oh, I said like Cheerios
cereal.
I don't get it. He Cheerios. Oh, thank you. God, I make one funny
joke in like years and Cherry doesn't even hear it. It's so up.
It's [__] up. is not funny. If you pretend. I'm sorry.
The joke's not funny. Now she's laughing saying it's not funny.
Why do you just do I'm laughing. I'm laughing because you I don't
know. I did the thing where I just like pretend I didn't hear
it so we can move on like for you. I'm doing a disconnect. I'm
going to disconnect. Okay. Tapping out. That's it. Not funny.
Not funny to joke like this. Okay. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Are
we going to keep going through some of this? There is like the
pirate software stuff. I don't I don't know if I want to start
it right now. What do we got? We got 5 minutes left on the stream
right now. Uh I think we have more than 5 minutes. I think I
have to be intellectually honest with the stream and say that
we got an hour and 5 minutes cuz uh I believe well I just hit
all of the goals for for financing and that means an 8 hour 15
to 8 hour 30 minute stream and I think we're at 7 hours 30. Yeah,
7 hours 20. We definitely have another hour on the stream that
I just was uh not I I didn't count the time correctly. So, I'm
going to be honest with you guys and say I didn't count the time
correctly, but we did make it to 8 hours on the stream. So, we
do have an hour left. Not sure exactly where I'm going. I We
have the pirate software stuff or we can keep watching the Techone
clips. The Techone clips. I just want to know if there's like
actually going to be a toss violation against Tee in here. Will
we get a single one is the question. A single actual toos violation
against Techone that took place off platform. Techone clips.
Okay. Okay. Hold on. Next. Teone clip. Oh, I had opened it and
we didn't hit play. I am genuinely considering full swabbing
to YouTube that this terrorist propaganda isn't punished harshly.
Wait, did Tech think
Techone unironically think him posting this is not going to be
a call for celebration?
Why? How in the world is Uh-huh. Where where's the toss violation?
Where is what? He's he said this is a folder full of like the
most unforgivable like uh violations of any you know of either
moral violations like with the as gold bomb comment or actual
to violations like terrorist support. What am I supposed to be
watching here that's that's wrong or anything weird? Oh, this
will be th this might be one.
But I got to be honest with my experience in life with people
like Ethan, the only thing that ever knocks them out of their
spiraling is is the rod. It's the Why does he have a react clip
of this stick? I don't know. It's not the carrot. Okay, chief.
Like they feel he feels like he's he's bullying you. He feels
like he's hurting you. He's not going to Oh, I've seen that before.
E-mer like Mewtwo King when they basically uh they accused him
somebody accused him of assault and he was like my don't work
bro you lied you lied I have documented documentary evidence
my ain't even work bro it's it's over for you stop until he's
you know he's bleeding out of the corner of his mouth and I get
it I want to be empathe like I understand the value of empathy
I understand the value of trying to reach out to someone but
somebody like Ethan he needs to get he needs to see some stars
before he's going back down. You know, this is
That whole clip he said, "Okay, chief." Mike should sue him and
say this was not transformative. Also, I'm not a chief, so his
his commentary is inaccurate. I don't know. Jeez.
I
So,
with that one,
I get where that's coming from. Personally, I think that could
possibly be Mike speaking metaphorically. I think you could argue
I might even argue that Twitch should probably play that a little
uh tighter. When it comes to things that could be interpreted
as threats of violence, you probably do have to action as a platform.
I I I think probably Mike's being metaphorical there, like as
in you can't back down from Ethan. He's being a bully. You have
to fight back. You can't just like be a [__] I think
that's probably what's happening. But I think you have to action
on it. And Mike has a history of actually making physical threats.
So it's on site. It's on site. Deserve 911. He was very obviously
saying that someone should hit Ethan.
I I don't think so because he's speaking in metaphors and he's
talking about like seeing stars. I think he is I think he is
not literally saying that personally. But in any case, even if
he's not literally saying that, I think you should still be it
should be actioned on as if you were saying that because it's
difficult to know. It's difficult to know and other people can
use that with plausible deniability to not get banned, right,
dude? People literally got away with saying yourself in a video
game. Let's not act like the most
does not just like slip through. Why does that work? It's so
dumb. People on TikTok get away with saying Listen, I would never
talk about on the other hand though. On the other hand, that's
horrifying. deserve 911. Very strange. Okay, hold on. America
deserve 911. Is this the Osama bin Laden Manifesto? It is the
Osama bin Laden Manifesto with no other citations. How is somebody
reviewing this supposed to know what it is? But it says we disavow
this on the screen. Deserve 9. We all Oh, true. We all disavow
this. We are learning. We all dis We all disavow this. We are
learning. I had heard this. Wait, but but this is literally why
the policy was brought in was this stuff. So he's saying he's
using this to say it's a toss violation. Yeah, they decided it
was a TS toss violation, but that wasn't the change. They weren't
going to retractally. Sure. Well, uh, it was close. We almost
had the first like toos violation here against Teone. No, wait.
Not against Techone. This is just a denim to violation. Still
not against Techone. Okay. She got banned. Wait, she also did
get banned for this. She absolutely got banned for the bin action.
Actioned to violation. That wasn't even a violation at the time.
Awesome stuff. Thank you, Techone. This is against Tech because
his father was in the military.
Exactly. Yeah. His father literally served in the Middle East.
He like got he like lost skin on his legs. No, I think of Vietnam,
right? No, the Middle East.
Like a rock or something. He's not that old. Come on. Come on.
I can't disavow facts, man. I can't disavow reality the same
way America deserved 911. America deserve 911, dude. It I'm saying
it. Leftist pre Hassan also Did Hassan not also get banned for
America deserves 911?
Yeah. And foam at the mouth at the thought of a revolution happening
in America. But as soon as it happens from Stardust video on
Frogan,
this is definitely taken from some This is definitely taken from
like Listen, I don't have Dan Derrangements, but I feel like
this is a Dan video. I'm almost positive. No, but Dan, but you
understand Dan doesn't make his own videos. I don't think there
is a single person who would put that there except for Stardust.
Oh, sure. This one. This one I could see being like mad about.
I don't think you I don't think you banned from Twitch for this.
Wait, what are you talking about? I'm talking about this clip
that's put together, right? We're not No one is stupid enough
to think that Techone went through and got all these clips and
screenshots. Someone compiled this library for him. Dan would
not make this
himself. Dan hires people who will accept slave wage. Stardust
one of the people who has accepted slave wage to do work for
Dan. Wait, isn't
now too? My crazy does it free for Dan. Anyway, what' you say?
Pretty sure Stard does it for free. Stop it. I tried to at least
slave wage is at least better than Dan's definitely said she's
done stuff for free before. 100%. Why would you do stuff for
Dan if he's out here telling people, "Yeah, she works for me
for
um disrespecting the [__] out of complete utter lack
of selfresect. Jerry, have you ever heard this like story about
how
build things out of build like men out of clay to do their bidding
for them? They'll like put together no like a being out of clay.
It's called like a golem and they they like just do work for
them. Jak has explained that somebody looks like a golem. I forget
who. John Fetman also tech. Oh, John. Stardust does it like clay
golem. That's true.
I didn't say that. Golems are like giants though. Stardust is
uh Well, no, she's small. I don't think I've ever told you guys
this, but Stardust is very banned. And she was actually more
helpful than basically anybody else. She like tried to help in
some way. So, I try not to talk too much about Stardust. Okay.
This is the most disgusting thing about you. This person said
something nice to me this one time when I was down and I just
don't want to call I don't want to talk [__] about
stardust
help me. I've never spoken to them again. No. It's like so easy
to be nice to me when I'm a victim. Someone get me the JQing
on main clip. I'll make fun of that all day. Okay. I'm just not
going to make fun of her appearance. Okay. That's where I will
draw the line. Oh yeah. Yeah. I'm not making fun. I've met her
I've met her in person. She's like shorter than me in person.
I wouldn't call her huge or anything. Oh, here's the uh the official
moment. I guarantee you a lot of people will be sewing about
how cool this is. Good evening. I've been thinking deeply about
everything going on, specifically against about the accusation
that I'm a misogynist for suing three women. You're all correct.
It's not being fair. That's why I decided to add Shawn the Black
to the lawsuits for gender equality. Shawn, be sure to thank
all of your Starker friends for their constructive advice. Wow.
Wow. Uh I'm going to double down. I'm going to say this is misogyny
and he is doing what racist people do and deciding that uh never
mind. [__] I actually I might make make this more
racist if I keep keep talking. Why not include Shawn before?
Uh I don't know. It'd be interesting to look at some of Sean's
reactions andor the actual complaint against Shawn. I haven't
even I really have not taken the time to look through the other
complaints either. I have not looked at the Froggen complaint.
I've not looked at the Casey complaint. So, Queen, I'd heard
you'd looked at the Frogan reaction, had you not? And seen that
the Frogan reaction was actually probably more substantive than
they're letting on. Like, while there is a chair component, that
she actually does comment on it a lot of the time. Well, I haven't
looked over the whole video, but my understand was she was doing
like challenges and [__] during it. Wasn't she doing
it's transformative. So, might not be She was doing like some
like event stream. Yeah. She was like doing like bits and games
or whatever the I thought. That's what I answered. I haven't
actually watched the stream, so I I don't I see. Okay. Okay.
I'm going to finish the thought and it's just there are a lot
of black men in Hollywood who have communicated a similar thing
which is the idea that the people who control Hollywood and control
their careers. They take black men, they are racist against black
men and they take black men and they put them in emasculating
situations to degrade them and put them.
That's what you're saying. Shan the black sold is batty. I don't
know what this what the what you're saying after sold like sold
his batty to Dan Clansancy for this reference or I literally
don't know the reference you're doing sold his batty sold his
batty is this is this one of your sayings
I don't know this it is one of his sayings if he has a saying
it's by definition no but seriously seriously if you look it
up it's something about um I think Martin Lawrence was one of
the first people who was like skitso talking about it maybe before
him Martin Lawrence Dave Chappelle I think has talked about it.
Um
like the phenomenon of how many black men have been put in movie
roles where they have to wear dresses
and stuff like that. It's just definitely talked about it. Okay.
The humiliation ritual. Let's go. When had to go show when he
had to go full hog in that modeling, okay, and then wear the
dress, wear that weird like lingerie thing. Seo had to go through
the humiliation ritual. He didn't even get anything out of it.
He's not even a model anymore. So for that entire list, the fact
that Ethan just wants to do something to make it seem like he's
not a misogynist, right? I'm not just picking easy targets. I'm
not just picking people that I devalue based on like any characteristics.
Um the fact that like the next thing that next person he picks
is a black man instead of anything else or anyone else. Uh just
very interesting.
Yeah, Cat Williams also also likes somebody who has brought it
up. I wonder if I should watch that club uh that Club Shay Shay
interview with Cat Williams. I wonder if that'd be a good one
to watch. I know it's like the big ask you to party and you just
got to tell him no. You just got to tell him no. It's fire is
really good. Yeah, maybe. Maybe that that might be something
we do. We'll see. We'll see. Hold on. Uh from Stardust video
on Frogan. We'll keep watching. See what else
in this clip is wrong. Uh Hezbollah is a is a paramilitary organization
that is also a
part of the Lebanese parliament. Do we like them or no? I think
as a resistance group, they're pretty successful against Israel.
Um Oh. But everybody hates them. Like everybody in the region,
a lot of people don't like them. Like I like what you like. I
don't have an issue with them, let's just say. But they are a
terrorist organization. Like they're designated they're they
are designated by the American state as a terrorist organization.
do not like them. Then there they are a terrorist a what I I
could defend that statement now. She's kind of poorly. I'm sorry.
No, Hassan is so base for that. Here is this brain deadad uh
clout driven that I'm friends with because I'll be friends with
retards cuz like Hassan's not ableist. He'll be friends with
idiots. Here's this or black people. Go ahead. Stop it. Here's
this. I'm saying stuff. He has no idea what I'm saying. He's
like, "Well, I like it cuz you do." I'm I'm gonna elaborate further
and show him how he's an idiot. Yeah, they're a terrorist. They're
labeled a terrorist organization.
Like I'm sorry, but that you're just like real for that. Trying
to teach him about critical thinking. Okay, don't just agree
with what I say. They are a terrorist organization. You shouldn't
just agree with me. God, what a kind and and like considerate
mentor Hassan is. He just he had to he had to just nudge him
like don't just listen to me. Wow. I didn't think about that,
Cherry. That is really I you know I newound respect for Hassan.
Let's go. Uh, was this just on orbiters? It probably was. Yeah,
it definitely was. This is We just watched this clip. Uh, Mike
from PA deserve 911. I can't Yeah, that's the one. Okay, hold
on. More clips. More clips. Watch that clip. Oh, it's a Destiny
clip for some reason. A 17-year-old whose family was murdered
in front of her and she was kidnapped for 50 days and continually
while being in captivity. Nothing to say. You're not going to
acknowledge what just happened? I will acknowledge what just
happened. This woman who you claimed was continually in captivity
did not claim to have been.
Hold on. This is uh this is very small. We need bigger. They
suffered at least one person with me said they suffered physical
abuse.
Half of them. In that interview, she said that at least half
the hostages she spoke to said they were assaulted. At no point
did she claim that anything had happened to her. And to my knowledge
so far, no hostages have given firsthand accounts of being sexually
assaulted in captivity. Mida, I remember thinking, I mean, now
is the moment something what you thought about is going to happen.
And then I remember I turned around. He was standing with his
gun and the gun was pointed out at me and he was huffing and
breathing heavily and he had a face like a monster, like a beast,
like this.
So I stood up and held a blanket, a small blanket to cover myself.
And he came towards me and just pointed the gun really hard at
my forehead, screaming at me, take it off, take it off, and punching
me until I could not hold the the the
towel anymore. And he started touching me and I resisted.
And then he dragged me to the bedroom. And then he he forced
me to commit this act on him. No hostages have given firsthand
accounts of being assaulted in captivity. Okay. How can this
be in the same video? It's almost like she didn't watch it at
all. Okay. Well, wow. H I mean that looks bad. I'm literally
not laughing. The only I don't I don't I don't know if this is
true. My only thing would be is that 100% a hostage testimony
or is that or is that the woman who was born October 7th? I'm
not sure. Say that again.
Was were there any first hands from October 7th? Because it could
be that she's making the hostage that like she wasn't she wasn't
held hostage and this wasn't happen this didn't happen in captivity
that it happened in captivity
like Yeah. I'm not sure though. I I literally don't know what
a woman's claiming or I haven't watched the documentary. So yeah,
you'd have to listen to more cuz she does say in captivity is
in once they took them into Gaza or whatever. So like what is
going on? Why are there This is like two now where it could have
just been the clips, but it's like included
Destiny, but he has like no real commentary that's necessary
for the clip. Oh, I mean to begin with, that was a post. Why
couldn't he get the Reddit post or the I've absolutely noticed
I've absolutely noticed that for a bunch of these. I think this
was a thing that I pointed out I pointed this out to Queen. I
don't really talk about it on stream because it seems kind of
skitso, but I do believe people were farming um these clips from
LSF just like running the clips through Destin like basically
like trying to farm them from Destiny even when he wouldn't comment
just so they could get like Destiny further pushed up on the
board like farming the uh Ethan Hassan Destiny stuff the the
Ethan versus Hassan stuff farming like anti Denim's clips anti
whoever clips right yeah that's basically I mean I
got it clips and stuff were just pushing
uh a bunch of content out of his so that if people like name
search him, it's going to be just a whole bunch of irrelevant
clips and videos and stuff like that and Reddit post and like
anything that might be like controversial, let's say. It would
be like harder to instantly pop up. Manic says, "Destiny is already
pushed up as far as it can go." Also true. Unrelated, but also
true. So,
go ahead and watch the next clip. Uh for like those that makes
sense. It just doesn't make sense in this folder. Yeah, sure,
sure, sure. Sorry. Uh all my Why does Sherry have the M next
to her name? I'm actually not sure. Oh, I did that to go after
Kelly. I'll fix my nickname. One sec. Oh, served. And seeing
my brothers before the war and after the war, they became different
people. Uh
my my dad also has PTSD and it's very awful to see and seeing
him have to understand like what is okay and what's not okay
to do and you know society just says oh well you're not at war
this clip like actually gets so much better now godamn or just
get over it and he's got PTSD from those [__] congressional
trials okay them telling him this is not okay and he's like this
is how I grew up this is what I know and uh they come over and
they they have to relearn that they're safe. Now they have to
relearn that they're safe. What does it mean? Your dad had to
relearn what was okay and what was not okay. Time you're at war
is you have to feel safe. Every second you have to take as a
blessing because at any time a mortar can drop next to you, near
you, your friends are dead. My dad was in the bathroom stall.
Okay, he was in the bathroom with one of his best friends brushing
his teeth. One second he's brushing his teeth in the stall. The
next second he doesn't know where he is. He can't hear. He can't
see. It's actually so [__] disgusting that Denims
would laugh and or mock Tone's storytelling ability. Okay. And
his friend is gone. As well as the majority of the flesh on his
legs as well as the entirety of his ear gone. Have you seen my
dad? He's pretty much half robot at this point in case you guys
don't know. He's pretty much half robot because a mortar hit
the bathroom where he was brushing his teeth and one of his best
friends. Okay. And to see some fat [__]
go live on the internet and say, "I hope they get PTSD."
What a horrible thing to say. And now it would be great if she
ever does show true remorse and say, "I apologize." That was
a moment of ignorance. She literally apologized. Stupid for me
to say. H would be great. But instead, all I've seen is her doubling
down.
She apologized, misunderstanding me. What a joke. Dude, these
people are such liars. Dude, these people are such disingenuous
liars. An absolute [__] joke. I think Froggen eventually
kind of sort of halfway apologized while justifying like way
later. Uh I think it was like the third I think she doubled down
twice on the PTSD comments and then she kind of apologized. I
don't remember the apology. I'm sure it was like a halfass apology.
I don't think anybody owes you a fullthroated apology. At most,
they just need like a quarter of their throat, but okay. Who
gives a about what Froen did anyway? She talks on the vets. That's
awesome. The military, the vets, that's funny. Uh protected class.
Troops are Yeah, I guess violation, but like holy, who cares?
I just I seriously
what ever happened to people actually being the victim of the
thing that they cry about? Remind me, did Tee go into the military
or it's literally just the fact that like he had family members
in the military. Um his so Tectone is a victim of these same
things because his dad's PTSD from the military is probably what
led to one the Teeone is epigenetically tied to and two the the
attempted murder or whatever when when Te's dad is that's the
PTSD right when Te's dad holds him down and says tell me why
you should why I shouldn't kill you right now that's probably
like military PTSD so Tecton's kind of a victim right no I can't
he almost died for American troops. I do not know I do not know
what came first of the egg in this situation. There are some
people who just want to so they join the military cuz they think
this is going to be the place where they can like legally kill.
There's some people who feel like they want to protect and want
to serve their country and they go into the military and end
up having to kill somebody.
So yeah. No. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Why rope? You're Are you talking about techone right now? He
tried to be a WWE wrestler and failed. also did steroids and
lost his hair in the process. There's no way you're talking about
tectone right now. Oh, dude. The MTF allegations become more
and more believable. Like, he did testosterone, so he lost his
hairline. Oh, okay. All right. Interesting. Interesting.
No, that is pathetic. That is actually pathetic that he's going
to sit here cry like rivers
uh about veterans. FTM. Whoops. Sorry. You go ahead. cry about
veterans and the and the thing that he wanted to do was roleplay
fighting other men. Yeah. I mean, I think he just wanted to get
his head in a lot of crotches to be honest with you, but I'll
hit play. Disgusting. Mom, you dumb. Who's shielding from the
bomb vest? Well, we both have them strapped to our chest cuz
we're both Arabs. So, I think uh neither of us. Neither of us,
I guess. In a scenario like that, who would die first, me or
you?
I don't know. I think or would die at the same time. Mine wouldn't
go off. I I just I know it wouldn't go off. Do you think you
would die by proximity?
The the part of me would probably skimp out on like the part
of me would skimp out on the actual supplies for the bomb vest.
So, I think mine wouldn't work as well. That's insane.
So, I think I'm That's insane. Yours would go off first. You
know what I don't understand? Like I feel like whenever people
are like being being hated,
they're never original. Like I I want like original [__]
Okay. You call me You call me Hijab the Hut. Tech to
Why do I feel like I have not heard that before? But I should
have. Hijaba the Hut. Why? That's like the most obvious thing.
I just I feel like I've not heard it. What the [__]
He's an ugly [__] freak that got caught liking Loi.
I know. It must have been said in my chat at some point.
All right. I'm going to be offended by an ugly bald that's the
voice that likes Loi. Right. Okay.
Can't sleep at night because of that. Keemstar,
a a known predator,
dates girls that are closer to age to his daughter than him.
Oh my god. I can't sleep by night. The great thing is I don't
know why she's taking shots at Keemstar, but that's fine. I can
walk past the school with no thoughts. Well, I think he was tweeting
about her a lot, too. Uh after the Oh, the vet stuffed him off,
too. Has to control himself. Yeah. As a school with no thoughts
and Keemstar has to control himself. And then Ethan Klein. I
have no words. I have no words for Ethan Klein.
Uh that's anti-Semitic. His existence just speaks. Yeah, that's
absolutely I can sense it. I can tell Ethan Klein is evil by
virtue of his genetics of his birth. Okay. It's obvious what
Frogan's saying here.
I have nothing to say about him. You know, Hila poor shamed me
yesterday. What? Hila poor shamed me yesterday. Hila looks like
she I That's insane. I'm not I'm not going to go. I'm not going
to do that. I'm not going to attack the poor. I just I'm not
going to do that. I'm not going to attack the disabled. I I just
won't do it. Has ever seen the red bar bit? Has seen the bar
needs to see the red bar bit? Cherry needs to see the red do
you know the red bar bit? Would he look? Did you watch this with
us? Was she No. Wait. Red Bar obsessively hates her. Is it the
aerobics thing? Yeah. Okay. I thought you might have seen it
with us. Yeah. No. Pull it up. I don't remember. Red Bar Radio
Hila compilation. If you ever think to start maybe the funniest
one was when that that lefty go fumidor account on on Twitter
posted a compilation of red bar clips making fun of healer and
the very end of like this 3minute compilation of red bar clips.
It's just the one where he says he's like zooming in on Ethan
healer's faces. He's going listen you know if you saw a thousand
of those come over the hill you know you might you might retreat
and come up with a plan for Germany. Yeah, I'm not saying it
makes it right, but
that's not funny. That's not flavor.